and it's all
[Music]
right
everything is all
[Applause]
[Music]
right
everything is
all
[Music]
right
it's all
[Music]
right and it's
all it's all
[Music]
right and it's all
right
[Music]
he
oh
[Music]
n
he
[Music]
n
oh
[Music]
w
he
[Music]
n
welcome back to the games s stage here
at E3 2017 joining myself and tomor here
today talk about Call of Duty World War
II is Michael condre who's a co-founder
of Sledgehammer Games Michael thank you
so much for joining us thank you for
having me uh how was your show going so
far oh it is amazing I mean 3 years in
development we get to share what we've
been working on with fans it's been
fantastic reception's been great we
couldn't be more excited right um one of
the interesting things about you as a
studio is like you came in when Call of
Duty was really popular and you provided
this you're you know the third studio so
you're kind of the New Kids on the Call
of Duty block but now you've been tsed
with kind of changing Call of Duty in a
quite a drastic away from what it has
been for the past few years how do it
feel to go from being the new kid on the
Block to like redefining Call of Duty
again it's been an incredible journey
and you're right we turn eight
Sledgehammer Games turns eight this year
yeah it's been nearly a decade since
Call of Duty's been at World War II so
for us the chance to take it back to its
roots to take a beloved franchise back
to where it began it's a real honor for
Sledgehammer Games and yeah we are the
newest of the lead Studios but we've
done modern we did Advanced and now
we're back back to boots on the ground
right and why did you obviously a lot of
people are going to wonder what decid
what was the deciding factor in going
back to World War II I mean it's a lot
of people will say it's the trend now
but there must be something more than
everyone wants it or everyone is doing
it now to you guys that made you decide
we should go back to the roots of it was
it kind of an attempt to refocus on what
Call of Duty was when it started yeah
you know we we really enjoy the
interaction with fans I mean it fans are
Paramount to what we do and coming out
of Modern Warfare it was clear it was
all about innovation they wanted a new
way to play Call of Duty and that was
really the inspiration for advanced
warfare and we brought a lot of
innovation to Advanced Warfare with the
New Movement set and the EXO and all
those things and our relationship with
the fans continued and it was clear
there was an opportunity to then bring
it back to boots on the ground which is
strategic and fast-paced and grounded
but rooted in a cause that's really
remarkable and we hadn't touched in a
decade so it's really that engagement
with fans that has led us to to this
game so going back from so obviously
like in in modern Call of Duties like
the the movement has been you know that
much more you can reach that much higher
going back to as you say boots on the
ground how are you going to sort of make
that like the new standard for Call of
Duty I guess after reaching the sort of
mechanical heights yeah well you know
fan reception here at E3 has been
fantastic and I think we've captured
what makes multiplayer great you know
it's grounded it's strategic it's
fast-paced it's got arsenal of World War
II weapons and iconic locations so for
us it feels like what made Call of Duty
great and you're seeing some stuff here
on screen from multiplayer where it's
really about that experience of you and
your squad in this gritty and intense uh
World War II conflict so it feels right
and um for us we couldn't be more proud
of bringing this this year um especially
coming off of the games we did in the
past yeah yeah you've obviously had play
testing going on and that kind of stuff
from your experience has it have you
seen people kind of R needing to retrain
themselves a bit cuz I mean I'm someone
who plays you know the modern Call of
Duty's Titan Fall and all these other
like law Breakers that kind of stuff
it's a very kinetic momentum based
you're doing way more like it's almost
like you're you're playing the piano
with along the controller or something
so like the idea of playing a Call of
Duty that kind of strips all that way
all that way kind of makes me think I
might need to relearn some of the
simplicities or like take it easier
again so has you have you seen that
happen with play testing and yourself
like is there a learning curve to going
backwards to almost you know it's it's
really natural and it feels very
strategic you know the the game play
feels like Call of Duty but what we love
is it's
strategic uh threat identification and
Lanes make sense when it's rooted on the
ground and so we pick it up I don't know
maybe it's like getting on a bike again
it just feels really natural I guess it
helps that there's a lot of like classic
firstperson shooter games that are still
very popular on the PC and and and stuff
like simple games like for example play
around on Battlegrounds it's
mechanically quite simple it doesn't
have any of that movement stuff people
are really into that at the moment so
that must be quite exciting for you guys
to be in that moment as well yeah you
know look we we couldn't have made this
game on the consoles 10 years ago
there's a lot of innovation here this
the consoles are so powerful today so
we've got a ton of Innovations we've
never seen before in World War II like
our new war mode and divisions and
headquarters all these things that are a
first but that feeling of that grounded
Call of Duty action that we've all loved
for more than a decade it feels right
right it must help you kind of does it
help you tell a more focused story as
well because obviously with the previous
games they kind of they're all over the
place they've become like Michael Bay
style you know explosive you're leaping
around and doing crazy things that and
it's hard to keep track of a story and
characters and that kind of scenario cuz
you're just being wowed by the spectacle
of it all instead so has this allowed
you to kind of tell a more focused story
and a more a story that will resonate
with people perhaps in a way that you
know classic Call of Duties did and
maybe in a way that for example Call of
Duty for did yeah each of the games
we've made in Call of Duty has had its
own creative Challenge and
opportunity this one with the the canvas
of World War II and the backdrop of the
world's deadliest conflict it's powerful
it's a powerful story it's a moment in
human history and inflection where
really the the planet was on the brink
of tyranny right and so you have to
provide entertainment that fans are
going to have fun with and we've done
that but you also have to be respectful
of the cause of the sacrifice of what
really happened at that time so that
balance actually has been something that
the studio has really embraced to honor
and respect the the sacrifices of World
War II and you'll have those big moments
there'll be those opportunities to
really showcase some of the most
destructive battles in World War II but
there's this intensely personal moments
World War II that I think will will
shine in the in the their own way too so
you mentioned these personal moments and
it's going to be like you and your squad
how have you so I mean a lot of the
times you can play any type of game and
if you have like an AI companion you
might not necessarily be that inclined
to you know form a relationship with
them or they might be a hindrance I mean
games like uh bioch truck in for example
you had Elizabeth as your AI companion
but she was useful and like she would
give you things are you kind of
following that to kind of work a
relationship with the with your squad or
is it more like the is going to be a
real impactful personal story there too
yeah we really want you to connect with
this squad so you follow the squad of
the first infantry division now the
first Infantry Division was 15,000
troops and you're following a small
group with red Daniels as the leader of
that group an original story coming out
Sledgehammer Games for World War II
based on real world events but we really
want you to feel the struggle you know
the success the loss along the way
you'll meet a a glob Global and diverse
cast you'll connect with um rouso who's
a strong female leader of the French
Resistance but our hope is that that
Squad Daniels and others really you
connect with and the narrative team
spent a lot of time really trying to
bring that to life right how do you guys
obviously you mentioned it briefly there
but it's kind of like really piqu my
interest like balancing the idea of
creating a game for entertainment with
also exploring the war um and cuz there
are obviously there's a big discussion
about all the different atrocities that
happened during that war and how games
traditionally have tried to skirt around
them but you've said in the past that
it's you're going to try and go to some
Dark Places and you need to do that in
order to be respectful of the war itself
um and the sacrifices that were made so
can you talk a bit bit about how you
kind of approached that from from an
entertainment perspective as well as a
storytelling perspective yeah I'm glad
you asked I mean that's a really complex
question trying to deliver on the
authenticity of the war and you're right
I mean upwards of 100 million people
perished in this war worst atrocities in
human history so there's the
authenticity of the war that we want to
deliver but we also have to be very
respectful of the people who lost their
lives and sacrificed and we struggle on
that from everything around Nazi
iconography in the game um including the
swastika yeah and so with our military
historian and a lot of focus on the
studio we are trying to find that
balance and you'll see the swastika in
in um parts of the narrative parts of
the campaign not in multiplayer and
zombies because that's a global
community and there's Regional laws that
we have to respect um but I tell you we
went literally to the the footsteps we
sat in Normandy we went to Germany and
France we saw these battle locations
stood in the fox holes that they're
still here today and when you when you
invest in that level of
research it sort of imparts a Prof found
respect for what happened so it is
entertainment and it's also um telling
the story of the world's greediest War
but it must also be a tremendous amount
of pressure to sort of
respect the events of what happened and
the memories of people who died
absolutely and you know when this
started it was for us about telling the
story so it could never happen again
right so this atrocity and this you know
World on the brink of tyranny moment
which can't let that happen again and
it's in some ways faded from human
consciousness right it's a war that's 80
years ago um but as we Dove deeper and
we talk to the veterans and we research
we realize that most of the people that
fought in that battle they're not here
today so they're not here to tell them
stories themselves and so I think
respect and honor is really what
probably the two words that come most to
mind in how we've treated this this
creative in a similar vein how did you
approach introducing not introduc but
having a fan favorite mode like zombies
because you've got this like I know why
you did it of course and I'm I'm a fan
of that mode so like but it's got to be
had been a discussion where like we're
trying to be faithful to this world war
thing how do we introduce something that
we know everyone wants and will'll enjoy
but we don't want to create this
perception where we're taking the rest
of it lightly by introducing this fun
mode that's all about zombies and and so
how did you approach that yeah you know
each of the modes sort of has their own
uh Creative Drive and priorities and
campaign is really about delivering that
authenticity and that deeply personal
story multiplayer is very social and
competitive and there are some Liberties
there and and you're right Nazi Zombies
Return of Nazi zombies we can't sit here
and say that there's authenticity to
that right um and nor do fans really
want that right like this is a creative
Outlet now it's rooted on where the
franchise began you know zombies and
Call of Duty started in Nazi zombies so
that's an honor for us and we get to put
a sledgehammer game stamp on that and
you know our our background with dead
space so it'll be an adrenaline fied
take on it um it's rooted in some
research we found about some of the
beliefs that that the Germans had about
excited
about Nazi oul uh Origins we have done
intense amount of research there you go
um we think it's going to be really fun
for fans to have that outlet um but
you're right the um the authenticity
doesn't quite apply to Nazi zombies it
does to the campaign cool uh one of the
other things you mentioned was war mode
which is something that's really
interesting me can you tell people about
what that is and kind of what your idea
behind was that was why you decided to
introduce something like that war Mode's
brand new game mode in multiplayer this
year first to Call of Duty and you know
three years ago we were talking about
this idea of how you really get the the
feeling of big war of squad-based
warfare which really was what World War
II was about it's not the Super Soldier
it's not the Lone Wolf experience it was
about group of common men and women
coming together to fight and so we
wanted to capture that and War mode is
our answer to that sort of creative
challenge it's axis versus Allied it's a
narrative driven asymmetrical experience
where you're really colliding on these
battlefronts that happened and you saw
some of that in the trailer um that we
released this week where you know the
first objective is to take the manor or
defend the manor or take the bridge
escort the tank protect the ammo dumps
and so this gives us that opportunity to
bring that conflict to life in a way
that really feels new and unique to Call
of Duty World War II and obviously it
has a a narrative element to it that do
you want players to focus more on the
story you're telling or is it about the
micro stories that happen within the
engagement that's really kind of selling
the narrative part of that mode yeah
it's more about grounding the conflict
in World War II and I think we're seeing
a little bit well this is multiplayer
point point to Hawk and Team Deathmatch
but you'll see that really the setup is
trying to make that feel like a true
conflict in World War II and these
moments where axis and Alli came
together to fight for the Strategic
positions was really what the war was
about and so you'll see in our war mode
that sort of narrative micro story if
you will grounding it in a way that's
really powerful right yeah cool uh let's
talk about your you have a new sort of
headquarters like a social space could
you tell us a little bit about that yeah
absolutely headquarters for Call of Duty
we think this is the biggest in in
multiplayer this year and it's a true
first for the
franchise for us you know if you if you
go back six years which is a long time
in game development at the beginning of
Advanced Warfare you were really just a
gamertag and a rank in multiplayer and
we saw an opportunity to bring your
character to life and really have you
invest in that that character Avatar and
we we delivered that and the virtual
Lobby gave you a chance to sort of show
off in a small setting and this is the
evolution of that this is taking you in
into a true space where your character
your investment your division
advancements and
customizations now have a place to live
48 players come together in this living
world where you can compete in new ways
like our 1 V one or shoot offs in the um
in the virtual firing range that now
becomes a living firing range you can be
rewarded be social peacock and show off
in ways that we know the community loves
to do so there'll be more to see on
headquarters later at the beta but this
is a big one for us yeah that that seems
really interesting cuz one of the issues
that I had was like that first the loop
of it you know leveling up and unlocking
things it were I really loved it in the
first few like modern warfare and Modern
Warfare 2 and a few of the other games
but now I feel like I'm just kind of
running endlessly on a grind so that
seems like an interesting way of getting
people to re-engage with that kind of
loop again so it sounds encouraging it
really is and you know we talked a lot
about these moments that are super
important in your multiplayer
progression like prestiging and if you
think about it in the past prestiging is
there was very little Fanfare you did it
you know this was a moment in your
progression that really is like the
Pinnacle of your accomplishment and you
you hit a button at home by yourself and
you get a little celebratory thing you
do little Dan you've done it right now
in headquarters you get to go to what
we're in development terms calling
Prestige OverWatch where you go up on
the cliff above the whole headquarters
and you prestige in front of the whole
community and you celebrate and they get
to Cate with you right and that's how it
should be this is a moment in your
progression that's important and now we
give you a space to do that with your
friends and and other members of the
community that's cool uh one of the
things that I was really interested in
is um where you're getting your
influences and what you're looking to
obviously you have a lot of research
done and the real world is your primary
influence and your Source but you know
obviously it's hard not to make
connections to other types of media
stuff like bandab brother Saving Private
Ryan what are you looking to to kind of
thematically and aesthetically kind of
sell your game and present it to to
people you're right research really was
at the Corvette and everything from
going to museums in New Orleans a
remarkable World War II museum there or
the museum in Luxembourg which is
phenomenal these trips that we went on
with the military historian boots on the
ground actually there um that really is
the essence of it and you have to do
that to really understand the conflict
from a on the ground level no pun
intended um but there are also
Inspirations clearly from other points
of media like Saving Private Ryan right
now the crazy thing about sa Private
Ryan is it's 20 years old yeah I know it
doesn't seem like that's the reaction
you could make it today and it would be
it holds up really well maybe the most
iconic depiction of World War II in film
so for us yes films like saving priv
Ryan clearly um modern films like um I
don't know I guess Blackhawk Down had a
take on what war meant in a in a
different era but for us giving the
chance to give New Generation maybe
generation who's never seen Sav Private
Ryan or even ble Brothers which was 10
years ago or played Call of Duty that
hasn't been there in nearly a decade
this might be their first exposure so we
wanted to capture that in our own way so
would you go be as bold as to say you
want this to be the Saving Private Ryan
of the current gaming generation for
Absol absolutely I mean for people who
are coming back like you and me who've
played Call of Duty from the beginning
right we want this to feel really
powerful and new right and for people
who are playing it for the first time
time we hope that that we hope that
that's an experience that they will look
to now as their pop culture sort of
iconic experience in World War II
awesome it's an incredible amount of
pressure there as well though you're
sort of providing a a cultural and
historical touch point for a lot of
people yeah you're right and I'm so
thankful for the the team at
Sledgehammer Games everybody at
Activision because you know that
pressure it you can feel it and and
moments like this at E3 to celebrate
with fans that's a huge honor for us cuz
it kind of reinvigorates that that drive
but you're right this is a beloved
franchise and in many ways I think
about I don't know Abrams having a
chance to sort of put his stamp on Star
Wars beloved franchise that that has
existed for a very very long time in in
pop culture maybe that might be a bridge
too far I don't know but like that that
pressure that opportunity that um
experience for our studio is really
something we take to heart okay stepping
back a bit going back to the mechanical
level something just remembered you you
talked about um kind of going back to
roots and that means doing things like
removing crutches or gameplay facets of
Call of Duty that people are well
familiar with and his second nature
stuff like unlimited Sprint recovering
health so can you talk about the process
of reaching the decision to do that cuz
that's a big thing it's not just a Call
of Duty thing that's a that's a
fundamental design principle of the
genre now so how do you how do you go
about making the decision to roll that
back and has there were any discussions
that were there any discussions where
you're like we can't do this it's too
fundamental to what games of first
person shooters are now the great thing
about having three-year development
Cycles with Activision is you have the
time to really be ambitious and that
gives us time to be more Innovative and
more thoughtful in our approach and in
multiplayer specifically we wanted to
take that time to really look at every
part of the multiplayer experience
including progression and cre a class
which we've now sort of replaced with
Visions a a new but refined approach to
your soldier
career in campaign with the removal of
the autogenerating health system and
having that replaced with health packs
yeah that's a big step yeah now we feel
like it's absolutely the right decision
for World War II it was a different
conflict you weren't a tier one super
soldier of the future who had all the
tech and information you needed at your
hands and it feels right for us those
conversations we've had from day one and
and Frank L we're still having to make
sure that the things that make Call of
Duty great we preserve but the
experience feels right for the era I
guess I guess a a kind of change like
having to rely on your friends and your
squadmates to help you through battles
kind of reinforces the narrative that
you're trying to deliver as well right
absolutely and you asked about
inspiration and I'll be honest I love
band brothers and a lot of those
episodes were really talking about how
these impactful characters like the
medic
really brought that Squad together and
kept them alive and we want to capture
that in our experience as well okay cool
uh one of the things I was interested in
is how have you seen the has the pacing
of multiplayer changed cuz current
modern day Call of Duty it's like it's
very you're dying quickly and respawning
and have you seen people kind of be a
little more cautious in the way they
approach multi player now cuz we live in
you know the current state of Call of
Duty is like you run straight in good
chance that if you see someone you can
back flip out the way or slide out of
the way or leap across a building or
something like that yeah exactly now you
have a Call of Duty where that's
impossible you can't do these crazy
things have you seen people kind of like
has the pace of multiplayer slowed down
somewhat you know it's a great question
the fast sort of gun- onun action that's
really grounded in Call of Duty fans
want that and we want to deliver it but
with these iconic weapons and these real
signature weapons from World War II the
engagements are very different whether
you're running a a trench gun shoty in a
small map like point to Hawk which you
saw or you're a
sniper there is a different sort of
approach to it now it's fast and it's
frenetic and it and it delivers on
everything we love about Call of Duty
multiplayer and we've built maps that
specifically tailored to different play
Styles so you you get a more of a
breadth of play style and divisions
leads in that that too so I guess the
short answer is it captures that that
grounded fast action multiplayer
experience but there is new Strate that
really is important to how you play
right how does that I don't know if
you've discussed your Ambitions for it
but how does that fit into kind of like
the professional competitive scene
because obviously even even the kind of
thematic and the way the you know
professional Call of Duty league is sold
is about fast it's almost like American
football style like really hooa and this
kind of like high energy kind of kind of
uh presentation to it all and that kind
of fits with the frenetic nature of
current Call of Duty um have you thought
about how your kind of slower paced more
boots on the ground and realistic Call
of Duty impacts that and do you think
that the scene will kind of take to that
they're used to doing a lot and showing
off that they're the best at leaping
around and that kind of stuff so this
might be kind of a very different change
to you expect it to kind of shift the
way Esports happens around Call of Duty
yeah we have a lot of Esports
announcements coming later this this
summer um as you know from our studio
and and Activision there's a big
investment in orts and we love engaging
with the players early and I can tell
you they are going to love this
experience and really a lot of it is
because the strategy of being on the
ground again and mastering the maps and
really focusing on your ability with
your arsenal of weapons is what they
want and I think they're going to go
bananas for this one we're already
seeing it at the event there's been a
lot of influencers who come in and
played with us and given us great
feedback I think fans are going to be
able to give us feedback at the beta
that's coming later this summer too so I
think by the time we get to the Esports
season right it's going to feel great
okay cool um and final question I think
what do you want this what do you want
Call of Duty World War II to be
remembered for wow that's a powerful
question one to end on well I think you
know Sledgehammer Games you know we talk
about this commitment to Excellence and
to Quality and I hope if players are
campaign players or zombie players or
multiplayer players or maybe they play
all of it um they'll appreciate the
commitment from the studio to deliver
quality for the
experience and bigger than that I hope
that people really feel the respect and
honor that we have brought to try and um
you know frankly bring World War II to
Consciousness in a respectful way okay
cool well Michael thank you so much for
joining us pleas an absolute pleasure
can't wait to play um for more from this
year's E3 make sure you don't go
anywhere we'll be talking about
matterall in just a few short minutes so
we'll see you
then
found
[Music]
oh
you
[Music]
B
hi everyone and welcome back to the game
s stage here at E3 2017 joining joining
tomorrow and I is Yari from housemark
hello welcome real to be here and you're
going to be showing us matterall yeah so
yeah I mean let's Jump Right In uh
double jump right in what I see on the
screen yeah we on tutorial now yeah so I
mean what's what's the basic premise so
basic premise is in each court
matterfall is a twin stick shooter but
we added lot of elements from from like
platformer games and bullet H games it's
like combination of lots of genres right
so this these kind of AR style games are
completely Your Studios Jam like you
this is what you kind of specialize in I
really like how you guys are kind of
mixing up the formula because you know
you've had ship Shooters and now you're
doing this what were kind of your key
Inspirations for this game I'm seeing
this and I'm looking I'm thinking of you
know Metroid and that kind of stuff yeah
yeah Metroid and like tan and like
Contra and run and gun games like gunar
Heroes and like of course like buetel
games like like radant silver gun and
like that quite old school inspiration
right so what's the what's the story so
how how is all of this able to happen
basically about the game story yeah yeah
your players you play as a Avalon daro
hired mercenary whose job is to clear
out the city about the evil red matter
so basically the city has has been built
up like this blue matter and it got
corrupt corrupted and took took like
those you can see those red enemies
there so basically your job is to clear
them okay and save all the civilians
from the from the levels so can you
manipulate the blue matter you have to
destroy the red yeah you can actually
create like platforms out of blue matter
and use that like your advantage like
build up Shields and like better
platform right see this the color stuff
um is just reminding me of ikaruga quite
a bit so did you play a lot of that to
kind of yeah of course and our like
former game like Outland was was based
onity mechanic oh man I love Outland so
much what a great game bring that
back but yeah so can you talk about
briefly about the mechanics that you
kind of got going here cuz you're a very
mechanic heavy stud yeah yeah mechanic
heavy Yeah so basically you you are this
is like a shooter you you shoot with
like a right stick and then we have like
lots of like secondary weapons like this
grenade that we are using here uh and
then we have the smatter gun that
smatter jet that we just used to explode
those bombs there right and you can
choose uh up to three different
augmentation they can be like passive
augmentation they can be the weapons but
you can switch at threee okay cool and
what kind of augmentations are available
to you what they allow what do they
allow you to do yeah so basically the
weapons are you have this homing weapon
called seeker and poers shot that is
like basically a piercing weapon and
then basic shotgun and the grenade
launcher okay yeah and the passive
augmentations are like they are
increasing your like Dash explosion and
you can trigger different stuff and get
extra health and better reloads for your
secondary fires so there's like lots of
combination that you can try yeah and
obviously movement is a big part of it
you have the ability to kind of change
the way you kind of get around yeah well
you have the basic double jump then but
then we have this core mechanic called
strike that you can basically strike
everywhere like you just saw the
Striking through blue matter so
basically the strike is your like part
of your core movement you can stun
enemies with it and kill enemies easily
and that's what we're seeing there it's
like a head on Dash style thing B
basically you want to the player use the
strike as a offensive move right it's
like you you're basically turning this
bit here you're turning the character
into almost like a ship when it goes
back to Res floating around and yeah
yeah that's really cool yeah and with
with the strike you can destroy all the
bullets and yeah right right and uh what
about how does the progression work in
this game is it like a level by level
thing it's a level by level and when you
save the civilians you get the
augmentations so basically explore the
levels and get the highest score but
there but there's no like overarching
world that you're moving between level
it's just like one after the other yeah
one after the other okay cool and I
guess that allows you to do crazy things
with like theme and way build levels
yeah we have we have like we three
different teams we have the city that we
are currently in then we have the second
level is coming it's Hydroponics it's a
that's a plant grow Place yeah with lots
of like environment effect FKS and stuff
right it's interesting uh throughout
play testing have there been
combinations that you maybe haven't
anticipated that people would come up
with yeah there there there are yeah
because the different augmentations when
you put them together
you get totally different game playay so
so there been been lots of like tuning
to get them get them right so one of the
things that I'm noticing here is your
games are often the longevity in them
comes through the score chasing and that
kind of stuff how have you introduced
that element of it into this game so so
basically uh to get the highest score
you need to use the overcharge mechanic
that we have so every enemy that you
kill drop these blue orbs when you
collect them you can activate overcharge
okay and that means that time slows down
and you can kill the enemies faster so
you get the a higher higher score so you
just need to know when to use that okay
and you anticipate that's going to be
what people will be score chasing with
yeah if you want to get the highest
score you need to know how to use that
okay cool is there any sort of
multiplayer component no single player
only single player only but you have the
leaderboards to sort of yeah leader
boards for yeah for like they're like
Global leader boards okay cool that's
interesting so are we moving on to
another area of the game level this is
the Hydroponics Hydroponics okay so what
to deal with this level so how does this
fit into the the story of the game yeah
basically this is a the place where the
O oxygen is made made for the like the
city so basically this is like layer
City you have first in the city then you
are on the Hydroponics level and the
third place is the like mines all all
like underground okay cool I mean just
looking at it it's um got an astonishing
number of particle effects and I mean
you guys love your particle effect you
guys do love your particle effects was
this more or less of a challenge than in
previous games cuz it just seems like
there's so much more going on yeah yeah
getting the clarity right is was was was
a big job so you can put some particles
in but if you don't know what's going to
happen what's happening in the screen so
that that that was a big challenge I
guess yeah that comes it must be
interesting to try and balance that with
the design of a bullet shooter style
element because those games are all
about overwhelming you and trying to
give you making you find the small break
and all the how did you kind of balance
feeling like a a bullet hell shooter but
also making sure the clarity is there
and yeah it it was just dry and error
and lots of iteration right so getting
the color right getting the particle
amount right yeah okay interesting so do
you know how long this kind of how many
levels there are going to be in this
game or is it something we still tuning
tuning the difficulty and the the level
so we are not yet announcing the level
okay cool is there just one difficulty
level or can you there's three different
difficulty levels like basically easy
medium hard but when you finish the game
we unlock this insane mode that okay
then you have one bar of health and
revenge bullet for every enemy right wow
so it's a super hard mode okay yeah that
sounds that sounds like something I'll
never play but I'm glad you have it in
there for people who care the hardcore
player yeah so have you thought about um
whether people like in the speedr
running Community are going to be
interested in this it seems like a very
speedrunnable game yeah this is
speedrunnable game and all the levels
are built for speedr running okay but
you can basically just Dash through
everything and try to kill everything on
your way right and the fastest time on
the level this cool I love the way this
the side on kind of like games look like
this um it's reminding me of that what's
that Microsoft Shadow complex a lot
quite a bit um so I'm seeing it um yeah
it looks super active I love the kind of
feeling so you you you guys are kind of
big into making sure bullet impact and
that kind of stuff is is is kind of like
really felt how have you kind of
approached that in this game it's easy
to do with like a ship but it's a little
more tricky when you've got multiple
things blowing up and you've got like G
need to have like good effect good
feedback on everything
all the like bullet hits needs to be
shown and yeah when you get the damage
you that it's it's just about the
feedback right right okay cool it
correct so basically there we can see
the civilian now on the purple Crystal
when you save that you get the reward so
basically you get the augmentation from
from to right and so is that kind of
like the end of the stage once you find
civilian or does it like they hidden
around yeah so okay basically you have
to find them to get the right so now we
have the Seeker weapon right o yeah how
so how long is is each level roughly I
think that first level was about five
minutes but I mean yeah basic level is
about 15 to 2 five minutes yeah so I
mean like how do you balance um you know
giving players a a good amount of
content in one level with like intensity
right because it's it looks incredibly
intense so how do you kind of make sure
that players don't I mean burn out maybe
not the right word but don't become over
burden yeah yeah well we have a like
smaller moments and then we have these
moments where like enemies coming all
around so we are trying to balance that
that putting some like high intense
moments into levels but then like just
like basic platforming sections also so
you're you're not constantly shooting
everything right it's interesting you
you we're seeing the uh player creating
platforms there is it always defined
where the platforms are yeah okay cool
and but you don't have to use them they
are usually you you can like set up a
different rotes with them so right
basically you can just skip them or use
them as the shield right okay so it's
more about you can use them
strategically toally create a war
between you and all the bullets and that
kind of stuff okay is there any kind of
like puzzle solving element to this or
are you trying to maintain forward
momentum which yeah really streamlined
action okay cool that's interesting is
that the same for uh kind of like the
platforming elements of it because B
basically what we can soon see is that
that we have like conoyer belts and
stuff like that like basic platforming
elements that give us the flavor for the
level right okay cool this cool wow
Stargate yeah yeah
Stargate yeah right and so are they like
Boss characters cuz I'm not seen any so
far like little Demi boss yeah we have
these like bigger enemies that we that's
the shal guy what that we saw and the
bigger spider but then we have like
three different bosses that are like
huge bosses okay so each each team has
their own boss boss fight right okay and
is this exclusively for the PlayStation
yeah exclusively play dang no VA version
no oh man my PO what's going
on see look I I was looking at this and
thinking I'm really going to enjoy
playing this on my v and then I
remembered oh wait a second if it exist
yeah that's that's unfortunate but yeah
yeah there's the red matter that is like
a crystal that's the corrupted matter
right okay so your your role is to get
rid of that essenti yeah get rid of that
avoid that and Destroy these red matter
enemies okay so and we're seeing like uh
enemies explode into a lot of these kind
of little particle things that just is
that just an effect or is that something
that you'll be able to like use in terms
of gameplay yeah it's just effect and
basically react to player is just for
the like eye candy right okay yeah we're
always on board
of Cy looks cool what we seeing here now
yeah different types of enemies you've
got here so it look like enemies so uh
what kind of different types of enemies
do you have so this one looks like a
quite a defensive one which requires you
to get yeah you cannot shoot it front it
because it has the shield so you can
utilize like the grenades that bounce or
jump in the back oh wow yeah go there
you see it okay okay so you're building
so how how do you how are the kind of
enemies plac is this something that
you've kind of designed an algorithm to
take care of are you kind of hand
placing hand hand placed and then we
have this like spawning system like you
can see here those arade enemies they
are like triggered by spawns okay yeah
and then we have it the persistent
enemies that are hand be the hand place
on the levels that that must make tuning
the game quite difficult cuz you're
never quite sure you have this like
random element to it so is there worry
that there's a part of the game
somewhere that just is incredibly
difficult that you don't know about we
we've been tuned this game like on
Perfection So Okay cool so yeah how long
have you been working on it yeah two
years now wow with the team size of
maximum of 20 people 20 people yeah wow
okay cool is this is this the only game
in development at the studio or are you
kind of working on other things Yeah we
actually have the next MAA coming up
okay oh yeah yeah of course next ma yeah
that's
interesting wow so there's the cor boyor
belts and stuff all right so that's the
kind of like platforming stuff yeah so
it looks very much like classic bullet
ho Shooters where it's trying to
overwhelm you but not too much giving
you enough to kind of balance together
platforming and and kind of escaping
through hails of
bullet and that's another is there an OP
can you like miss a lot of um these
civilians well you can but we we have
like sound effect and hard elements
popping when you're near the civilian so
so we want you to find them but they are
usually and behind of some kind of
challenge so they are not like the
golden path so is it possible to kind of
return to a level and pick up because of
the Miss civilian and you always know
you can see on the H on the right top
right corner that how many civilians you
right right reminds me of um saving the
teensies yeah in like Ray man Origins
the te is going help me what are those
things that he's picking up cuz it looks
like pies but I'm assuming it's not pies
Pi uh you mean those blue orbs uh yeah
the the orange orbs that were kind of
floating around uh or or oh yeah oh I
guess there were enemies then yeah there
was enemies that were like
right they look like pies me he was just
running at them so I was
like P P yeah I'm sure you can go back
to the studio and can we change these to
pies now please because so this is the
like the classical bullet place that
right there's lots of enemies lots of
bullets so this really like you need to
know what you're doing here and and
you've got a strict Health System where
it's like it's not covering is it is it
no no you you collect like Health orbs
that enemies will drop okay and what
what's the blue bar underneath the
health yeah it's the overcharge bar so
when you collect those blue orbs and it
gets fed you can activate the overcharge
yeah and every time he dashes it sounds
out like a shock wave is that's explos
that's explosion it runs the enemies
destroys the bullets uh and it's just
the easier way to get round right so you
have to actually take a risk and dash at
yeah yeah basically Dash to the enemies
so in it score when in D to use the dash
okay so it works as a defensive and
offensive kind of like thing okay that's
really Dodge but we uh it's better that
you dash straight to the enemies get in
close and then finish it with the guns
and is this is there any kind of like
chain combo system I'm not maybe like
well no not basically but what we are
going on the score mechanic that you
need to kill enemies fast when they
activate be fast on the killing you get
higher score when you're killing them
fast right and is it like multipliers
and yeah multipliers there are okay cool
that looks cool so each difficulty has
their own multiplier so if you want to
have the best score you need to B with
the highest difficulty right okay cool
what's been the biggest challenge in
bringing matal to reality yeah cuz
you've had a lot of experience with the
PlayStation 4 now so you must have been
yeah on this game maybe maybe def
finding the fun that because we have
lots of elements we have the platforming
we have bullet cells and so getting it
to feel right that yeah it was like
under lots of tuning right and I guess
it must be difficult there must be some
sort of like thought about maybe people
won't respond to every element of the
game cuz some people like platforming
some people aren't bullet Hill fans
bullet Hills are quite a niche genre and
it can be quite stressful to play them
so have you thought about what how you
kind of present that and balance that
for people who don't like every element
of it yeah that's why the levels are
like usually SE like there's multiple
sections so you are not constantly
getting the same thing so it's not
constantly the bullet HS and constantly
the platforming it's like mix of mix of
those elements okay where are we going
to now now we are going to the first
boss okay okay so this is this is one of
the big buses yeah this is the big buses
okay
cool it's a wasp so I'm already don't
like this one
bit is there a reason that the enemies
seem to be very insect focused I mean
yeah it's it's where we draw the
inspiration so they they look like
mening and who who likes insects so yeah
cuz insects suck that's why everyone
hates insects there's no one out there
that enjoys seeing a wasp soed I don't
in real life they are usually the best
episodes of like planet Earth yeah I
mean there's no good scenario where
someone's happy I'm fan of insects yeah
yeah exactly so you are a fan of insects
then no not F no no there got to be
someone at the team if you're doing this
over and over again but yeah yeah so so
so this boss battle looks like a lot of
um P recognition and classic boss yeah
classic like classic boss boss design so
basically you have to utilize your
jumping here your dasing here and all
the movement right and I guess all the
bosses will be similarly do they kind of
they are different yeah yeah so each
team has like Own Boss and it should
feel like it belongs to that team so
right yeah do they kind of as you go
along account for cuz all of these
bosses are designed to challenge your
Mastery of movement and shooting that
kind of stuff but you have the
opportunity to change some of that the
way you you know the way you upgrade and
kind of progress so the boss is going
forward kind of account that you may
have a different style of play and try
and challenge that as well or is it like
the fundamentals of being yeah it's a
fundamentals so okay yeah okay cool Bas
basically you can try different kind of
augmentation Combos and see what's
worked with the best with these okay
cool this was is looks like he's
stressing me out without the amount of
bullets like I'm already like I bullets
lots of striking yeah this is
cool yeah yeah all right oh wow is that
it oh no no about okay so that
multiphases and that kind of stuff okay
I thought I was I was going to say
that's easy guys you need to maybe
I mean our our friend over there demoing
it is probably an expert at this so so
playing yeah so we are seeing Master at
his work right right no pressure no
pressure yeah exactly wow so the game
runs actually on 60 frame per second
right yeah and okay on base PS4 or just
PS4 Pro with both both yeah and with PS
Pro we have like a better higher
resolution high resolution yeah and
better like environment effect and
increase particle count right but the
gameplay experience is the same yeah
right and this a game that you intend on
kind of uh supporting for a while with
extra content and that kind of stuff
currently we have no Blast for DLC so
you're building as a fully form yeah
yeah it's a fully formed games that you
can play from start to finish okay cool
that's interesting it's getting a bit
busy now and yeah it's stressing me out
stressing you yeah it's all the
particles like I think you guys need to
relax on the particles cuz it's it's
freaking me out yeah
right and he's gone no he's back I keep
see that the health bar is just
underneath the table so I can't see it
like I have to stand up and be like all
right no he's still alive he's still
there that's cool I like the mix of kind
of like platforming and uh how it's kind
of diverting your attention away from
platforming at the same time as at the
same time as you know needing you to
actually attack the enemy those are the
things that get me and it's the and it's
the skill that you have to build to do
it remembering to shoot as well as as
yourself and I guess that's the kind of
a lot of your games are about that like
figuring out trying to access different
parts of your skill set and that that
was what reso gun really spoke to me it
was one of one of the first games on the
PS4 that I kind of got obsessed with it
was like it made me felt like I was
becoming a better gamer when I was
playing yeah you were learning by play
yeah I think the the skills that I
learned from playing reson have
transferred into many other games yeah
so I guess I think I can ow I owe my
OverWatch
abilities my abilities to hit things are
it's a training platform exactly why do
you think people um resonate with the
the leaderboard aspect so much because I
mean we have friends that just would be
like okay yeah other games coming out
but I'm going to I'm I'm still on resan
I'm still going to hit that I think it's
the competition feel that you can be
best at something and you you see your
progress and how you compare to other
players so as a as a Studio do you guys
foresee that you kind of you guys are
keeping like the classic arcade game
alive and obviously you're huge fans of
it but are you kind of like now we can
actually see a awesome explosion okay
good and it's the WASP dying so that's
perfect for me like do you guys
anticipate you carry on making these
that was that looked insane by the way
that was insane yeah so do you guys
anticipate your carry on making these
kind of arcade style games or are you
building up to something that's going to
be huge Triple A at some point well
let's let's see what's what's coming up
do you have an ambition to do that yeah
yeah yeah yeah okay well that'll be
interesting to see in the future then
yeah well thank you so much for joining
us when can we get our hands on mat yeah
August 15 on North America and August 16
on Europe lovely well thank you so much
for joining us thanks for having guys
don't go anywhere in a matter of moments
we're going to be having Metroid Samus
returns here on the gamesport stream
let's keep your eyes
[Music]
peeled
when I see the Sun
from it's all
right
yeah when I see the moon begin to
rise it's all
right everything is
[Music]
changes the journeys
beond the time that we are Tak so
[Music]
much to
do it's all
[Music]
right it's
all well it's
[Music]
all and it's
all
[Music]
he
everything is all
[Applause]
[Music]
right everything
is
[Music]
it's all all
right and it's
[Music]
all it's
all and it's all
[Music]
right
n
[Music]
hello everyone welcome back to the
GameSpot e32 17 2017 stage it's a good
start joining myself and tomorrow is
Daniel orella from Nintendo Treehouse
Lord and Master of the tree house no
master of the Tre house don't say that
that would be horrible title to have yes
uh here bringing us uh Metroid Samus
return Yes the new announced yesterday
for you
guys for Metroid fans as well it was
after years of complaining about no
Metroid you came out with two of them
two it's true hey you guys stop
complaining
we've got an old one and a new one so
yeah so this is a remake yeah this is a
remake of the original Game Boy game um
but a lot of bells and whistles been
added to it um they added a bunch of new
audio they added a really strong 3D
element to it that gives it a nice
vibrant feel to as you're going through
the game as well um and some new P new
abilities for Samus to add to her
Arsenal as well so interesting choice to
go to this game of all of them like
obviously they are a wealth of 2D
metroed games that you could have ch
chose to uh reimagine in some way some
people would have been like like super
metroid one of the greatest I think
greatest game of all time um why why not
that what was it about Metroid 2 and
return of Samus that you decided uh
that's a good question uh actually I'm
not the dev I mean there's so many
different games to look at I mean this
is one they particularly saw I mean such
an older game on the Game Boy like super
Metro you're bring already had color
going to a Game Boy game and really this
is it feels completely new when you take
the original game boy one now go to this
kind of level of detail and some
different moves and new additions so
it's probably why the dev shows that
direction but I mean it's better
question ask them Direction I'm sure
they had plenty of re they thought
debated many different options this is
why they went this one for many
different ways and you and you went with
Mercury steam an interesting choice of
developer you guys you guys tend to keep
Metroid development well I was going to
say you tend to keep it inhouse but like
you have experiment with going outside
with you know Other M and that kind of
stuff so what was it about Mercury steam
do you think that attracted Nintendo to
them they're just a partner they wanted
to work with for this time around I mean
there's they've they've done something
in the past before so just an
opportunity to do something different
creative with them um we like partnering
with them too yeah we definitely work
with work closely with developers
especially when it's using one of the
Nintendo IPS especially when it's
cherished as s so no I mean it's just an
opportunity and take advantage they've
done a great job with it so far I mean
I've had a chance to play it a little
bit myself and it just it feels great
playing on 3D and seeing the I know you
can't see the 3D here now but um even
the trailer itself you actually you can
download a Nintendo ehhop and you
actually can see the trailer in 3D um
which really helps this I know we're
only see in 2D right now um but it gives
you got a whole different vibrant life
too go through that as well so tell us
some of the you briefly on a bunch of
them but can we go a little bit in
deeper into what the new abilities s
sure yeah know a lot of things they
added to it um I mean a lot of people
might have played the game originally
and didn't really real like there's some
things like aiming is a big thing in
this one too now like Sam has the
ability to aim in 360 Degrees um like
there you can see that s Sarah's playing
for us by the way too but yeah she's
doing this whole 360 motion you guys and
even shows a targeting a targeting
aspect behind it and even lights up red
when you're actually hitting that enemy
oh nice um here's a cool new move you're
showing too is the melee counter as well
that Sams can now do when an enemy comes
flying at matter she is able to kind of
basic counter back and if you're being
able to shoot right away you can get a
critical hit out of it and it kills the
enemy almost instantly by doing that so
there's a lot of cool fun like that as
well so in terms of oh sorry I was going
to say presumably those those kind of
like these new abilities they they kind
update the game but it also kind of
introduced a challenge in cuz you know
Metroid has a very specific way of
providing challenges the limitations are
almost a challenge
to if you're able to do things like you
know aim everywhere does that has that
resulted in having a knock on effect in
how much of the game you have to
redesign cuz presumably you know you go
into a certain room and the old game you
could only fire forward or whatever it
was now they moving everywhere yeah
they're moving all directions yeah the I
mean the dev team took that into account
for sure when they remade this game is
that they wanted they wanted to add a
challenge for people who are familiar
with the game already but at the same
time they still want to make it
accessible for people who've never
played a Metroid game this might be
People's First Metroid game especially
for younger kids who would have no idea
what these games are and the challenge
behind that as well so they want to add
some other some additional abilities
like that like the melee counter um and
the 360 aiming which adds a lot too and
just the visuals um we get to some other
abilities in a little bit too that you
that Sam has as well beyond what she
normally has like right now like and
that's Al also bringing up too the
limitations is that's what's Samus is
known for that she's she's basically all
by herself on this planet um and she
basic she's has what's going on and her
Arsenal is always limited yeah so she
just to build up her Arsenal she goes
from there as well in terms of adding
new abilities um I guess how how have
mercury steam sort of worked with
Nintendo to sort of make sure that it's
an authentic thing that Samus would have
you know what I mean yeah know I mean
that's something they worked on just
when going through the whole design of
the game figuring out how it's going to
play and how that and how those new
abilities can add to gameplay elements
like the like the like the melee counter
um we'll get to some other abilities
called the Aon abilities as well which
show off in a little bit too which adds
something different to the game as well
and just gives it helps for different
parts of they can all be for different
portions like the melee Tech being more
defensive and how to fight different
enemies the A on abilities we get to
that too is more of a scanning ability
like scan pulse we'll get to that right
um kind of changes up in that direction
as well Okay cool so you've redesigned
Samus in quite some significant ways but
about the world around Samus is that
similar to the original version of the
game or it is similar the version but I
mean again that was all in just the old
school Game Boy screen of no color
involved so I mean just bringing all
that stuff to life is just something
different that people um got a chance to
experience uh when the Deb teams were
working when the Deb team was working on
this game play this all together so
people who have a considerable amount of
experience playing the original version
of the game perhaps may even KN off by
heart um they'll have a different kind
of experience here yeah for sure no I
mean they definitely wanted to they
wanted to make sure people who came back
to the game experienc a little bit of
different challenge the new the the
bosses which we kind of showed a little
bit in the trailer and those kind of
things like that we'll even get a chance
to fight one of the bosses soon here as
well right um so it'll be fun in that
aspect but yeah no that's what they're
having a lot of fun doing is building
all these different things and finding
all these aspects of Discovery and just
kind of having to explore the world in a
different way that you've never and
that's the thing as I said like Sam is
all by herself here just trying to
figure out what's going on um and trying
to to destroy the metroids okay which
look like some cute little cuddly
characters but they're not deadly as
yeah you want to
be are you going to step in there like
yes be careful of those metroids ex
except for that one baby Metroid of
course the baby V yeah but this is the
new ability right here that uh we're
about to get right now this is the the
Aon ability um so this is going to add
an element to the exploration as uh so
right now if if you shoot straight ahead
you don't know where you need to go like
by shooting Straight Ahead um the wall
will get to a second but yeah when you
start shooting at the the area right in
front of you um you won't be able to
destroy it so you have to figure out
what where do I need to go so there's
that little yellow meter that appeared
there that's the basically the energy of
the Aon abilities um those you be able
to get but that energy bar you those
little yellow spheres you got from
defeating enemies we keep refilling that
so now you can do a scan pulse and now
you can locate where you actually need
to go next to keep exploring oh
interesting that's that's quite a
significant change like a lot of a lot
of Metroid is about hitting a wall and
guessing and kind of having that's how
you learn the world right you kind of
you hit you you hit a dead end and
you're like well I guess I need to
re-examine everything that comes before
whereas if you have this ability now
it's kind of like you always know where
to go so that must have been an
discussion yeah I mean that's just
that's the thing you want to make the
game accessible to not just the hardcore
fans of people who never played it and
it's an ability you can choose to use it
or choose not to use it it's up to the
player to decide how they want to use
these things to take advantage of them
um and we have the map at the lower
screen too which you can even you can
even put markers on the map below too
remember location you haven't gone to
before so it's not like having to
memorize or Draw like when you were I
was a kid I remember drawing Maps I love
doing that M so you can find where you
need to go doing all those things as
well see this kind of drag and drop menu
screen here you can simply just add
where you want to put locations right
and remember where you wanted to go cuz
that's one I that's one thing you you to
remember from Samus from these games too
is that when you get these abilities you
have to go you have to go back and track
them you have to get the morph ball the
charge beam things like that yeah for
bombs as well so it's just a fun thing
to keep going in that direction it seems
that it's seems like smart additions to
it but as a longtime fan it's just it'll
take me a little time to get on board
with it cuz I'm like so used to having
this specific type of experience with
Metroid so this is kind of like I
welcome it yeah it's going to take some
time for me to get used to it what did I
tell you never never TR the Metro but
it's like uh it's the additions that
kind of make it bring it to the modern
day right because the way they play the
way the game is play games has changed a
lot I mean and it's nice that the game
is sort of being updated to refle that
but you can also choose to play it the
old way the way you want yes that's the
thing too you mean the gaming a has just
grown so much over the years I remember
when I was a kid I mean there's only
some people who play video games and now
they're trying to get the people who are
like the hardcore Gamers the more casual
gamers everyone has different feels to
it some people like playing for 20
minutes some people play for like 30
hour sessions and right so whatever
whatever works for each person going
through all that so yeah it's just a fun
experience in that way to keep having
fun with the game yeah and I guess it
helps kind of build samus's profile back
up again she's been gone for quite a
while gone for a so like having the
least amount of barriers to people
enjoying Samus and Metroid again would
be beneficial for future Metroid
projects I imagine you want to you want
to have people know the character and be
kind of like engaged with it and if you
have a incredibly old school Metroid
game that might be a bit difficult to do
no for sure and that's one thing I leave
like too even talk about the design like
Samus in this one looks a lot more like
the old schooler look more like what you
see in Smash Brothers than what you see
in Metroid Prime um which is cool and
even the amiibo reflects that as well
there are two new amiibo coming with one
is Sam in her more classic like on her
on her it's the cover art isn't it yeah
the cover art from that yeah it's was
really cool but then even the the other
amiibo is the the Metroid Metroid but
it's even
squishy squishy and a lot of people have
been checking out in the booth I I don't
buy a lot of amiibo cuz I know if I did
it would become a problem I'm buying I'm
buying that one for sure no we had a
moment when uh we were watching uh The
Treehouse yesterday where everyone was
like amiibo oh God cuz everyone just
sort of everyone just sort of felt their
wallets get a bit lighter pre-ordered
coming up I know I'm trying to pre-order
right now oh and actually here we're
fighting against boss this is one of the
first enemy the first kind of bosses
you're going to fight you have to figure
out how to defeat it oh well now we know
yeah thanks yes SP guys and Sarah's
actually really good at this so she's
able she basically quickly did the melee
counter went right to her missiles um
which hold on the AR uh the shoulder
button on the side and you're able to
then quickly see that um yeah yeah is
there any sort of like obviously one of
the big new Mechanics for Metroid since
Prime's introduction has been scanning
and kind of looking in your environment
and sure is there any sort of element of
that or was there a discussion about
maybe bringing that forward I mean
that's what the scan pulse kind of does
give that little bit of that aspect
there in the map of the lower screen cou
like that but yeah know you mean like
scanning H en behind it I'll have to
stay tuned and see what they add that
aspect for that um I know a lot of
people always at people always want to
know what is the story how tie do they
tie together in some how do the all the
all the Met TR games tie together in
some long story this is Sam's Grand
Adventure in told in many different ways
um so it's really just great to see how
that plays out and now he's got the
charge beam nice awesome so yeah that's
the thing too is you can quickly see the
Arsenal starting to build further in the
game uh which is just really fun for
just people to experience yeah but it's
it's like you're hitting them like very
quickly of get build very quickly and
like Master them is it is it going to be
like easy to play difficult to master
kind of or is it going to be like a
fairly balanced it's probably fairly
balanced I mean I have the game's not
it's not it's not released yet it'll be
coming out in September uh on the 15th
but yeah well that's everyone and that's
it's up to every player too at the same
time it's interesting like some players
are going to are going to take this and
find it they're going to basically
speedrun through the whole thing that's
their kind of their their skill set some
people I'm more of a completionist where
I'm going to want to find every little
Mil and craning on the map um and see
what else I can discover beyond that
even try to find all the secrets all the
energy tanks all the missile all the
missile uh inventory increases all those
things as well I'm a big fan of the uh
aiming animation when she she's aiming
behind her she just looks bored right
she's like I've I am too good for this
the cool thing too when you're aiming to
if you notice that the the when you're
aiming uh at enemies it actually turns
red right you get on that so you
actually know when you're going to hit
okay so when you're in line yes when
you're in line the line of Cu that was
yeah that was tricky with the games
where you could aim diagonally lining it
up and then shuffling forward a bit just
to hit him and enemies were moving at
the same time so you're constantly going
back and forth yes but man this is we're
ending our little demo here now last
part we're going to be showing is this
animation here going on but thing right
here that that water below is now
dropping level before that drop you
couldn't go past anywhere because it's
that that water would just basically
take damage damage while you in that
side so when when is this game coming
out September 15th September 15th the
amiibo to get a pre-ordering it's not
far off no not at all excited for that
well Daniel thank you so much for
joining us um and guys for all the
latest from E3 2017 don't go anywhere
the lobby is going to be live from the
E3 show floor in 15 or so minutes we're
going to have Harvey Smith uh talking
about the new Doner DLC and and Jake
Solomon talking about XCOM so make sure
you stay
tuned was going to deliver six ter flops
of GPU performance but with the
company's E3 press conference out of the
way we actually learned a couple new
things about the system we're going to
walk you through them right now so
Michael the uh one of the first things
that we learned about the system is
actually the name it's no longer called
project Scorpio it's called the Xbox One
X yeah what do you think about the title
uh it makes sense in terms of keeping it
within the family of Xbox consoles so we
have the Xbox One S which is the
standard console and the Xbox One X
which is kind of the premium console so
it all makes sense to me yeah we also
learned the the price which is
$499 that's pretty expensive what do you
think about the price uh it kind of
aligns with my predictions and a lot of
other people's predictions just because
of how much power this thing is packing
into one console it makes sense that
it's $4.99 but I think the interesting
part is like how is that going to
compete with the PS4 Pro which is $100
cheaper it may beut even l
yeah it seems like it's more it's more
powerful though oh yeah yeah definitely
it's way more powerful yeah and I think
you know the internet right now is
saying that it's very expensive if you
want something cheaper there is the Xbox
One S we also got its release date which
is November 7th yeah so it's coming out
this holiday season yeah they promised
to deliver it within the holiday season
and it seems that they are going to be
delivering on that promise yeah and then
finally we got a look at what you know
the console looks like you know what did
you think of that yes this for me I
thought this was one of the more
impressive Parts was they said this is
the smallest Xbox console to date so not
only is it way more powerful it's also
compacted into the smaller chassis to be
able to do that is impressive smaller
than the Xbox One S which is you know
approximately 40% smaller than Xbox one
so they've really shrunk their size
smaller Black version of the Xbox One S
yeah and it looks sleek probably fit it
anywhere in your home entertainment
system so you know that was one of the
cooler parts with the Microsoft
conference you know while Microsoft is
pitching the console as a 4K capable
system theany compy also said that it's
going to be making improvements to 1080p
gaming as well you're going to get
faster low times anistropic filtering
and super sampling do you mind walking
through you know users through what
those some of those things are well yeah
super sampling is if you're in a 1080p
display it'll essentially be the image
will render in like a higher resolu yeah
and then be condensed so the image
quality is much more fine so people who
don't have 4K to displays we'll still
gep some benefits you know we saw the
games running in 4k throughout the whole
press conference and I never really saw
any like massive frame drops and I don't
think everything was running at a steady
60 frames per second but rendering 4K is
uh a feet within itself it's very yeah
yeah and nothing looked framy nothing
looked like choppy overall with all the
games they sh showed off from like AAA
titles to the Indy titles like look
great overall I'm impressed I think this
is what Microsoft needed to do looks all
good to me gotcha yeah it seems like
it's a console that you can get if you
have a 1080p screen now and then you can
get some benefits that way and then
later if you wanted to you can upgrade
to a 4K TV and like you know continue to
get better benefits right right and then
the last thing is you know the console
you know by itself is is is fine but
what about the games you know what did
you think about the games they showed
you know Assassin's Creed Origins I
think it was called uh Metro was Exodus
which I thought looked amazing um what
do you think about the you know the
lineup of games and how they looked okay
well in terms of the lineup I was super
hyped up for to see Metro Exodus see it
running it looked really smooth too cuz
Metro has a long history of being one of
the more graphically demanding games
with 2033 and last Light and now this
one it's like it's it seems like it's
going to be in that same line of
impressively yeah yeah uh and I mean
scor just running at 4K it's on a cons
unbelievable yeah on a console at 4K
looked really smooth and see you know
other games like shadow of War
Assassin's Creed you know they they look
great too they're also rendering 4K the
only thing was the some of the lighting
maybe some of the textures weren't on
par with what we would see if we cranked
a PC version all the way up to ultra
which is fine I mean I'm not going to
expect a console to run 4K and like
super fine textures all at the same time
but they ran smooth which is I think is
the most important part for me it looked
playable if you like this video give it
a thumbs up and subscribe to us on
YouTube thank you for
watching
we got our hands on and played with the
Xbox One X Microsoft says it's their
smallest console yet and in person it
looks a lot like a black Xbox One S the
ports on the back include power HDMI out
HDMI in two USB 3.0 ports IR out spiff
and gigabit Ethernet there are also
vents on both sides of the console the
Xbox One 1 X features a physical power
button on the front along with another
USB 3.0 Port Microsoft also provided an
inside look at the system showing off
all the layers of the console moving
past the top of the case in the chassis
here's a look at the Blu-ray optical
drive which is capable of playing 4K HDR
movies not even Sony's high-end PS4 pro
has a Blu-ray Drive this is the console
CPU fan underneath the fan there's a
vapor chamber cooler heat sink which
contains a vacuum sealed liquid that
transforms to gas at high temperatures
to help keep the console cool like the
Xbox One S before the 1 X features an
integrated power supply this is the 1
X's motherboard which houses the
console's 8 core am so and integrated
GPU it's capable of delivering six terap
plops of performance the black little
rectangle surrounding the chip are the
12 GB of gddr5 memory next up is the
console's 2.5 in 1 TB hard drive we also
get a chance to play for2 Motorsports 7
at 4K using the Xbox One X's development
kit game was running at 60 frames per
second and turn 10 Studios told us that
it's running at approximately High to
ultra PC equivalent settings the game
looked great though if we're netp
picking we did notice some slight
jaggies on power lines in the background
not only will the Xbox One X run at a
higher resolution than its Xbox One
counterpart the developer tells us that
it's able to slightly crank up some
additional graphical bells and whistles
so that was our first look at the Xbox
One X if you like this video give it a
thumbs up for more gaming Hardware
coverage subscribe to us on YouTube
thank you for
watching
hey guys welcome here to e327 I'm Justin
here with Peter and Nintendo revealed a
whole lot more about probably one of its
most exciting games coming up Super
Mario Odyssey and and Peter you got a
chance to play like 20 minutes of it
yeah I got to play two different levels
uh one of them being new donk City you
know that City we've seen that uh has
humans next to Mario that are very
different heights do they explain that
why why are the humans all different
sizes it's a weird game a lot of it is
not actually explained like you know the
premise is kind of the same you're
trying to rescue Princess Peach from
Bowser but apart from that the game is
just filled with a lot of interesting
New Opportunities and possibilities that
have never really been seen in a Mario
game before and I was just kind of
thrown to the fire so I had to kind of
just uh treat it like a playground well
one of those new things is this hat
every Mario game introduces some kind of
new mechanic and this one the Hat
definitely seems like a a really way out
there different kind of thing yeah like
as you saw during the Nintendo Spotlight
presentation the uh the moment for Mario
Odyssey opens up with a shot of a
dinosaur and you don't even really know
what this game is until the dinosaur
turns around you realize he's wearing
Mario's hat and then he poofs into Mario
come on and then you kind of start to
realize okay wait a minute you can throw
that hat on the enemies and and take
over their bodies so that is the big
thing about the Hat what we've seen up
until now is that you can use it as a
platform but as we saw and as I got to
try uh you know if you see a Goomba or
any other classic Mario enemy like what
is the Bullet Bill is that is that his
name throw a hat on him and you can
possess
that
[Applause]
[Music]
when
he
[Music]
yeah
he
[Music]
n
he
[Music]
yeah
spe
okay
[Music]
know
hey everyone welcome back to gam spots
E3 stage we are here with our live show
the lobby which we do most Wednesdays uh
in San Francisco but we figured we'd
take the chance to do it for live
audience here glad everybody could join
good to see you and of course we will be
doing demos and uh developer interviews
throughout the week as it continues uh
up on our upstairs stage and down here
uh I'm your host Mike Mahari it's good
to see everybody I'm here with Pete
Brown as usual hello Cy pagy hello and
Rob
Henry we got like a 90 minute show today
and uh we will also be having a couple
of guests on later Jack Jake Solomon to
talk about the XCOM 2 chosen War DLC and
Harvey Smith talk about death of the
outsider dishonor 2 DLC expansion kind
of thing they just announced at the
Bethesda showcase but I want to take the
opportunity to talk to you three about
our favorite game so far I kind of asked
you yesterday but I've got a list uh I
think first off Pete you played Super
Mario Odyssey I have man that game is
really fun it looks really fun uh tell
us how it like felt to play it uh it
felt a lot like you know a Mario 64 like
any 3D Mario game like when you're
actually just moving Mario on his own
but once you start interacting with the
world things just get very strange very
fast um these aren't really like you
know distinct levels you're basically
going around environments finding new
challenges to accomplish and a lot of
them are delightful and weird and
strange so it was just it's surprising
to play the game and just to see like
moment to moment almost like Zelda where
it was like there's one thing I want to
do but then there's like 10 other things
that capture my attention on my on the
way there so the Hat seems to be or
Cappy seems to be the star of the show
yeah yeah yeah is there any sort of
Direction though like I mean at least
Zelda you have like you know your your
general main quest to follow is so there
is like a main quest in each of the
Little Worlds that's denoted by like a
beacon but the whole thing is that
you're trying to collect these uh Power
Moon Collectibles to fuel your ship to
go to the next location so even if you
beat that main objective you may not
have enough to go to the next one so
ultimately you'll have to just explore
and do all this fun stuff anyways but
unlike something like Mario 64 like when
you get you know the equivalent of a
star you're not actually like kicked out
of the level you just get to keep going
yeah and they were talking about how
like you get transported from place to
place they didn't actually show it but
the Odyssey itself is like a ship right
you can move from place to place and
that's kind of the structure of the game
but uh yeah it seems like there's a lot
more room for experimentation with like
the capturing things with the cap a
little bit definitely yeah at least in
terms of like how you go about tackling
challenges and solving problems yeah
cool um did you guys play it at all I
did yeah what did you think of it same
thing yeah I liked it it's uh coins
actually have a use now so you can buy
like cosmetic items and stuff for your
ship it's saw like a safari outfit when
they I bought I bought a fedora as a a
laugh I hate that
only Mario can pull off a fedora and
then I threw it around a bunch no it's
fun I liked it I thought you could
become uh become human it's really weird
man it's David cage has got his hands in
Super Mario Odyssey yeah like Body
Snatchers it's weird yeah what's the
value of becoming human oh there's one
there was one point in New Dong City
where you can drive an RC car to get a
moon and uh you have to occupy this
guy's body to do it and I was like oh
this is little Weir weird yeah wasn't
expecting that from Mario do people know
Mario is running around does does anyone
acknowledge Him or want to talk to him
or like yeah they seem fine with it it's
straight up like that Simpsons episode
where Homer goes to the real world yeah
they also uh just like Logistics wise we
thought this was going to come out they
originally announced it holiday or was
it December or something we thought it
was going to be like later on in the
year I mean I at least assume so I
thought it was just 2017 at some point
yeah October 27th yeah the same day as
Wolfenstein 2 and Assassin's Creed
yeah like two weeks after even within
October is pretty packed uh yeah so
Super Mario Odyssey I think seems to be
one of the show Steelers so far I didn't
get the chance to play it myself but we
showed it on our live stage upstairs uh
another one that we was kind of rumored
but no one really knew what it was was
Mario plus rabids Kingdom battle yeah
and I'm hoping eventually we can stop
say uh Mario plus Rabbids I just want to
say Mario Rabbids I actually am really
pumped for this game of course you are I
know uh I love XCOM and we're talk I'm
pretty pumped to have Jake Solomon on
the stage in a little bit but uh yeah
mamoto comes out with a gun through
smoke at uh ubisoft's press conference I
thought that was kind of a pleasant
surprise uh and I'm curious how this
going to work overall because Alex new
house one of our writers he played it
and he said it's actually a lot I mean
the trailer showed off a lot of the
Tactical mechanics but he said it's
pretty deep even for like from despite
how quirky it looks yeah he said it was
like even more like XCOM than we all
thought it was watching it like okay and
I could be mistaken but I think this
comes out the same day as the chosen War
DLC for XCOM 2 no really I think I could
be wrong but I'm really pumped to play
both of them uh Jake Solomon's next to
our stage right now he's laughing I
don't know but I'm I love XCOM 2 is one
it was one of my favorite games last
year um I love the the DLC I'm looking
forward to that but I'm also curious to
see like how other developers might take
that kind of uh turn base tactical I
don't think there's like a strategy
layer in this game like there is an XCOM
I I hope there is be awesome who knows
but I don't know but yeah it's pretty
cool to see other developers with their
take on it I didn't think Ubisoft and
Nintendo would combine to do something
like that right but it's pretty
interesting uh you see like the creative
director when mamoto was on stage she
was tearing up it's like uh apparently
it's like a passion project that became
something big it's on Nintendo switch
it's coming to it that was like one of
my favorite games of the show so far
that we've seen I don't really like
Rabbids I'll be honest neither do I but
but but I'm intrigues yeah yeah looking
forward to I'll probably play it Mike's
looking directly at me yeah not pumped
for this I just don't like rabbits
they're like minions yeah minions are
pretty awesome come on no they're not
don't ever talk to me what uh yeah
anyway and then moving on past Mario
plus rabids Kingdom battle uh
Wolfenstein 2 The New Colossus we kind
of leaked on Amazon Germany before they
announced at the Bethesda press
conference uh this game looks awesome
they show us like an almost 10-minute
reveal at Bethesda between gameplay and
cut scenes and whatnot uh what did you
got Kelly you were pretty pumped for
this weren't you I'm so excited for it I
thought it looked fantastic like I loved
the um like getting the introduction to
the characters uh from that opening not
trailer I don't even know what you call
it like it's not a trailer it's not a
Gameplay trailer but uh just seeing like
what this um like what the tone is going
to be I thought they established that
really well and it got me really really
pumped I love alternate history so I'm
very very excited to play this yeah yeah
it feels it feels like they're really
owning yeah as you said alternate
history but also uh that that one scene
was just so Tastefully in my opinion
ripped from like um glorious bastards
right in the uh the diner in the diner
like a strawberry milkshake please well
they did onee they did that in the New
Order too with a fra angle on the train
she was asking I forget how it went I
haven't played that full game in a while
but it's they've kind of have a history
of doing that we were talking to the
developers yesterday and so the whole
deal is they want to make you know your
enemies they don't want them to feel
stupid because then you don't really
feel that great for overcoming them
right so they want to represent them as
like competent confident people yeah so
who are also hateful so you
really stick it to them but also feel
like yeah you pulled one over yeah The
New Colossus name is you know like taken
from the poem on on the Statue of
Liberty but all BJ Blas at the end of
the first game also recites it um but
they showed off like New Orleans stuff
in the trailer as well so it's not just
uh like New York where you would assume
I think because of The New Colossus T
yeah they said New York they said New
Orleans yeah that's kind of all they
would reveal There's an Alligator Farm
they just showed that shot was really
cool there were a couple SC I noticed
watching it again he's on like stilts
and then they cut to like the alligator
scene um maybe the stilts are like for
walking in the swamp I don't know what
else you like would have Stills for I
don't know I have no idea the other
thing that I am very excited for is I
feel like this time around there are a
handful of characters that are with you
that seem to be really well
distinguished right and defined like the
guy was like the arm and as she's Del
delivering some kind of pet talk that's
the thing all these quirks for the guy
who's basically dropping acid well so
those two characters
so uh something insightful that I think
Game Informer picked up on is pretty
positive your choice from the first game
what CU those two you have to choose who
survives play through so in order for
those both to be in the game I think
your choice from the first game could
carry over or maybe they'll do something
like Mass Effect uh three and two did
you could do like a quick thing to
choose it before if you haven't played
the first game so that's interesting to
see because now you before it was kind
of like choosing between the greenhorn
and the Scottish veteran now it's
choosing between the Cyborg and like the
drugie so to see how that turns out I
don't know but you can also I like that
you can dual wield two separate weapons
now the first game was like arcadey and
how how you got like the Dual assault
rifles within the first 10 minutes so
apparently that was the bigger technical
challenge for them to overcome for this
game like yeah it sounds like kind of
obvious like why would it be that
difficult but it actually takes a lot of
different animation and physics into
account and they were like no that's
it's actually super tough like who knew
interesting yeah cuz I mean the earliest
incarnation of that for me before like
Halo 2 did it was uh golden eye when you
had the all guns Cheat on You could uh
have dual wield of every weapon but if
you did like AA and then Za and then a
it took a long time yeah you could have
like as long as the weapons were next to
each other in the cycle you could
actually be using two different weapons
like the clob and the stavi however you
say that I mean things just have so many
more like nuan animations now not only
when you fire but like when you reload
and what you hit when you're firing and
how that reacts like yeah sure two
different weapons yeah that's a lot just
looking at some of the gameplay too you
can imagine I think there was a like a
freezing type gun or something like that
so like if you could imagine like a
flamethrower and like a freeze gun like
just like those counter elements would
be really need I think I'm you know it
looked like the laser craft work I think
it was called is coming back it's like
the uh electricity laser rifle not sure
it's one of those like alternate history
Nazi weapons um I do want to talk about
Skull and Bones another thing that came
up at the Ubisoft conference um oh yeah
yeah Cy you seemed excited about this
did you play a lot of uh Black Flag no
not a lot actually but um I don't know I
I think the most notable thing is a lot
of people were talking about I mean we
talked about this on our our postow but
um comparing it to CF thieves and being
like how are they're going to compete
and I really think they're for two
different audiences sure um and so I was
really intrigued by like naval battle
specifically in Skull and Bones well
it's also like worth noting I'm pretty
sure skull and bones when CA of Thieves
finally releases in its full form I
don't think it's going to be near each
other either cuz skull bones said like
2018 I think fall okay yeah and then SE
of Thieves is in like we' we've all I
think I've played it like three times by
now we're doing them up on our stage
later but uh yeah like you said though
it's two different very different
audiences one's like a quirky thing from
rare where you it's more communication
based this almost seems like there's
some uh aspects of for Honor in it with
the like different kinds of ships having
different uh functions like the Warriors
do in uh for Honor yeah curious to see
how that'll work but yeah they have said
like behind closed doors that there's
going to be a full single player
experience with it and you don't have to
be you can meet up with other people
like like we were talking Rob like maybe
I could meet up with you and then we
could go and see like a fleet far in the
distance and maybe like okay they have
treasure but it's like six frigs and
we're we just two regular ships and we
probably can't win that fight and that's
what's interesting to me because I love
Black Flag but not for its Assassin's
Creed aspects for the piracy aspects
yeah and I'm really interested I know
new house saw it Alex new house uh one
of our um contract what jeez is he
intern he's not an intern anymore he's
right you know he's a he's a he was an
intern associate editor I think my bad
anyways he was say love you Alex none of
you care about this he was mentioning
the wind having a big factor and he
wasn't sure if he liked it or not but it
does seem just like a whole another ball
game to focus on of just like oh there's
a guy chasing me let me uh let me bounce
out yeah make the wrong move there goes
your wind and your momentum now you're
screwed setting up yeah so that seems
really cool yeah yeah um and then I do
want to move on to uh something we saw
announced at EA's press conference but
shown off in Microsoft's his Anthem
right uh what do you think about this
the new IP coming from The A Team of
BioWare which is kind of I mean that's
why we're inged right yeah yeah yeah
veterans at BioWare yeah the uh the
mobility is what has me really stoked
and I hope that that will continue to
feel really good as the game goes on and
maybe you know continues to evolve yeah
uh because exploration is you know it
seems to be a huge part of this game you
know all these like what we go through
like a few environments just in this
like 20 30 seconds and uh it it just
looks phenomenal I I can't wait to hear
more about the systems involved right
you know all the mechanics how they line
up yeah because I think it was actually
kind of smart that they showed off the
combat and the navigation rather than
maybe like at the beginning that cut
scene was gorgeous apparently that was
ingame engine wow but knowing BioWare I
think it was smart that they showed this
stuff off and not the narrative because
we can kind of trust that they'll have
that yeah it's kind of like what Phil
Spencer was saying about the Xbox
conference he was saying we could have
shown like something from Halo 6 if we
want to we could have shown gears 5 if
we wanted to but you know we're going to
have that so why waste time doing that
uh I'm actually this was awesome the
scuba diving that you could just go
underwater immediately Rob like I
remember you were watching that when it
happened and you're like what is going
on I I was swearing I was like come on
yeah it's it looks great yeah I mean
that's such a cool idea just a nose dive
yeah in the long run I'm curious like I
said how cuz uh you know like a lot of
people are saying that saw more of it or
at least talk to um BioWare or Microsoft
or no sorry BioWare about it they said
there is definitely a narrative at play
it's not just going to be trying to be
Destiny although it isn't that space
Destiny the division yeah massive
multiplayer games I guess apparently
like Beyond Good and Evil 2 is more of
an MMO oh we've heard a lot of weird
things about that yeah but I guess
that's a separate thing I don't know I
didn't really put bionda Evil 2 on here
because I don't I'm not that excited for
it it was cool that they showed it 15
years after the first game came out but
anyway um one thing a lot of people
brought up Shadow of the Colossus on PS4
I had total surprise not even just like
a simple reskin it's like a remake
apparently yeah I mean you can just
tell like almost everything about it is
brand new as far as I can tell right
they've maintained like sort of the the
way the animations work and like you
know the movement and stuff like that
obviously the tone and like the Colossus
but everything just looks brand new the
fur on some of these guys like and you
know the depth of field and the motion
blur like all of that is is it really
adds to the the scale the sense of scale
that's going on here I'm curious if
they'll update the uh controls at all
I'm assuming they will because they
finck you know like through Rose tinted
glasses I love this game but when I do
go back to play it even the P PS3 Eco
collection team Eco collection it's kind
of controls are not the tightest I'm
sure the camera is going to be worked on
I mean those these games have you know a
waas games are like that where they're a
bit floaty and odd yeah uh maybe the
gyroscope could come into play to help
with some of the aiming and stuff from
horseback like that might be a thing
yeah especially when you're on Agro I
remember being kind of like you're
fighting the controls a little bit so
I'm I'm assuming they wouldn't do a pass
over this without doing that kind of
stuff I feel like we'll see it on every
Sony generation from here on out and I'm
fine with it yeah I'm excited I never
played it so I'm excited to have like an
opportunity to play it God it's such a
good game that's why I was excited when
John Luke are uh are TD upstairs the
first shot of the castle and it's really
exciting to see how much excitement is
actually in that room and he's just like
shut up the closet it's like what you're
crazy but he knew that castle so well
the first frame no that game's
phenomenal um yeah I played it back I
think I got it on release day back when
I before I was like in tune with the
constant flow of games coming out and I
didn't really know what it was I never
played Eco I forget how old I was when
sh the class came out but I just
remember playing it I was like what is
this it's all boss fights and it's just
like this really silent world the most
like life you'll see is your horse or
those lizards right fine for to upgrade
I didn't even know those existed when I
first played I didn't kill any of them I
just had the same health and endurance
the whole time what do you know about it
what do I know about it yeah you kind of
said it I mean the other thing I do know
is that it's the same creators of last
of or Last Guardian yeah and I really
like that game so that's and that's how
I heard about these games to be honest
is like I really enjoyed last guardian
and and it's like oh it's a
combination of uh some of the team from
Last Guardian right it's not completely
team right it's not completely right but
F TOA is the guy who's s of the
conceptual genius behind all this stuff
yeah aren't there like not I want don't
want say Easter eggs but like uh
narrative ties at all or is that just
kind of like
theorized Pixar shared Universe
Tarantino kind of thing maybe I don't
know if there's any direct nods but yeah
I love that game I the one colossa
Colossus that stands out to me is uh
it's a lake and there's a platform in
the middle when you finally find him cuz
like half of the game is finding them
and you hold up your sword and the light
shines to the next one yeah and then the
story unfolds in a cool way and
obviously I won't spoil if you guys
haven't played it you should experience
it yourself if you haven't found out uh
but you it's like a bird over the lake
and in order to like get onto him it's
it's unreal it's it's fantastic yeah
okay all right enough going to tell you
how to so we're going to play it is what
you're saying yeah really excited for
that a game we don't have much b-roll of
at all aside from like the logo menu
screen coming up it's Metroid Prime 4
yeah also want to talk about how they
brought this up during the conference it
was just like sandwich between a new
Yoshi game and a new Kirby I think well
it was a they did that like Pokemon
announcement they like the guy behind
his desk he's like yes there's a new
Pokemon yeah casually saying there's a
new like switch exclusive Pokemon RPG
right which you freaked out about I
freaked out and it was so casual was
like oh you know for the first time in
the console's 20 year history or the
series 20 years history yeah on a on
consoles but it's like so casual like I
was like excuse me what and guy
screamed yeah I mean I'm very excited we
just don't know anything about it very
casual it was like half hour Nintendo
Direct as opposed to what Microsoft did
like an hour and a half conference
Microsoft went over an hour and a half
and it was that was a great conference
not taken away from them but Nintendo
just like rifled through things short it
didn't feel cuz just you were left
wondering about like wait what did they
just announce what is that going to be
and then meanwhile they're casually
Pokemon on switch Metroid Prime 4 is
coming out and then even uh like
afterwards oh yeah right at my desk
we're looking over your questions for
Mario and you're like what and it's like
they're still going with the other Metro
yeah it was interesting at first cuz I
saw the four come up and it didn't
register right away cuz none of the
original trilogy had numbers it was just
Metroid Prime Echoes corruption and the
original one obviously didn't wasn't
called Metroid Prime 1 but um but it
came up and this is for a numbered title
now but uh did you did you all play the
Metroid Prime games yeah the first two I
didn't play corruption corruption is
like my favorite one actually despite
the fact that it's Wii U like motion
controls or sorry wow we motion controls
um did you play did that make it better
the aiming yeah oddly enough cuz I I
mean going from a GameCube controller to
that it was kind of like a res Evil 4 on
the Wii I actually really like and I
would tell you to play it like that cuz
it's because of the aiming again yeah
because um the C stick on the GameCube
is not the best thing to aim with
despite the fact that I played like time
Splitters 2 a lot on the GameCube um but
yeah Myro Prime is really good game
really good yeah it's long too takes a
while to get through but I mean if
you've played but played it you keep
looking at me cuz you keep trying to ask
me no I unfortunately haven't I never
had a GameCube yeah I know have a
GameCube no it man it adapts the the
things that made a 2d Metroid great into
3D and then with that comes a whole new
layer of like immersion and uh like new
puzzles and creativity It's s even at
the time like it was really great but
today it Petro Prime is still an amazing
game the first it does hold up well I
played it like over Christmas when I was
home uh on my GameCube and it's really
good and then they have the C right on
Wii yeah the trilogy colle I never
played those I'm assuming they updated
the the one in Echo the control yes they
did and it's also on Wii U you can
download it oh cool presumably they'd be
dumb not to bring it to switch right in
some form once Virtual Console stuff
gets figured out I wish that would
happen we'll see I uh I think it is
notable that Metroid Prime 4 is not
retro like it's not Retro Studios right
it is yeah it's a big deal so um oh it's
not no it's not Oh I thought they said
it was no it's it's a new young team
yeah oh we don't know if that's internal
or not yeah that I'm curious about that
like I'm I'm intrigued obviously because
of the the prime name yeah but I would
want to see more from the game because
it's not the same Studio sure not that a
new studio can't do a good job I just
want to like save my excitement for a
gameplay reveal we can get excited for
now yeah yeah but you know I didn't say
I wasn't excited I just want to like
knock it over hype I'm agreeing with you
totally but then then it's also the
question what is retro doing if not this
right yeah what are they up to one thing
I don't I don't have like we didn't
mention in our list I just want to bring
up quick is also after during the um
Tree House live they announced uh
Mercury steam who did Castlevania Lords
of Shadow one two and miror fate 3DS
game which I thought was all right um
okay yeah it's like 2.5d they called it
kind of like a shadow complex almost
maybe um but anyway they're making samis
returns which is a reimagining of Return
of samis Metroid 2 uh it's coming out
soon oh there's Boll sweet um yeah yeah
we have this on the stage we just did
actually before if you were if you've
been watching our stream all day we just
had it on the yeah uh it looks really
good yeah it's interesting they're
adding like Melee uh which is not really
a Metroid thing yeah and if you time it
properly you get a like charged Blast
From Your your arm Cannon the girl
playing um from Treehouse was awesome at
this and I'm like worried that I'm not
going to be like of course they picked
someone who's good at this game but I
was like damn she's timing this
perfectly they showed off the little
Metroid amiibo afterward the squishy
it's squishy yeah it's kind of like the
Yoshi woly world one was also like Yar
or did I say that right Yoshi's woolly
world yeah was yarney that doesn't make
sense it was woolly woolish it was I
mean it y it was yarn it's yarn Yoshi
yeah I don't I don't I don't like that
texture so I that Yoshi it's cool though
I am I am buying that squishy Metroid
amiibo so hard yeah you can already
pre-order it yeah I'm getting it you
know it's going to be funny and uh not
to just throw this to another outlet but
I'm looking forward to Griffin if you
guys watch amiibo Corner looking forward
to him trying to put that in his mouth
ow I wanted him to do the guardian the
uh Zelda there's also have a through his
cheek there's also the uh Zelda ballot
of the Champions DLC out and that's all
there's four amiibo for them that's
awesome I'm not a amiibo person I don't
like go crazy over them I have the Zelda
ones on my desk in San Francisco but
there's 11 new amiibo announced 83
and four of them five of them with Zelda
as one Champions those are pretty cool
so the four Champions the two for
Metroid three for Mario Odyssey and then
two for the remaster of Mario Luigi
Superstar Saga damn yeah awesome um lot
yeah and then I do want to move on to
Rob I think your game of the show so far
that you played Battlefront 2 oh
Battlefront 2 yeah I played uh like a
solid hour maybe a little more yeah
right after EA's uh press conference
right or before yeah yeah uh yes right
tell me about it I love it how you play
I mean I'm really excited for it
resident pilot sure how's the I I love
flying planes and spaceships um and that
was one of the biggest uh gripes I had
with the uh previous game was that you
know you weren't able to roll manual
roll your playe you had those like quick
Dash quick flip quick side rolls in
order to like disengage from a lock on
or anything like that that was the
biggest surprise was like getting I
didn't expect it like getting into a uh
nabo star fighter and then it was like
oh my God I'm rolling oh my God and so
you're doing tight turns you're able to
like really have fun uh and function as
a pilot because again the biggest gripe
is you know you're doing a flip and
you're doing a nose dive and I need to
pull away um you know I need to go uh
flip under well now I'm upside down yeah
my arms like getting tied up but now I'm
upside R so the game's like well we got
to auto Correct you you lose all control
and it's a mess um but here yeah you can
you can um manual roll and we talked
with uh the uh developers of the game
and that they also because it's tough
you know you you don't want to make
flying too difficult or too intimidating
so there are functions uh they they
clarify that you know you can make the
games or the flight controls uh
simplified like they kind of were in the
previous game um but other than that the
class based stuff is like very much
needed no longer are you just kind of
winging on the field hoping you'll find
any kind of power up maybe a hero or a
weapon um those are now isolated so you
also can like look at a player like most
games you would you know you want to
have some predictability factor in there
like all right this is a this is a heavy
guy with a like a heavy um machine gun
laser um I know what he's packing for
the most part so it's nice to have that
change I remember playing Battlefield
field one last year in October when it
came out cuz battle Battlefront one from
Dice was I think November of 2015 I
remember playing Battlefield one and
wishing that they had done more of a
shooter with Battlefront one kind of and
like hoping that maybe Battlefield 1's
mechanics would seep into Battlefront 2
and it kind of seems like that's the
case not as deep sure it's still for
Star Wars fans but I think there's more
of an actual game here under the Star
Wars which I don't think the first game
had no you you like you can really feel
these guns as far as like oh this is a
very much a a light SMG type that's
going to do low fire damage yeah um or
like the snipers have like long coold
Downs which again the active reload is
really neat where like that was present
in the last game where like you know I
think each gun had a different kind of
meter to time but now there's like the
yellow which will get you that quicker
reload obviously if you hit the red
you're going to have a longer reload as
a punishment Factor but then there's the
green which can be like a damage boost
or like maybe like a a high fire rate
where you just have no um
no uh what do you call it like um what
it cool down excuse me right like yeah
I'm just gonna like hammer out all these
like lasers I love it but overall it
seems like it improved on the first game
so far from what we played for most part
yeah it's just just one mode one one map
the map looks gorgeous like it's it was
smart because you know again they're
doing all three eras yeah and this was
just nice to see again because you know
say say what you will about Phantom
Menace like there's something about
there's something about battle droids
and just the Clone Army it's like it's
great it's a really gorgeous looking uh
City the coolest part about the sequels
to me or the only cool part was the
action military stuff and the action
yeah um and then you saw Darth Maul you
played as Han Solo the heroes they
revamped the battle point system
obviously but you played as Darth Maul
and Han Solo and Ray it was kind of
funny during the EA thing because
they're like oh here's Ray she's a
really she's badass and then
dies badan Darth Maul is
just yeah well each and they kind of had
this in the previous game where it's
like when you play as she was very much
like a support hero where she would like
lay down like Shields and I think even
like Health drops yeah Maul is very much
your front line choking people out Force
push barrel rolls with his double
lightsaber but Ray apparently has like
um pretty neat tricks where she can like
um mind warp you so your controls yeah
as as her enemy will like get all
screwed up but she can also um I forgot
these names but she can um she kind of
has that like radar scan so she can like
point out um enemy troops like you know
spot them on your HUD whether it be
scanning I I forget what it looks like
but again you know you're also very much
reserved with these heroes in the
previous game like you know you see I
always say like you see Luke Skywalker
from like miles out you are still
running away from him because he's
hopping towards you it's like uh Bon
python the holy grow when Lance A lot's
sprinting at him he back uh but now
sorry now they're easier to take down I
if I see like a hero like I can get some
shots off I'll probably die but as a
team you want to take them down yeah
yeah yeah uh any other thoughts on
Battle Front 2 I think the uh battle
point system is really smart I want to
talk about that again cuz like the
rather than tokens um kind of earning
sort of like kill streaks y I think it's
a really good way to update the
multiplayer so I'm excited about that
definitely yeah and that's another
aspect that seems more Tor made to
Shooters than just the Star Wars game
like for the sake of being Leia randomly
yeah and and just to yeah the battle
point system is probably the the biggest
thing to take away because again in the
game it's like you know you're a team
you want to have roles yeah you can get
into four person squads but the other
thing is like okay if I want to be a
pilot like I can I can focus on that
opposed to like rushing across the
battlefield and getting like killed
chasing for an X-Wing token like it's
one of the first things you get so if I
get only just a couple kills on the
field that's that's something I can
generally get into quick if I want to
focus on the hero stuff I'll have to
risk it and and get like 5,000 and um
yeah absolutely it's it's it's fun to
see I do want to bring up uh one last
game before we get our guests on um The
Evil Within two I'm actually pretty
excited for because the first game under
chinji Mami and Tango Gameworks had a
lot of potential back in 2014 but I
think there's 15 chapters and I Remember
Loving the first 10 it felt like res
Evil 4 kind of uh at its best moments it
felt like the beginning of res evil four
or 5 when you're in that Village and
kind of running around surviving and
using the tools that you have at your
disposal to your advantage but then the
last five chapters of Evil Within in my
opinion became you know there's a turret
sequence the final boss if I recall
correctly you're like avoiding this
giant person just giant eyeballs like
gaze as you're it was like a mini game
almost and I think the last five
chapters had really bad pacing issues
yeah but evil then two I'm curious like
how they'll build on the first game yeah
so I talked to Pete Hines with Lucy
James on our demo stage yesterday and he
was talking about how one of the things
they're going into this game thinking
about is uh how to Pace it so there's
like points of respit for the player so
not always having like super grotesque
enemies or jump scares but like having
just moments of tension where it's a
little bit of a breather but without
letting go of that horror element and so
I think they're I'm I mean from what he
told us it sounds like they're putting a
little more emphasis on improving the
pacing yeah which was an issue with the
first one so right um I think if you
learn the mistakes from your first game
I I'm very excited to play your second
game you know definitely yeah I would
love to see I just Mami and the people
that he like mentors doing their thing
in the future uh cool and last minute
ones before I yeah yeah I'm really
excited for undertale on PS4 and oh
right I still have not played undertale
wow yay I haven't played undertale I'm
sorry should I play it undertale I know
I should undertale's just so phenomenal
I I and it's one of those I didn't
expect it to come to anything besides PC
because of the way the saves work yeah
um so I'm just really excited to see
that and the collector's edition is
gorgeous and I'll absolutely be buying
it uh I think Toby Fox just knocked it
out of the park with yeah the Earthbound
inspired RPG self-aware game yeah I'm
looking forward to playing it for the
first time on PS4 but uh unfortunately
Rob Henry I'm GNA have to kick you off
that's cool I got another Point yeah I
got cancers you got a call get off the
stage where do I go this way all
right everyone there dude uh we are
bringing in Jake Solomon from uh foris
onto the stage we're going to talk about
XCOM 2 War The Chosen and here he is
right now um yeah but we uh just the DLC
was announced the EXP Jake how you doing
hi everybody how's it going that's
louder than I thought I'm sorry Hi
everybody yeah take some adjusting but
uh yeah check one check check good good
all right I feel good so uh big news
from yesterday on the PC gaming show was
that yesterday I'm I don't don't ask me
I what was it yesterday day before de
before yesterday day before yesterday
yep yeah yeah uh War of The Chosen XCOM
2 is biggest expansion to dat right yeah
yeah it's big it's very very big it's um
it's I'm trying to think of another
words than big right now it's huge it's
m it's it's massive it's gigantic it's
bursting uh it's bursting with that was
a bad that's not good
girthy oh my God what uh yeah
comprehensive yes comprehensive that's
better thank you yeah I don't want to
sound like uh too much of a kiss ass but
XCOM 2 was one of my favorite games last
year I would shut up oh that's okay
continue uh it's every Lobby game is
genius no uh but uh yeah I'm excited for
this it actually I missed it because we
were watching something else like during
the PC game show I was hosting something
upstairs and then I got off and I came
down to I got off the stage and then I
came down to uh catch up on it it looks
really great um but it looks huge
because the last I think the biggest one
for two so far was Shen's last gift
right yeah we we had a couple of DLCs
and then this one is it's not you know
it's it's an expansion it is it's huge
you know we
have a lot a ton of new enemies we have
three new Soldier classes we've got all
kind of toys for the player to engage
with it's just really really big tons of
systems like I lost my voice on the
first day because I was trying to
explain the whole thing to people and
then like ABD I have to like hit high
points and just hope people trust that
it's it's really really big yeah um
would it be fair to compare it to uh The
Evil Within wow no holy sorry what
not at all it's very similar the hor
Enemy Within oh my God the Enemy Within
which which pretty much week yeah but
yeah you're right Enemy Within so yeah
it's it's like it's it's much much
bigger even than Enemy Within it's huge
it's huge um and and so you know we have
these these chosen these handsome
handsome aliens there and so they're
like these and there she is huh she's
lovely um they're these they're kind of
like the Ultimate Enemy of XCOM and so
they're like the player in the sense
that the player's going to fight them
multiple times of of course of the game
and every time they do uh the chos are
going to get stronger they're going to
gain they procedurally gain new
strengths and new weaknesses and so
maybe one time you come in to fight the
Assassin you think you know she's going
to work but instead now she's completely
immune to melee and you're like okay I
just lost my ability to attack her that
way and so it just forces the player to
sort of rethink things every time they
face them that's awesome it reminds me a
little bit of the Nemesis system sort of
maybe not as like deep as the Nemesis
system from Shadow Mor but kind of
before is that a yes um yeah I mean that
was definitely the inspiration
absolutely um you know we
thought certainly the the ability to
have those procedural strengths um and
our characters are more fixed but having
we've never had enemies with actual
personality before and so that's one of
the big things we wanted to do here was
add a lot of characters with personality
and so they always play procedurally
it's still very much XCOM but they all
personalties they'll talk to you when
you're fighting them about how you did
against them last time how the other
chosen are doing big things you've done
throughout the game and then they'll
talk to you outside of combat as well
and it's the same thing with the
factions these are the new uh sort of
new um resistance movements the player
can integrate with they have leaders and
those leaders of characters and they'll
be talking to you about um things that
are going as well so it's very Lively
and even to the point where we have on
your on the drop ship back from missions
you know you'll hear like the radio from
the Advent the government and they'll be
trying to spin what you just did you
know for them they'll be like h no
nobody worry it was no big deal nobody
got hurt uh just a gas explosion or
something and then in the Bas when you
go to the bar we actually have Jake Bucy
I don't know if people you know who Jake
Bucy is you know he's Gary bucy's
amazing son and he's our radio
resistance DJ and so he'll be in there
and he's like spinning thing for the
resistance so there's just a lot of
voices and a lot of characters that are
they all respond to the things that
you're doing and so it really feels like
okay this is a real resistance movement
people are responding to it it feels
like a live world can you go more into
the like how you build the relationships
with the resistance factions because uh
like in the trailer it says like problem
is that they all hate each other or
something so like you're kind of seems
like um it's almost like citystate
relationships to talk about civilization
yeah yeah you you have to win them over
and so yeah they have very different
philosophies all these different
factions have different philosophies and
you need to win them over and and the
way you do that is that each faction is
kind of paired off against one of these
Chosen and so to win over the factions
you kind of have to go after the chosen
that they don't like and then eventually
you can recruit their soldiers which are
very very powerful units you can have
more control over their faction and you
can start telling them what to do and so
it's a really it's another really
in-depth system that's totally new for
people who get really geeky about it
like me can you go a little more in
depth on the three um
the I'm never afraid to go geeky you
know that's it that's what I do um yeah
so you've got one faction it's uh
they're called the Reapers and they are
stealth marksmen and they're sabator so
they can attack yeah there you go
there's a Reaper sweet um so they can
attack from concealment and there's
always a chance that they won't be conce
they won't be revealed every time you
attack you'll actually see like a meter
rolling and be like oh you stayed
concealed and so it's always this big
trade-off of do I really want to you
know they're a Great Scout unit but
they're also really deadly so you kind
of trade that off and then there's a
skirmisher which is they're defectors
from the alien Army that actually join
XCOM and so they're they're half alien
half Soldier hybrids and they're
skirmisher look at the nails see you can
tell by those Nails that's not human
it's not human um but um he needs to get
that touched up um but yeah so they
they're really powerful they take a lot
of actions every turn and so they get an
extra action if somebody attacks them
they even have an ability called battle
Lord which if they trigger it then every
time an AI unit takes an action the
skirmisher gets an action so they can
take like 10 actions in in one single
turn they're they're crazy um and then
the final group is called the Templars
and they're this melee only class and
they have these big psionic blades there
we go there's the Templars and they're
cool because they build up power every
time they attack they build up power and
then they can unleash it with their
really powerful abilities so there's
this trade-off of building up power and
then wanting to keep it because it makes
their attacks more deadly or you can
unleash it in these really big powerful
attacks cool so for me I'm an XCOM
newbie I'm such a baby I don't welc I
don't know any I don't know much about
it I do love strategy though is this
something I can jump into or should I
start off on just base game no no you
can definitely jump into this because
this integrates completely with the base
game I mean what we've done is we've
added a bunch of new narrative we've
added all this stuff but it actually
sits on top of and integrates into the
base game and so you know we've got a
new intro cinematic we've got a new
finale we've got all this cinematic
stuff that adds in we've got all this
gameplay stuff that adds in but yeah you
can just jump right in and and get going
okay because I think Michael want me to
play this I want to check it out yeah
for sure I can jump straight into it
I'll do it talk about it every day yeah
think without I'm not joking we need an
XCOM jar where he puts a dollar in every
time he brings it up yeah I did not tell
them to say this I
promise uh yeah um I'm curious so as
someone myself who's played a lot and I
want to go into like mods if you don't
mind a little bit outside of the DLC
because uh I've been playing the long
War pretty regular long War I regularly
since it came out yeah you are for real
yeah I'm a masochist um I look I can't
make it past the mission and that yeah
I'm just like oh this is for Real yeah
yeah well I haven't beaten it at all but
I played a lot of it and I don't you
know like you don't really beat XCOM
XCOM to fail a lot but I'm curious what
um The Chosen war is going to do to like
the overall flow of XCOM 2 right like
what does it mean for like you know you
said you go to the bar and you got a new
character there that's kind of like
doing the propaganda stuff on both sides
Advent and resistance and I'm curious
what like if I'm as someone who's played
a lot of XCOM 2 yeah chosen War when I
jump into it outside of these like these
three factions and you know like all the
um the added layers with these bosses um
what is it going to mean like for the
overall like identity of it it's very
it's very different I mean so we have
all these small systems that change that
we've changed research we've changed so
your soldiers now they get fatigued and
so if they go on multiple missions even
if they're not wounded they're going to
get tired and what that means is that
you're going to start rotating a lot
more soldiers through the game is much
longer because of all this extra content
um one of the cool things is that your
soldiers can now gain negative traits
which are like personality quirks okay
and so if they get really wounded you
know one of the funnier ones is the
obsessive and that means that that
Soldier if they're running around and
their gun isn't fully loaded instead of
doing what you tell them to do they'll
instead they'll reload your gun awesome
and so sounds like me right so you have
you have this big tactic you want to
pull off and you'll be like move over
here and they'll move over there then be
like oh my gun's not loading they'll
reload it and you're like ah crap you
know and so it creates these these
personality quirks with your soldiers
and so there's a lot of these little
elements that just really change the way
that the game used to work and it's it's
a longer game you have a lot more
Soldier you have these Heroes there are
all these new strategy systems
interacting with the factions there's a
lot of fun stuff like um there's a daily
uh there's a like a a propaganda mode so
every time you win a mission what it's
going to do is take your soldiers and
it's going to put them together and pose
them in a bunch of different poses and
generate like a motto for this squad and
then it'll put filters over it and you
can you can adjust everything you can
type in what text you want you can
rotate your soldiers give them from a
bunch of different poses and so you sort
of take this like group selfie after the
mission take a picture and then that
poster starts appearing throughout the
world on the sides of buildings and and
so there's there's just on the fun side
of things there's a challenge mode so
you can jump in and play a sort of like
challenge that it's you got 30 minutes
you got one time to beat it and then
you're ranked against everybody else in
the world and there's these really
difficult challenges so if you just want
to play a little bit of XCOM so yeah
there's just there's just tons and tons
of stuff yeah that's awesome because
it's kind of hard to explain to people
outside of XCOM that there actually is a
despite the fact that it's like this
pretty hardcore strategy title there's a
lot of personality to it like I remember
some of my favorite like snipers and
grenadiers from XCOM 2 more than I do in
like narrative games yeah and I I like
this stuff because I feel like it'll
increase my connection to this world
into these characters that's right and I
don't know if that's the aim for that
that's absolutely the aim there there's
two sides of story it's the story that
you know the the dictated like narrative
cinematic story and we certainly have
added to that but really the stuff that
sticks with you as players is your own
moment and being able to share those and
so we have something called Soldier
bonds which leans into that the idea is
that soldiers form relationships with
each other now and so now soldiers have
compatibility with other soldiers you
take them on missions and you'll find
out hey these two are really compatible
and if they go on multiple missions
together they'll form a bond and that
means when they go on missions together
they get a bunch of free abilities that
are all about their bond and so it just
sort of creates a new story you're like
oh these two guys they love each other
and these two over here they're they
bonded together and they're really
powerful when they're together so it
sort of feeds into the idea of like the
player driven story is that inspired by
Fire
Emblem that's what I thought of I
thought yeah yeah I mean you you will
not be able to bring your kids back from
the future I we have we don't we don't
yet have that technology um but yeah I
mean I always I always love that about
Fire Emblem it just makes sense you know
in your head you're already forming
these relationships between characters
and so you know it just sort of was a
natural thing to do yeah yeah and uh I
am curious actually actually speaking of
like long War I have you been talking to
the team that did that and like how
that's going to affect or how the DLC
might affect that or they I haven't
actually I haven't talked to those guys
yet so that's that's on my list of
things to but yeah I did want I was
talking to Pete before the show about
like uh like mods and how you can go
about creating them and obviously like
the long war is probably the one that
arose out of XCOM the most and that's
the most uh you know the famous one that
came out and I played a lot I played
like long War I a lot um and you've
always been really vocal that you love
supporting modding commun you talk about
I guess like in Broad terms um what the
community has done for XCOM 2
specifically I mean it's it's amazing so
I I think that it's this idea and and
there are some studios like this and
where you where you realize
that if I'm a creative director my team
we're not the owners of the game or the
game experience like it is especially
once you have a number after your name
in the in the game that means that the
only reason you exist is because there's
an audience the audience owns the game
I'm not going to go off and make
something something that the audience
doesn't like you know they're they're
more owners of the game than and than
any of us are and mods are the ultimate
extension of that where members of your
audience are actually creating content
and they can serve people may have well
I want this specific thing like long War
we xcom's not hard enough we want it
even more hard we want it more complex
and so to allow your audience to sort of
be part of the creative process like
it's a gift because we can't make that
much content nobody can and and you can
cater to very specific parts of your
audience you can create all this content
you can get direct feedback from people
it's it's amazing so I'm so glad that
it's worked out like the modding is it's
a very big part of what XCOM is yeah I
think some of my favorite mods are kind
of minor as well like having the Halo
weapons in the game that's really right
yeah or like Star Wars cosmetic stuff uh
Bob Ross mod is pretty strong a Bob Ross
it is amazing wait explain this to me
what does this amazing it's you get you
have Bob Ross you have the model it's
it's Bob Ross he got his hair and then
voice lines from Bob like actual lines
from Bob Ross so he'll be like oh isn't
that a pretty little he'll be like
taking a shot of somebody be like that's
a beautiful thing and you're like it's
just amazing and so and those are
moments where you're like obviously
probably for legal reasons I could have
nothing to do with that but um but you
watch that and you're just like I've
I've got to try that I've got to play
that so yeah it's amazing and and so
there's the funny mods there's the
serious mods there's the purely cosmetic
mods it's just really amazing stuff yeah
and if you don't mind me saying I think
there are mods that make your game
better maybe things like the Evac all I
think that was like a minor one so when
you're trying to like Evac troops from a
drop ship you used to have to uh okay
you you are not kidding you are hardcore
yeah okay okay yeah no you you used to
have to like go click each one Evac him
he take you would repel up to it but
then of course there's Evac all so they
would all just go through once you're in
the zone of the drop Shi but like what's
it like seeing modders like like I said
it sounds like you're open to the idea
that they made of course yeah we we
don't think that we we can't tell people
we've made the perfect game every time
we make it we don't believe that and so
it's nice again modding is great because
if all of a sudden there's this hey the
audience really doesn't like this or
they think this would make it better
people can use our tools go out there
and be like we made it for you and then
we can play and be like that's amazing
like we we integrate stuff from mods
like we look at um and we improve on it
um now since you're so hardcore I will
tell you we now have the ability to as
you're moving your mouth as you're
moving the cursor around if you hold
down the ALT key it will show you a
preview of like what are the targeting
options at that location oh sick that's
that's super and and that was inspired
by some mods pushed what we did further
and we said okay we'll go even further
than that and it's just it's a great
symbiotic relationship yeah I've got
people I've got friends who play XCOM 2
and it's a question I want to ask you is
do does the like vast the amount of mods
in the in the XCOM 2 Community diminish
the uh the impact of like paid DLC when
you can play these mods for free I don't
think so I mean I think that what mods
do is they keep people engaged and they
change it up and they keep it fresh for
people and then we can come along and do
things that other people can't you know
we can create certain types of content
certain types of gameplay that you know
we hope we can add value that others
can't but for us we see the mods is it's
a great way of saying like Okay the
community gets all this new content that
they can engage with and then we can
come in that gives us the time you know
took us a while to make this product it
took us a long time make something this
big it took us our entire team it took
us a long time and and thank God for
mods that can keep people excited and
playing and then we can come in later
and say all right now we have this
massive thing that you know modders
can't do and then we we release it to
people and I think everybody gets
re-energized and then people are just
going to go and and mod the expansion
pack yeah um and then I think we did an
interview with you recently if I'm not
mistaken or like a couple months ago we
asked you like at at a certain point
does the game stop becoming the
developers and almost become fans like
how do you balance implementing fan
feedback with like the authorial intent
on your side yeah and and that's the
balance is that even if your audience
they're not designers but they are the
owners and my opinion their values are
more important than mine I'm not going
to I'm not going to force try to force
my values on players because if I do
that then I won't be in this job very
long so I listen to what they say and I
say okay I'm the designer should have
the tools to implement what they want
you know you know so they tell me I
don't like this or this part's greater
we wish we had more of that well then
it's my job to say okay my job my
training should allow me to say like I
know how to implement that and so that's
what that's what's led to a lot of the
things in the expansion package saying
like Okay we we've heard what people
love about XCOM 2 what they want what
they want improved and so let's go out
there and make something massive that
sort of delivers on that if enough
people got in your ear is there ever a
chance we could see XCOM come to
Nintendo
switch
um
yeah as a player I would love that I can
say with all honesty I have not had that
conversation yet but yeah I definitely
see the Val that for
sure besides we got Mario and
Rabbids ask you about that I know but I
just you know I see I see an opportunity
for something that would work great with
a touchcreen in some respects absolutely
absolutely no that that's absolutely
true I mean we've certainly had success
on touch screens with um Enemy Unknown
so yeah what do you you think of uh
Mario plus rabbit's battle Kingdom I
mean I I wish I wish somebody had a
camera on me as I was watching press
conference I was like I was like oh cool
yeah and I was like what I like what
what is that I was like what are they
doing and then there's like some point
where I think some guy was like and as
you see Luigi has taken half cover and I
was like what world am I in like I I
seriously have had a stroke clearly um
so it's I mean it is amazing to me me
it's really really cool I think what
they've done is really cool I mean they
like I just seeing it is very exciting I
love the look of it and it for me it's
fun I cannot play XCOM with my daughters
in fact so I have I have three daughters
seven four and one and so the other day
when I was on the uh PC gaming show um
my wife was like hey let's watch daddy
on it on the show and and I forgot to
tell like the trailer is going to be on
before I come on and it's just all these
scary like you know my daughter's like
oh jez I don't let them watch XCOM and
so I see this and I'm like hey there's
something that's turn-based it's
tactical it's not XCOM it's their
completely new thing but there are
similarities there and I'm like I can
actually like play something and I could
be like hey Daddy does something kind of
like this you know and so I could have
that experience with him so for me it's
it's awesome you see the fact that maybe
uh since it was on Nintendo's or sorry
Ubisoft stage but Nintendo's involved
the fact that like now Mario is getting
into this kind of genre like sub genre
of strategy you know fire emblem's
another comparison do you see this as a
promising kind of maybe spark for other
teams to make games like this
unquestionably I mean we all we all
build off of each other you know
everything every time I play a game you
know everything I do I'm sitting there
going like how can I use this how can I
use this and so it's great I mean I this
is going to bring more fans to Tactical
gameplay um and so yeah I mean yeah
that's that's so awesome to see that so
awesome to see so yeah I think it's for
me it's exciting I think it's it's
validating when you make you know
turn-based tactics to see some other
Studios trying it out and adding their
own spin on things so yeah it's it's
really exciting did you see anything
else from uh whether it was Nintendo or
Ubisoft or anything that excited you did
you get to watch the press conferences
or were you yeah yeah I mean Battlefront
like the single player portion of it
like you know like that's really really
exciting for me I'm a super star wars
nerd um yeah Anthem I think Anthem
anytime Bor does anything that's the
kind of Studio that I'll be like okay I
will definitely play that you know know
I just need to see like the BioWare logo
and I'm like yeah all right I'll buy
that I'll play that um so yeah I mean I
think those were two that I was super
excited about last night looked pretty
crazy um looked really cool so yeah I
mean I love I love E3 I mean I'm I'm a
gamer I love E3 I'm not cynical about it
like I get so excited seeing what people
are making like it's just as exciting
yeah more personal side um going back to
XCOM as you can imagine after I've been
talking about it I actually know a deal
like a decent deal about how XCOM in
2012 became a thing yeah it's not easy
no what is it like now that xcom's out
the world XCOM 2 and you're just like
pushing out DLC now huge expansions uh
like Nintendo and Ubisoft are kind of
getting into that kind of game what does
it feel like to go from the struggle
that was to bring Xcom 2012 to life to
now I mean it's it's very different I
mean it's very different and I'm very
very grateful I mean because the thing
to remember is that what we do it's it's
very like you know what did you do last
I mean we all know like your your first
bad game is probably your last one and
so I just sort of keep that present and
and I think our team we stay hungry and
we get excited by what other people are
doing and all of us we went through that
and it was hard and then we we got to a
point like this but we still remember
like we just need to worry about like
making sure we're always making a good
game and that's what it always comes
down to you always got to make a good
game so yeah it's it but it is rewarding
it's it's super rewarding to look around
and see more turn-based tactical games
and seeing that becoming a bigger deal
like that's it's pretty cool do you get
the chance to play any fire emblems much
of them oh yeah I mean yeah and and I
think that that's really inspiring I
mean they do completely different things
they do they do damage types they do
they did the relationship stuff and so
yeah I mean you get you feed off of
those kinds of games you feed off of I'm
playing Persona right now like in my
hotel room like I brought my PS4 and
everybody like hey you going to the
party tonight I'm like are you kidding
me like I have three young got some
hearts to steal I I brought my PS4 so I
wake up in the morning I play Persona I
go to bed at night playing Persona like
I'm like just you know that to me is
like the dream of of e3 it's not the
parties it's like being in a hotel room
just playing video game so but uh where
are you in the game without spoiling too
much very early I'm very early I'm still
attacking the first castle so me too
there's a guy in the pink underwear in
the Rob and I I'm having a hard time
parsing uh what I'm seeing so
some of the enemies get pretty graphic
later on if you haven't seen them yet I
think you know what I'm talking about if
you have but I I don't think I don't
think I mean I've seen some strange ones
where I'm like I'm not sure what I'm
what I'm looking at there but yeah
that's that's the joy that's part of the
joy of it you're just like wow this is
yeah yep uh so you are like you know F
aess itself between civilization uh the
recent civilization 6 and XCOM 2 and
going back in your development history
you've been very uh I think it's fair to
say focused on like PC development but X
has come to consoles y uh last
generation with XCOM and Enemy Within
not Evil Within uh Evil Within was also
on consoles though so true I guess I'm
lying um but then of course now it's on
PS4 Xbox One XCOM XCOM 2 yeah um what do
you think of like Xbox One X all this
stuff that's coming out with this what
do you think of this console shift
toward almost like PC Cycles it's pretty
interesting yeah I mean I think the the
basically they they now have to make the
case of like why why I'm upgrading and
it's easy for me because you know I'm
like a hardware junkie you know so I'm
like yeah that sounds amazing like 4K I
that means that I have to buy that and
then I have to buy a 4K TV because I
have to obviously I it's research for
work so yeah for me it's exciting I love
I love backwards compatibility because
there's still games that I still enjoy
you know and so it's it's really cool if
if they can if they continue that then
that for me is really exciting um yeah I
mean it's it's it's them responding to
the market Market it's them being smart
you know and so yeah I think it's
great does it change how you think at
all about like development on your end
everybody we've talked to says like you
know like making it for the to be
supported on the Xbox One X is actually
pretty simple because it actually like
can benefit like working for the S and
the Xbox One Etc and the P4 Pro can also
benefit the slim version right um what
is it does it change how you think I
mean I think is that you you get excited
at the possibilities especially if you
make crossplatform so if you're making
at PC title where you you have to take
advantage of these wide ranges of
hardware and some pretty extreme
Hardware um you always worry about like
the minimum spec is what you worry about
though so you know you got to make it
work on Xbox One and and just PS4 and
then you look at you know the pro you
look at the X and you say like what
extra can we do and for us it's exciting
because we make PC games as well we
already can take advantage of some of
that better Hardware yeah uh just to go
back to XCOM toward the end uh we have
another guest coming out soonish but I
do want to go back before we leave um
future of XCOM right like I said it took
a while for you to get XCOM to be a
reality back in 2012 it was like a
decade long kind of struggle thing um
from a you know like a cult classic back
in the '90s yeah uh bringing that like
pretty hardcore game to life um but now
you've got two you got a few DLCs for
XCOM 2 got Shen's last gift you got
Anarchy children or some more cosmetic
stuff and then you've got uh chosen War
coming out soon yeah um do you think
you'll like leave XCOM behind anytime
soon obviously you probably can't go
into too much detail but yeah are you
itching to kind of do something new or
is still like something you're committed
to and this is and I I get I get asked
this and I can answer it honestly
because I can tell you so I've been at
fraxis games for 17 years over 17 years
it was my first job out of college I've
been married for 17 years I am a guy
when I like something I like it and I
just don't I am I gifted to be simple
enough to be like if I like it I'm I
don't typically be like or I could do
this other thing I'm more like I like
this I will probably do this for the
rest of I will probably be on the stage
in 50 we'll be floating because it'll be
50 years from now but wait in 50 I I'll
be 90 I think I think I'm younger than
him okay I'll be 90 I'll be making XCOM
27 you know and I'll be up here it's
great I love it I mean I really don't
think I honestly don't see myself
leaving this because because especially
even when you see other Studios dipping
their toes into Tactical stuff like
there's just so much left to do there is
so much left to do and I like this genre
games because this this is my favorite
and this is what I play and so I play
all kinds of games but for me this is
what I always come back to so you know
sometimes you know I'll see something
people are doing I get I get blown away
by it but I really I always get excited
about like what more can I do in in this
space yeah what do you think of the
overall state of the strategy like
larger strategy genre now cuz you see so
many things you see fire em doing really
well on 3DS you see like you said
Ubisoft showed off a really weird quirky
combination of two big uh like
properties but like but you see other
things like outside of that you see like
tactical games you see you know like his
favorite game is Final Fantasy Tactics
that's nowhere to be seen right but and
I still have not played that but surely
not for long right I mean that's what I
think I think like I think everybody's
recognizing surely not for long I mean I
think that especially as we have more
platforms to play on you know strategic
games tactical games games that are
focused around turns that give the
player a little more freedom to play
games like none of us just sit there and
or rarely do we just sit there and play
games anymore like I play games and I've
got a stream going and I'm messing
around social media like and so tactical
games any turn-based games they're great
for that and it doesn't mean that that's
all you have to play I think that people
are just more open now to being like
yeah that every once in a while I'll
play this I'll have this kind of
experience with games or I'll play this
different kind of game so I don't think
that I'm also dying for Final Fantasy
Tactics to come back strong it needs to
be like a medieval like you know High
fantasy type not the we're kids we
opened a book and we time traveled and
still kids see somebody's been thinking
about this yeah he waiting for me to
jump on it and what bugs me is that I've
been telling him since I've known him
that it's my favorite game of all time
and he has never played it play XCOM 2
and then we can
talk right sick kidding I I I'll play
final fan deex but all right so Jake
Solomon when can we play uh War of The
Chosen uh August 29th it's out on on PC
Xbox One and PS4 awesome well we really
appreciate you taking time out I know
you're probably busy this week no I love
I love stopping by here so thank you
guys for taking the time to talk to me
thank you so much and I'm looking
forward to it but uh yeah unfortunately
we do have to bring someone else on yes
now I will I will leave all right Jak
don't forget me all
right all right cool uh we're going to
bring on Harvey Smith to talk about
death of the outsider bring him up right
now just start too uh Harvey we've
actually had you on Gamespot a lot over
the last few hi guys Hello nice to meet
you oh here we go Harvey I didn't know
that was you sitting down there hey guys
a crossover I saw your badge back in the
Green Room don't lose yeah sit on the
couch take it we could swap so it I sold
it on Reddit I'm sure you got like 50
cents for it uh anyway you just
announced death of the outsider I think
a lot of people were kind of predicting
this seems like the time for dishonor 2
DLC right like uh prey just came out I
oh what are you talking about was the
total surprise like come on uh so tell
us about it what was it like to have
this out in the open now yeah so um it
is called death of the outsider it stars
Billy lur uh that's the thing we're
really excited about we've been waiting
years to do this she's a fan favorite
she first appeared in knife of Dunwall
and the brigmore
witches um she's going after her old
Mentor Dow and together they conceived
this like almost impossible
assassination mission to take down the
outside
uh Godlike figure in our world uh
something I should say though is we push
really hard to make this Standalone
right so even if you have not played
dishonor before you can go check out
death of the outsider it's a little
shorter than a full release it's just a
few missions uh but it does feature
Billy lur and she has our own powers her
own gadgets um and you don't need any
prior Dishonored stuff you can buy it as
as a standal thing okay yeah the the
opening trailer if I'm not mistaken was
this Megan Foster and dowed that we're
seeing yeah this is Billy lurk so um
it's a spoiler cover your ears if you
haven't played dishonor 2 but uh there's
a character named Billy lurk from the
earlier Dishonored games who is in
Dishonored 2 under an assumed name right
as the boat captain Megan Foster yeah uh
captain of a boat that she owns called
the Dreadful whale which is an anagram
for farewell dowed so she still got some
unresolved issues with her old Mentor uh
and after the adventure with Emily uh in
dishonor 2 in caraka they go their
separate way ways and she begins to hunt
for Dow yeah you're saying um it's been
a like fans have been asking to know
more about what previously we called
Megan Foster and everything because she
was such a cool character in dishonor to
and like you said knife of Dunwall and
everything um was this were you always
trying to explore the story was it
largely because of fans wanted to know
so much more about her you know um there
was a moment in early on in Dishonored
2's development where the idea uh um
popped up about revisiting or visiting
this concept you know um sort of the end
of The Outsider and it just percolated
in the back of my head and I would talk
to various team members about it um and
all of us love Dow as a character where
where would he be 15 years later at the
end of his life an older man with
regrets uh Billy now that she's found
her footing at the end of Dishonor 2 and
she she's got new purpose what would she
do you know she's now the actor in the
in the world she's the one that's going
to like realize this uh this almost
impossible assassination mission so you
know at one level Dishonored is about
badass Supernatural assassin moving
through a steampunk City killing off
high value targets Aristocrats and uh
corrupt leaders and things like that
another level it's a family story so the
whole Dishonored series which we've
worked on for eight years now has had
corvo atano as a protagonist it's had
Dow as a protagonist it's had Emily
calwin and cor corvo as a protagonist
against the Dishonored 2 and now Billy
lur is uh closing out that Arc for this
part of the
Dishonored fiction yeah I do want to
talk about how it's Standalone because I
think like two days ago after W Bethesda
it's like oh you I think you can get it
for $30 even if you didn't Play
Dishonored 2 yeah I I was just telling
someone like uh talking to dinga bakaba
our lead designer uh we we realized at
some point if we did this that it may be
for some percentage of the audience
their first and only forray into
Dishonored sure it might be the first
time they played the game uh which is a
weird concept you know so it had to work
as a as a standalone piece about uh this
woman who's was part of the underworld
and now has some remorse about that
wants to set things right going after
this uh legendary assassin who's gone
into retirement finding him and then uh
undertaking this Mission so it stands
alone you know both in terms of you can
just buy it and play it but also
fictionally you understand the world if
you if you move into it when you get
into sort of that format when you're
offering something that's that's just
like this when normally it would just be
DLC does that does that alter maybe how
you think about this the scope of what
you're giving people in any way yeah I
mean all of those things
are uh you know like I don't know how
interesting this is to most people who
play games but like there's what you can
do in the given amount of time uh
there's like how much it should cost
there's uh how much of it should be
reuse of space in caraka versus new
levels versus is some old levels but
that have been heavily updated new
locations um do you scrap all the
existing powers and movement model and
start over because it's a new
protagonist like Billy lurk has entirely
different powers than corvo or Emily had
or Dow and um you can play through with
her powers and once you've completed the
game then you can play what we call OG
plus original game plus where you can
play it again with some of corvo and
Emily's Powers instead swapped out but
she has her own gadgets too uh she
doesn't use the pistol crossbow
combination that they used uh she has
like a a voltaic gun that fires like a
magnetically charged particles okay um
so she's a really interesting character
but it's like where you put the work
because there's a lot of work that goes
into something like this um and where
you put that you know to to give value
to the people that love the series and
want to see Billy lurk want to explore
caraka again want to take this thing
with the outsider to its in conclusion
uh those are all like highly subjective
calls that we have to make during the
course of
development um so in addition to being
Standalone do you think it's something
that can be an entry point for people
who haven't played Dishonored yeah
absolutely um yeah that's
um you know again like we it occurred to
us as we were talking about it wow it is
possible it's going to be a small
percentage of the a audience I guess
because most people who are familiar
with Dishonored one or two or the knife
of dunwell brigmore witches but when we
made knife of Dunwall and brigmore
witches it was very popular DLC for
Dishonored 1 but only people who already
had Dishonored one could play it you
know so so I don't know I mean I I
definitely think it works and and it's
exciting for some players that might
have a different reason for for playing
this they weren't interested in the the
former one but they like Billy lurk as a
character more or they like the idea of
going after the outsider more I I don't
know but um it's definitely playable uh
if you have never played dishonor before
it's it's a potential entry point to the
series do you ever have a concern when
you're using like fan favorite
characters or existing locations that
somebody who maybe starts out on this
and goes back to the first Dishonored
going back in time doesn't work as well
as as kind of starting here no I didn't
think about that that's an interesting
idea like uh I mean every there's so
many players out there and we mostly
hear from the people that like
Dishonored one and two or or our DLC for
Des one one and two knife of Dunwall
brigmore witches but it isn't enely
possible that someone out there is going
to play all of these in reverse order or
something so and I have no idea what
that experience would be like but um
it'd be interesting I think like in a
way this this whole thing constantly
cross references the political
assassination of the empress yeah in the
first game and it that's still
reverberating you know like Dow feels he
made the world a worse place he
destabilized the World by doing that
corvo misses the woman he loved Emily it
was her mother uh Billy lurk was Dow's
right hand during during that time and
was there that day participated in it um
and uh doesn't want to just feel guilty
about it she wants to do something about
it so if she sees the outsider as a
concentration of power that can be
abused by people and so by taking him
out she'd remove that from the world um
yeah so it's it's all in you know the
whole thing like weaves back and forth
across the the timeline of uh roughly 15
years I'm curious it seems like with
Billy you're going for more Gadget
oriented approach or does she have like
Outsider Powers as well despite the fact
that she's trying to kill him she's not
marked by The Outsider her powers come
from another source okay um so again
badass Supernatural assassin that's the
that's the promise that if if you play
the game that's what you get uh but she
doesn't use Blink she uses something
called displace where she can imagine
being two places at once and choose
which one she wants to go to basically
which means she can leave a marker
behind that no one else can see and
later go to it which effectively means
she can go through walls she doesn't
have to have line of sight to the place
she's going uh she also has a power
called void strike that she can charge
up uh she has semblance where she can uh
take someone down and take their
identity so their allies speak to her as
if she were you know the the person that
she's copying basically uh and then she
has a Talisman she's carried presumably
we say she was a teenage girl given to
her by her friend deardra uh that that
allows her to hear the thoughts of rats
so she can if you get near pools of rats
which in Dishonored one were very scary
yeah with uh Billy's Talisman she can
get near them it's called rat Whispers
And she uh she gets little Clues and
pieces of information from the rats so
yeah she has Supernatural Powers but
they come from artifacts she has the
sword that was originally used to
sacrifice The Outsider she has an arm
made up of void particles uh she has an
eye called the sliver of the eye that is
um a a big chunk of the eye of the
Divinity that existed before the
outsider to get super nerdy on you uh
and then she has this Talisman rat
Whispers uh so yeah she's a combination
on top of that she has the hook mines
the magnetic thing that will you can put
on the wall and will drag people across
the room you can put multiple in
different spots and it will pull them
apart uh hook mines are super fun to
play with when I saw her eye I instantly
thought of Kano for Mortal Kombat and I
can't unsee
it it's very unbranched just a little
anecdote I'm sorry someone someone said
earlier you know I worked on the
original day of Sex and the second day
of sex and we had a character that was
pretty popular called Anna Navar who had
a cybernetic eye that glowed red I think
and so someone said oh this reminds me
of Anna Navar as well so I I think once
in a while uh the world needs a
character with an evil red glowing eye
everything's cyclical right you got to
come back to it but the fact that is
death of the outsider it's called it
seems pretty bold because you think if
you kill the outsider how do you do like
a Dishonored three yeah I guess you have
to get creative yeah or have a alternate
power source outside of the outsider uh
I do want to talk about like um I kind
of was asking you actually just brought
up DSX uh you worked on DSX and you were
I know you did a QA on uh System Shock
yeah back at when it was origin in EA
but I'm I'm curious you know you see
Arcane is known as kind of the torch
bear of immersive Sims which you know is
like the dry term for these like
emerging gameplay based um you know like
just putting you in these realized
worlds where you can kind of use the
tools that your disposable to play with
it and find different you know like
experiment differently with different
mechanics and systems I'm curious why um
I've talked to you extensively about
this in the past why this kind of game
seems to be making a comeback because
like breath of the wild is doing this
emerging gameplay kind of stuff metal
gear solid five even did more of that
open-ended kind of stuff whereas before
it was like a you know more linear fine
tune stealth game what do you think it
is that's bringing back these kind of
games you know I think there's strength
in all kinds of games um recently I
played uh what remains of Edith fent
it's one of my favorite games everyone
should go play that game it's amazing uh
every now and then I pull my phone out
and I play hoplight which is an amazing
little Rog like uh Hitman Go was one of
my favorite games the year that it came
out you know but I also love Horizon
zero Dawn I love Destiny you know there
are many different game types and
reasons to play them but I think more
and more people who grew up with games
like all of us and who have played a lot
of games uh they don't want to just
follow a trail of breadcrumbs they want
to make decisions they want to see
surprising outcomes by mixing and
matching things so on the Indie scene
you have things like Terraria uh you
know and but even in the the very
high-end commercial Market big games
with lots of heavy art and um you know
that take a long time to make and are
big in scope you have uh people
experimenting in the Dishonored games or
the prey games you know um breath of the
Wild's a good example you know the the
video Everybody shared where he grabs
the goose and goes after the Giant and
then the giant hits the goose and all
the other geese show up and attack or
whatever I mean it was fantastic I I
played
prey uh as they were hitting Alpha that
that's a team that I didn't work with it
was in Austin but it came back to Austin
and I played two playthroughs back
toback about 70 hours of prey around
Alpha I gave him lots of notes and the
first playthrough I did all human skills
like engineer and things like that I did
no s Powers the second one I did only s
Powers just to really see the difference
and it took me about 70 hours to do
those two playthroughs and I swear I I
told Raphael col anonio my dear friend
the creative director and Ricardo bear
and uh Susan Kath our producer like uh
or banister Kath banister now um I was
talking to them and I told them like one
of my favorite moments in a game ever in
the history of my playing games 23 years
in the industry in my top 100 moments
was a moment in prey where as the first
playthrough where I didn't use any side
Powers I felt very secure cuz I had a
lot of engineering skill and and
whatever I would find a turret I would
in I would put it in place I would
upgrade it you know I'd put it in the
right position I'd hear it in the
background killing tyin the aliens as
they came in and so I was in this
reactor room behind this shielded uh
glass rebooting the reactor which
creates this huge storm of energy
outside the room but I had like four
turrets set up and so anytime anything
would come in it just get mowed down I
felt very powerful but as I rebooted the
reactor two technopath come into the
area responding to the disturbance and
they just have these systemic rules
where if they get near some of the
operators the the little robotic floaty
things or the turrets they dominate them
that's their nature as a they're
connected to machines and so the two
technopath flew into the area they flew
by my turrets they they sucked up all
four of the turrets so the two
technopath are now flying around with
these turrets serving them in orbit
around them firing at me and I like
that's a situation I created through my
agency through my play of the game just
to rules interaction and it was and it
worked against me right but I still
loved it because it was like oh my God
that makes sense I get why this happened
but holy now I have to deal with
these four the these two technopath with
four turrets you know and it's it's the
kind of gameplay that I think we love
you know where you do something and the
world reacts in an interesting way it's
not just going to the Next Room getting
the key opening the door killing the
monster going to the Next Room uh it's
it's very uh um creatively flexible yeah
it's fascinating because like whether
it's Designer 2 or prey as developers
you have to create these worlds where
that's possible even if you don't intend
for that exact thing to happen yeah we
never conceive of half the things that
happen right um and I am kind of like
Curious you know prey and dishonor 2 are
very different games right uh I mean
they're still in the same kind of sub
genre if you want they are different
yeah right but Ste uh dishonor 2 is more
like stealth Focus also kind of like uh
discret missions whereas prey is this uh
kind of uh singular open world if you
want to call it that um on the TS one
space station um what is it like seeing
uh Arcane Austin which is separate from
your studio in Leon where you worked on
Des H to what's it like seeing them do
such a kind of a new thing that I know
you said Raphael Co anonio had been
wanting to do that for a long time yeah
it's a total pleasure because very few
Studios specialize in the kind of games
that we make and so Raph and uh those
guys making prey basically meant that
the kind of game that I love just
emerged for me to play at some point
because I was head down on dishonor 2
with the the team in Leon who worked
very hard many of them worked on
Dishonored one but they exclusively did
Dishonored 2 with me I was living in
France and now they've done uh I moved
back halfway through the death of the
outsider and I've been working with them
remotely so they are also responsible
for death of the outsider um so we were
head down on that and we just only play
prey once in a while to give them a
little feedback but then by the time I
moved back back to Austin and they were
they needed feedback around Alpha Beta
near the end of the project uh it was
just a sheer pleasure you know to like
be able to jump in and play this kind of
game that I love so much that just
seemingly fell out of the sky to me you
know so it was really great yeah uh you
said uh you know there's room for all
different kinds of games in the industry
but do you see this kind of immersive
Sim game becoming bigger from here on
out with prey and Designer 2 and like I
said these other properties are kind of
using this kind of
gameplay um what I see is that pces of
things that work get absorbed into other
things right and so uh many things that
the the original pioneers of this type
of game uh whether you're talking about
the one square a time kind of games that
came out of the late 80s like dungeon
master or games like that or you're
talking about looking glass who made
underworld and thief and System Shock
very important early pioneers of this
kind of you are there firsters systems
based uh the world is plausible it acts
and reacts the way you you would expect
it to according to expectation I just
see all the pieces of of those
games have been largely absorbed even
into games that are more abstract in in
nature
um the same way RPGs used to be this
thing that were like very esoteric and
now play Call of Duty and it has all
these RPG features in it you know so um
I think it's more like that that people
have cherry-picked parts of it and it's
spread you know MH yeah you see uh some
EA sports games are actually yeah doing
RPG stuff now like NBA Live and uh
everything outside that uh Madden is
doing that now it's weird to see it kind
of invade all these other genres yeah um
but I am uh it's it's fascinating to see
how like to go back to death of the
outsider I was talking to Jake Solomon
before this um do you ever feel like
you're getting burnt down Dishonored
like I know you I know you love it cuz
you worked on it but like is there ever
this like seeing Arcane Austin make prey
is there
do you have this kind of itch to do
something different yeah I mean I've
worked on Dishonored games for eight
years now like from the time that rafh
and I started Dishonored one in Austin
was co-developed between Leon and and
Austin um through Dishonored one knife
of Dunwall brigmore witches Dishonored
two with Emily and corvo and now with
Billy lurk and death of the outsider um
and dowed that has that has been eight
years and so I definitely am feeling
that call to uh you know what else is
out there what what should I be
exploring right now you know but uh that
said we love our fans we love our
players and um uh it's been an amazing
ride it does feel like death of the
outsider is the end of kind of an arc
not the end of Dishonored but the end of
an arc like the the the event around the
assassination of Jessamine calwin and uh
the corvo Emily Dow Billy story it it
does feel like closure to that you know
you know so which also gives us creative
latitude if we ever talk about new
Dishonored stuff I don't know yeah I do
kind of want to get your take on the
rest of the conference unless you guys
have any other uh deathly Outsider
questions that seems pretty well covered
yeah but that's so much here that's what
I was curious about is what you thought
of what you've seen here um I haven't
seen much actually uh I went to the
Bethesda showcase so believe it or not
we don't see some of that stuff so I had
never seen the Wolfenstein trailer which
blew me away
I had never seen The Evil Within with
amazing cover of the dur dur song
Ordinary World way back but um I was
blown away by that stuff it's very cool
I've been part of a publisher off and on
through my 23-year career but I have to
say this is the first time you just look
around at all the other Studios and
you're just like intimidated humbled
amazed at the things your your peers are
working on whether it's the Fallout
games or the Elder Scrolls bringing
moral wi to the MMO the guys at machine
game work working on machine games
working on Wolfenstein um it's all cool
and we got lots of feedback from them on
death of the outsider and Billy lurk as
a character but that said also walking
around um I'm aware of what's here or
what people are talking about and I you
mentioned Jake Solomon like I'm super
excited about the new XCOM stuff I hope
that's really good I want to play that
um there's new content coming for
Horizon zero Dawn I think I'm so excited
about that um
Tacoma is something I'm watching because
I love U gone home and the guys that
worked on that so I mean uh it's
overwhelming because especially when you
like you guys you're working well your
your view is probably more transversal
of everything mine is much more head
down talking about Billy lurk and DOW
and the death of the outsider so a lot
of it for me is watching the videos
later when I get back to the hotel room
and I'm just wiped out and exhausted I'm
in a bathrobe and I'm
watching that's my evening by the way
like yeah that's it sounds like
everybody sounds about right um what
about the Xbox One X I guess that's like
a thing I just I've kind of been asking
anytime I get the chance to chat with a
developer this week I'm asking what they
kind of think of this new uh console
cycle if you want to call it that's
moving toward more like the PC side of
things from your perspective as a
developer does that change how you think
about development at all you know I have
a developer's view of that
um uh in that more power is always
better yeah um but at the same time it's
also requires more support and backwards
support and all that and it's a little
more complicated um but I think in
general uh we'll see we'll see how the
players respond to it but I'm generally
very optimistic about it yeah like all
the things that are being brought to it
you know uh uh I know I'll get one I'm
excited you know I have a PS4 at home
also and I have a high-end PC you know
so um it's it's all good and uh I
haven't bought a switch yet but I want
to buy a switch you know so um uh but
I'm probably anomalous in that I don't I
don't feel compelled to pick one and and
go with it you know I'm always
straddling two or three uh uh last time
for me it was probably PC iPhone and
Xbox 360 and this time I've spent a lot
of time on my PS4 and my PC yeah um I
actually been disappointed with the
mobile games lately like it feels like
we went through a period of time where
mobile games are really exciting yeah
and uh nothing's really caught my
attention lately I don't I don't know
maybe maybe that'll change soon but uh
yeah you mentioned like Hitman Go and
was lka was great too but since then
there hasn't been yeah you're right now
that I think about it there hasn't
really been like a I mean
discoverability is such a challenge on
mobile yeah there you go I mean like
it's great that everybody more and more
people can make games tools are more
free form everything's out there you can
just put it up or
whatever but it doesn't help anybody if
it's just instantly lost in a massive
sea of uncurated consents or whatever
you know so um I'm glad that's not my
problem to solve that sounds like a very
hard hard problem but yeah I don't want
to ask while we're actually it's kind of
like we're on a stream right now and
Jake Solomon is saying whenever he's
playing a game he almost always has a
stream up and he's looking at his phone
and everything um and then with game the
kind of games you make there they reward
experimentation and you find out things
that you could do like you mention the
chicken and uh breath of the wild of
kako kako whatever they're called uh
like finding things like that that you
didn't know could happen just like it's
funny that you know the kind of games
you make seem almost tellor made for
like these YouTube videos that come out
or like the streamer to find something
crazy like is that like does that affect
how you see your games in the aftermath
like I know um I was talking to you
before like what it's like to see people
playing Dishonored on YouTube like the
next day and like doing things that you
didn't even consider yeah I mean that
phenomenon is really fantastic um and
I've told the story before about how at
the end of Dishonored
one um long before death of the outsider
and the Billy lurk conclusion and all
that just we had just finished
Dishonored one and we were working on
knife of Dunwall or something I think or
a patch actually it was earlier than
that we were working on a patch or
something and um rip tide is one of the
early streamers that we watched um rip
TI p i I don't remember what his exact
handle is but he was playing the very
end of the game and you know he played
the entire game and every day we'd walk
through the the break area and like stop
at the Monitor and look oh he's he's
third a third of the way through the
game oh he's half of the way through the
game and by the time he got to the final
mission the end the whole team was
gathered in this break room around this
monitor watching talking and uh I'll
never forget he like Admiral havlock had
Emily was like the high chaos ending or
whatever and was threatening to drop her
off the tower and he was like I don't I
in my memory it's probably wrong but in
my memory he was eating or something and
he was like oh yeah sure you're going to
drop the little girl off the Tower video
game and then she goes and Falls to her
her Doom you know and he was just like
what and so we all had this amazing
reaction to to watching somebody else
work their way through the gameplay and
through the story and stuff it's very
gratifying in a way that I wouldn't have
anticipated and what a way to get
feedback right like the most honest
feedback possible yeah yeah exactly and
not only what they're saying but what
people in the comments are saying is
that do you take that to into account
when you go into something like death of
the
outsider yeah I mean not not too much
because uh for at least this Arc of
Dishonored games we pretty much have a
vision for them we know that people play
them um you know we have several people
who play Dishonored in the most stealthy
way possible and they comment as they're
playing and they try all the little
clever things and other Dishonored fans
are watching them and it something goes
wrong and it all goes crazy violent or
whatever we anticipate that for the the
Billy lurk uh death of the outsider
chapter as well um but as yet we haven't
really like moved the game to that to
something that's more supportive of that
model you know we've we've been pretty
focused on this is the kind of game we
make it's all about being a badass
Supernatural assassin jumping rooftop to
Rooftop killing off corrupt Aristocrats
sneaking past guards um trying to be
careful but then when things go wrong
going super violent you know that's
pretty much like what our players love
about the Dishonored games that in the
rich world you know the we do layers and
layers of environmental storytelling in
the world it's a very plausible complete
world even though it's a fantasy world
so yeah so I I do hope death of the
outsider is a an entry point for some
people who haven't played and I also
hope that the people who have been with
us this 8-year ride like it as well they
they like the conclusion that we come to
yeah to be kind of a geek quick about
like the history of this kind of game um
you know like you can look at Dishonored
as an homage to Thief almost and then
you can look at prey as an homage to
System Shock and then even if you want
to go back before you at Arcane um you
know when they open with Arc Fatalis is
kind of an homage to Ultimate under yeah
yeah do do you see anything else from
the past you would like to see come back
whether it's from you or from someone
else well I'm really excited about the
new Metro game yeah and so you know
there's always been like a vibe there a
tone that I've that I found appealing
because it's from a culture outside my
own or whatever right stalker originally
was like kind of magical for some of us
um so yeah I mean um there's also
teranova a game nobody remembers but it
was like uh based on the wing Commander
structure of play but you played uh you
know a power suit Char a power armor
character in a Wi-Fi setting and some of
the mission design behind that was
really really amazing for its time
awesome uh yeah so we're just going to
close it out and go back up to our stage
momentarily but last question I guess
like $30 death of the outsider when can
we play it $29.99 actually um sorry my
bad thought you were professional I know
I'm tired it's available death of the
outsider starring Billy lurk
Standalone uh is available September
15th okay cool well Harvey thanks so
much for coming on stage we going to
close it out soon quickly I meant to do
this earlier in the show but uh if you
watch the lobby you know we do giveaways
uh this one's actually kind of huge uh
if you follow uh Gamespot on Twitter you
can go we have a link on the site doing
LG and New Egg are teaming up to it's
like an entire gaming prize pack it's a
34in ultrawide uh HD curved LED gaming
monitor as well as mechanical gaming
keyboard stereo gaming headset gaming
mice uh $50 Newegg gift card uh we're
going to choose one winner tonight and
another one tomorrow night so you can go
to Gamespot if you don't follow us on
Twitter do that and then you can go
check that out uh but yeah we're going
to go back up the stage upstairs but
Harvey thank you so much for joining us
thank you guys have a good rest of the
show and uh thanks for talking about
death of the outsider with us always
yeah and everybody thank you so much for
joining here we really appreciate it uh
we appreciate seeing some familiar faces
and stream and everything uh we're going
to throw it back upstairs to the stage
for uh another demo throughout the day
but stay tuned to Gamespot see you
there
[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to the
Gamespot stage here at E3 2017 joining
Dave and myself is Clint coming to talk
to us about Crackdown 3 yes uh how's
your show going so far it's been great
yeah I mean let's Terry Cruz yes okay
how long have you been sat on
that for a while we uh we wanted you
know E3 for us this year was all about
revealing our campaign experience nobody
had seen campaign yet we talked a lot
about destruction um and our cloud
comput and that's part of our
competitive multiplayer experience
absolutely part of Crackdown 3 Nobody
seen campaign yet oh so we wanted to
come and and show campaign for the first
time and show off the partnership with
Terry Cruz and it's it's been awesome to
see people play the game for the first
time I've heard rumors that Cruz himself
is actually around somewhere
substantiate those I have heard similar
rumors that he may be at some point I
honestly don't know if it's now I'm
leaving yeah just this interview's done
you're out yeah swap him in Terry Cruz I
would not be offended if you swapped me
out for Terry Cruz I'm not going to lie
you stay I'll go well how do the whole
partnership with Terry come about um you
know Terry's a huge gamer loves games uh
did I did enjoy seeing him play Battle
was it Battlefront last year or
Battlefield one Battlefield 1 he's
recently built his own PC he's yeah yeah
yeah so it it was so such a perfect
partnership um and then some
conversations you know I think he really
wanted to be in the game um and so you
know now not only is he character in the
game he's Commander Jackson You're he's
actually playable and you can play as
Terry Cruz both in campaign and in
competitive multiplayer incredible but
does um so you have you have Terry Cruz
are there going to be other celebrities
or he going to be taking like and for
Forefront right now we're only talking
about Terry Cruz um which was it's been
awesome the funny story about him when
we were shooting that opening um and
he's running around and he's you know
being Terry Cruz he would Flex he would
break the suit like entire panels of it
would flip up and somebody have to run
out and glue him back down and put him
back together and then he would go back
to doing his thing and that gun he's
carrying we actually built I mean you
know it's an actual prop and when we
first saw it like that that gun is
enormous and then he you put it in his
hands you're like it's about the red
size um all right so let's talk
Crackdown three so it's been a while
since you guys announ you guys announced
then you went quied for a bit little
Resurgence and now you're back in full
force ready to release later this year
yes November 7th wow so what's it like
kind of finally having it out there like
in more more than just like one trailer
actually having people get their hands
on the game it's it's been incredible um
you know what we have on the show floor
is what we call our skills for kills
challenge it's essentially a Sandbox we
put our craziest weapons up on the
rooftops and people are going around and
taking out different parts of the gang's
business and and collecting orbs and
it's it's just this challenge to get the
h score um and and for us it's just been
so exciting to watch people play it and
people come around like oh you know
these hardcore Crackdown fans like it's
back and it it feels like Crackdown but
it feels like this this way you pushed
it forward we had a double jump and an
air burst and so you have some more
controls and you have some crazy weapons
we have the singularity weapon uh that
creates black holes uh but because
Crackdown such a physical game right
where you can you know smash a light
pole and then pick it up and use it as a
javelin everything in the world is
physical so when you create that black
hole it sucks in enemies it sucks in
props and cars and everything else and
then sends them flying it tears monil
carriages off the mon rail line and so
people are having a lot of fun just
playing with all of our crazy weapons a
lot of people have said that um or
people have had some hands on they've
compared it it's more like Crackdown one
than it is to crack down to are you is
that was that a conscious thing
returning to your roots after the kind
of departure when you went to crack down
to the whole mutants thing absolutely um
you know we we wanted to take it back to
its roots uh you know we wanted to
create this all new Criminal Empire so
it's an all new city and that city is
completely controlled by a criminal
Empire that calls itself teranova city
is twice as large as the one in the
original um and the tallest building in
the original was the agency Tower the
tallest building in the new one is the
Kingpin Tower and it is twice the height
of the HC Tower so not only have we
gotten a much larger footprint we have
just insane amounts of verticality but
for us the that that gang that criminal
Empire was such a part of it uh in a
game like this where the entire city is
open to you from the beginning where
there's no you know you failed cuz you
left the mission area this is a game
where like the G the mission is to
dismantle the organization you dismantle
in any way you can and players use the
crazy tools we give them and this
exponential power curve and I'm I'm
super excited to see how players do it
but with it being called Crackdown three
is there a necessity for players to have
played one and two or can you just go in
fresh and just be exposed to the
craziness from the GetGo there you do
not need to play The Originals I love
the original so I would never tell
anybody they shouldn't um but but you
absolutely don't need to this this is
its its own narrative it takes place uh
more than 10 years after the events of
the second one there'll be some familiar
voices uh for fans of the original such
as the voice of the agency um but you
don't have need to have played The
Originals to to understand what's
happening does the Freedom that you're
creating with the open world also
translate to the campaign a lot of
people have been saying that it's you
it's possible to just go to the Head
Kingpin and fight him rather than chip
away as lieutenants that is so um
Crackdown is a game where really we give
the player their tools and then we
unleash them into this giant sand boox
and we see the choices they make and we
want to make sure that the game reacted
to those choices so the beginning of the
game the entire city is open you can go
right after the Kingpin if you want it's
going to be incredibly hard you're going
to be underleveled I'm sure somebody
will figure it out and in you know the
world of games probably you know
somebody figures it out within
yeah exactly um but that's that's what's
exciting for us you know this this is a
game where it's it's different for every
player and a big part of that's the
system we call gangs bite back so every
one of our crime bosses has something in
the world that they care about a part of
the organization that they run as a
player you want to figure out what that
is and attack it and that pisses them
off and as you piss them off they add
defenses to their areas and then
eventually they'll start to retaliate
they'll send people after you that can
happen anywhere in the world so you'll
have fights in an area that I didn't
fight anybody and that's just because
that's where you were when that
retaliation was triggered you go through
enough of that you can finally pull
those bosses into play and they'll come
after you personally so those bosses are
also those boss battles are also
completely Dynamic yeah all of that
gives players where it's this feeling of
the way that I dismantled teranova was
completely different than the way
somebody else did and every playthrough
feels different I mean speak I mean you
mentioned the word dismantle let's talk
about your destruction so that was
really like the first thing that was
shown off about the game was that every
it was powered by the cloud and it was
like the first time really we'd seen
that um how has that technology evolved
since that first showing CU it wasn't
really a big part of this year's press
conference right it was it was a single
player but like so well how is how is it
how was it going to work so um know the
the cloud compute gives us these 100%
destructible environments where you're
tearing down buildings and creating your
own paths through maps and it gives
players just total agency over the map
and so like I said that's that's all
about our competitive multiplayer
experience um and people are definitely
going to be learning more about that
soon the figure originally was it made
it 20 times more powerful than Xbox one
right is that still the figure or is is
it has it changed with the Xbox One X
have you been able to refine it and make
it even more powerful still um the kind
of the comput computational requirements
of that that mode and the our
competitive multiplayer
experience that's nothing's changed that
it's the exact same so it's you know
Xbox One X you'll get it in 4k um and of
course our explosions and everything
else they look amazing in 4k but we
we're still going to use the cloud to
power our competitive multiplayer
experience so that's just for the the
cloud competion is just for competitive
multiplayer it's not going to transfer
to the single player correct so in the
campaign mode you have online which you
can play in four player co-op um and
then you have Offline that you can play
single player and so in campaign you
save the city in competitive multiplayer
you wreck it
Fair have you designed any kind of
multiplayer game modes around
destruction like the the fastest group
to destroy a c win sort of thing is that
something you're thinking about to
really play upon those uh destruction
mechanics you've built I mean
destruction is such a kind of game
changing mechanic uh it changes the way
you think about everything from pathing
to how you design levels and everything
so I'm super excited to uh to talk more
about that kind of stuff but uh like I
said at E3 this year we're we're all
about campaign and we're going to talk
more about the competitive multiplayer
soon all right so you said the whole
City's open to you as soon as like soon
as you drop into the game yes how you
how is that going to work with like
onboarding like tutorials or is it just
basically for the player who like yeah
you go out there you figure it out
yourself so I mean much like the
originals you have the voice of the
agency in your ear and this is the you
know one of the characters that really
helps you understand you know what's
going on and who you are and what you
should be doing in the world but because
it's this giant sandbox players we we
never completely limit the player we
never block off parts of the city you
don't fail because you left the mission
area um and so we give you the entire
city but certainly we're going to help
players kind of figure out how to play
the game and we want players to
obviously have success and we want them
climbing up and collecting orbs and
getting these crazy weapons and leveling
up their skills for kills and uh so
we'll we'll have plenty of stuff to get
people there you mentioned orbs that's
obviously a very classic Crackdown
staple is it is it the same as the
original Crackdown or have you evolved
the orb system the upgrade system into
something a little different this time
so the skills for kills system uh we
really took again kind of taking it back
to its roots we took that original
system but we wanted to add some stuff
to it so it still has that crazy
exponential curve where in the beginning
of the game you know you're throwing
rocks or trash cans you know but you
know level up a couple of times and
suddenly you're throwing giant fuel
trucks and you know at the beginning of
the game you're running around and you
feel really fast but you level up your
agility a couple times and suddenly
you're jumping over entire buildings and
so that that still it's such a part of
the DNA of the franchise I mean
Crackdown was always such a vertical
platformer um but now what we wanted to
add was some some new abilities you
unlock as you progress so we've added a
double jump we've added an air burst
we've we've you know added the ability
to be able to pick up objects from a
distance so that you could do everything
on the run you never really have to stop
so you you can jump through the air and
Target a car and sub Target the gas cap
blow up the car turn pull you know a
prop off a rooftop throw and hit
somebody with it all before you hit the
ground and the idea is and just give
player all these crazy options and then
see how they play with all of these sort
of these variables right through play
testing you guys must have come up
against some like I didn't know I could
do
that always but that's for me like and
this just personally these are the kinds
of games I love to make I like games
where uh you know players kind of create
their own experiences in many ways and I
think then you multiply that by four
players in Co-op you multiply that by
Dynamic boss battles that can happen
anywhere so the three of us can be
playing playing together in three
different parts of the city pissing off
three different gang bosses at the same
time triggering retaliations pulling
bosses into play and all be happening in
the same world and that that for me it's
so interesting to see a game that kind
of allows the player to make those kinds
of second to Second choices how I want
to play this game and that it can react
to them I've been reading a lot about um
the the retaliations retaliation system
um it sounds like there's a lot of
emerging gameplay there you can get a
retaliation flee to another area all
that chaos creates another retaliation
how chaotic can it get is it can you get
like the whole city on your back or
something it can be incredibly chaotic
so we'll you know we'll have some ways
for players to feel like if if they need
to cool it down they can cool it down
but at the end of the day I mean this is
a game that's bombastic it's crazy over
the top um and so we we want to make
sure that we can crank that up and we've
always talked about Crackdown as being
the the Op game I me it's a game where
you have a black hole gun like you have
another one called the micro missile
launcher that's a fully automatic rifle
it shoots rockets and so you can juggle
cars and things like that and so we'll
give you plenty of tools to be able to
deal with that chaos what's it like sort
of I mean it's been a good few years now
since Crackdown 2 and in that time there
have been a lot of similar games I'm
thinking like Saint R 4 I'm pretty sure
had a black hole gun or something very
similar what's it like sort of now being
like oh no we're back we're back
guys uh it's yeah it's it's been an
incredibly exciting show um you know
I've had a lot of fun hanging out in the
booth and watching people play and um
you know I've already got you know we
came in and I had done you know a
10-minute playthrough and I had you know
a five star rating and I had my 26,000
point and I've you know had a person
who's come back and played multiple
times and they've almost beaten my score
now and so uh it's been a blast to just
to watch people get to play and and
frankly I've seen people do crazy stuff
on the show floor that I wasn't
expecting either so we're feels like
we're we're already there how have you
really up the anti because as a huge
Crackdown one and two fan I'm imagining
it in my brain like every time I play
one of your games it's like how can this
get crazier cuz you always seem to hit
that ceiling of insanity so what have
you done to really push this forward
because without getting getting hands on
yet I can't really imagine how crazy you
could have gotten it I mean a big part
of that is that gangs bite back system
is the fact that you can have all of
these different elements interacting to
create experiences that were completely
unique to your playthrough um you know
so if you've got a boss battle and you
end up you know dragging that boss
battle into another area then triggering
retaliation then you again it just gives
you this experience that's completely
your own um and so for me that's a big
part of the game we've always said like
every playthrough is different that's
what we wanted and that the gangs buite
back is how we get there uh this year's
E3 press conference on Microsoft not a
lot of first party but what they did
have on show was this incredible sort of
mix of developer with third third party
relations right so what was it like
being sort of like at the front and
foremost and all eyes on you guys and
the Pyro yeah yes it was awesome that
was pretty cool um yeah I mean we you
know you're always in those moments
you're sitting in the show and you're
like I can't wait for people to see this
and it starts with Terry Cruz and people
CLA through his first line so people
didn't even hear it like um it's uh
showing a game for the first time uh and
having a big reveal like that uh it's
it's always the most it's one of the
most exhilarating parts of making
games so now you're you know getting
gearing up to release it's like it's
it's on the horizon now um I mean the
reason a lot of people got the first
Crackdown youve it was like bundled with
a Halo Beta key um you've obviously got
a lot of of um Ste in your back catalog
why why now why with this uh Xbox One X
do you think that's going to push you
over the Over the Horizon do you think
you're going to be the ones to be like
this this game is the reason to buy an
Xbox One X yes um I think when you see
this in 4 okay with our explosions with
all that bombastic Crazy Action and our
you know living graphic novel style um I
I think it's it's amazing on Xbox One X
um but also playing on Xbox One S
playing on Xbox One playing on Windows
10 and uh it was important for us also
to have crossplay across those devices
so just because you've got a friend
playing on a different device doesn't
mean you can't play co-op together
what's been the biggest challenge in
bringing Crackdown 3 to fruition I guess
I mean I think you know Crackdown has
such a devoted following um even after
you know you know it's been what 10
years since the original or so and
people it's still one of these games
that people talk about they remember
their stories um and we knew that it it
had to come back right um and so the the
focus was on taking it back to its roots
but pushing it Forward how do we change
it how do we uh add to it so it feels
like again you know every playthrough is
different um and it's that's always the
challenge with these games is trying to
bring these back and you've got to make
sure like okay this has to feel like the
original crack has to feel like a love
letter to fans of the original and I I
think that we're in a really good spot
there since it's been s years since
Crackdown 2 now that's kind of a lot of
time to be away from away from the
spotlight now Crackdown 3 is any here
are you determined to remain in the
gaming space and and say like Crackdown
is now here to stay we're not going
anywhere for a while we've got cool
stuff to show you that is absolutely my
hope I mean obviously you know we're
we're focused on uh Landing a a super
highquality campaign experience uh and
then an incredibly kind of gamechanging
competitive multiplayer experience um
and right now we're focused on that for
November 7th awesome well Clint thank
you so much for joining us uh so
November 7th November 7th Xbox One Xbox
One S uh X and S PC on on the same day
Windows 10 yep excellent thank you so
much for joining us thank you for having
me uh guys make sure you don't go
anywhere in just a few short minutes
we'll be talking about the crew too
don't go
anywhere
now
[Music]
welcome back to the gamesport stage here
at E3 2017 joining Dave and myself is
Stefan from Ivory Tower to talk about
the crew 2 welcome thanks a lot for
having me yeah what's it been like I
mean you got like a kind of tease I
think there was a financial report and
they said oh yeah the crew to's coming
and everyone was like all right that was
interesting time because everyone in the
community was just like what that's
going to be so they went crazy on every
kind of idas and we were just like yeah
yeah yeah yeah go on guys go on guys we
we have some something big for you so
yeah we're quite happy for the reveal
today uh and with a huge trailer we had
and that was a crazy reception so far so
super happy super proud I mean it's a
very very big departure from the first
game I mean so the first game it was
like driving across America and having
like the good old American road trip and
now it's like you can drive you can ride
drive a plane you can pilot a boat you
can do everything and you can change
between them so where did where did this
come from from the players actually
really from the players we saw a lot of
players inside of the crew one just
having fun going around so we had that
dark story you know in thean and that
was a bit of a forced progression but
players just didn't want that they
really want to have that huge open world
the full USA really to have fun and and
enjoy them the way they want I said okay
there's something there so we reworked
completely the anti playground the
antire USA to allow them to have fun
just basically and so the more Vehicles
the more interaction you can have with
the world the better and every test that
we do right now is super positive
players enjoy the fact that it's more
free it's just just fun you know mhm but
it seems like the um the the main story
now is is just to become there's that
called King of Motorsports thing so are
you literally just be like I want to be
number one everything it's going to be
up to you man it's just like you want to
do this okay you want to do more
exploration and don't do any races any
kind it's okay you're going to be able
to progress and earn points and continue
to unlock new content even if you're
don't do more racing stuff uh you can do
more freestyle you can be more off-road
we've opened the gates to every kind of
play style for every kind of players
here so I mean straight off the bat if I
like you boot up the crew to do you have
a car that you start with do you have a
plane or a boat or is the are these
things that we have to sort of work
through and unlock and discover by
ourselves Yeah so basically the first
five minutes you're going to play
everything you're going to play car
plane boat and then after that it's up
to you decide you want to do plane right
now okay yeah let go you want to play
alone just with planes for your all
experience in theu you can it's okay if
it's your kind of fun that's where
you're going to have fun and we have a
lot of diversity in planes and in boats
and in cars and in bikes and all that
kind of stuff it's just for any kind of
players you know we wanted to access
everything to give access to everything
for all the players instantly so no more
gating no more you have to do this and
this and this before having the game
just like go on have fun so what
challenges was as that bro taking your
vehicles just from the tarmac to huge
Open Sky and then seas and rivers all
across America like how how did how did
you build that after you know being
stuck to the road uh a lot of work
now seriously that was a huge uh intense
work for the team to recreate and
reshape the whole USA But now for all
these kind of new vehicles so uh even
the far view the graphics andine uh the
render has been improved to be sure that
now when you are flying through the sky
you have these wonderful volumetric
clouds in the sky uh you can go through
them you can see at a very far view it's
it's really a cool uh experience that is
completely different from the crean and
now you got doing this and then you you
can switch to a boat because why not you
know because you see a river you want to
go into the river do an event into the
river go there do it now it's it's as
accessible as that yeah if I wanted to
be uh you know bit of a renegade could I
take a boat and just sort of like if if
I'm in a plane can I just go boat and
then land on the on the road I mean
obviously I wouldn't get very far yeah
but I could do it yeah if you want to
have fun like that you can do it we
didn't put any restriction in this kind
of of switch because players like this
kind of situation
just having a jump with a car and then
switching to a a plane and then going on
top of the water and switching to the
boat and then doing crazy stuff trying
to jump on top of the bridge and and we
let the players go we let the players do
it because that's what they want to do
exactly so you've talked a lot about it
being open um a lot of people when they
think of a racing game they think of of
the track of the the the the black
arrows and the yellow background to take
you around corners how open is your game
if I see a hill in a forest can I just
drive there can I get to get to point A
to point B no matter like what route I
want to take yeah simple answer no
seriously it's just as simple as that
yes everything in the game is accessible
either by car by boat by plane do
whatever you want and that that's it uh
but we also build some circuits because
we have some very uh you know Pro Racing
fans in the in the community so we have
also this covered by different kind of
disciplines we have we call them the
family so we have a family for off-road
we have a family for jet spr oh sorry
for uh freestyle family for uh street
racing and a family for pro racer so
those guys if they want the perfect line
you know uh beating the seconds the the
mill seconds they have something for we
have something for them here yeah so
with these families how are you ensuring
that each family gets like enough
content that will keep them satisfied we
test we test a lot we have a lot of
players doing some play test for us
since a long time now uh so we we check
their interest and we check how they
feel with the controller uh with the new
type of vehicles do do they like it is
it too smooth to too hard Etc and we
fine tune fine tune and we continue to
do that we have a bit of phases coming
very soon for the crew two where we'll
have let lot of new players play the
game give the feedback and we'll do like
this and this and this and this is where
we have fun also as a team to really
make the game for the players not just
for us as game makers you know the what
of the biggest surprises is when you
showed that first trailer they had the
um Inception style bending of world uh
right I thought that was like that's
just a cool stylistic thing they've gone
for and then you see the game play and
the world in front of you is bending
what's happening there are we Inception
is Doctor Strange behind the wheel
what's happening we had that first idea
the first idea came from uh for the
Traer we said okay what can we do for
the Trader you know crazy idas flowing
in and just like okay bending the world
can be fun okay and then the creative
director calls me and say you know what
we should do it in game I was just like
really
man are you serious want to do that in
the game say yeah that's going to be
very fun and we tested it we had it in
the game and we're just like okay this
is so cool this is just perfect W moment
that we can do in the game that nobody
can do you know so we are just like okay
this is this is pure stuff so we need to
keep it and uh actually the players
react really strongly to that the first
time you play the demo even here at E3 I
just like whoa whoa whoa what's
happening what's that bridge doing I
just like so whe it as a transition uh
for certain type of events to move from
one type of vehicle to the other you
know more uh scripted event and stuff
like that so it gives more U you
know um how do we call that it's you
know capturing the moment and and even
stronger so you don't see that every
moment you don't click and we bend the
world just on demand because it's nice
it's a special treat every now and
again it's it's we have that here and
there and it's okay so far we're happy
with that yeah so I mean how have you
chosen how to sort of bend the world if
that makes sense so I mean in the
original game it was like a a huge map
of the us and you could visit all these
big cities and famous sites but now it
sort of seems like you know things can
fold in and can you just hop like can I
be in San Francisco and the world just
be like all right now you're in New York
well we try to keep it realistic at some
point even if ending world you know it's
just like does make sense yeah kind yeah
no no we really keep that for certain
events uh during the progression and the
story uh you're going to have these kind
of crazy events where you're going to
you know experience something very very
different and very unique so we don't
put that everywhere in the game we
really want to be special moments for
the players is it going to be explained
in the game like the main character
being like whoa what's what's happening
here why is it fun it's so it's good
yeah like how difficult is that Tech
technically to implement that was a bit
tough seriously that was a bit tough I
still remember discussion with the tech
guys they were just like no we shouldn't
do that you know it's it's not a very
good idea you know you want to do what
yeah starting night that but at the end
of the day we have that Tech that allows
us to build that huge uh country the USA
completely reshaped for us so we can use
some tricks here and there to really use
that at our advantage so that was really
fun at the end of the day what was the
choice behind staging your game in
America was it because you're kind of
familiar with with the country or was it
more of a decision that America has such
a vast array of like landmarks and
sceneries that you can go to it's it's
all comes down to a trip we did uh with
the team in the United States and to
discover more about those new motor
sports uh Rising here and there and we
wanted to really feel how those guys
were living this and we really you know
we we call our game Moto Nation that's
kind of a moto we have in the game this
is really this this is the United States
this is where all Motorsports behave and
live and evolve to Crazy new races on on
Ice Lake and whatnot and it's just like
this is this is where it's happening
right now so we had that huge playground
already for the crew one we've kipped it
and we decided okay like how we can make
it even better so we've reshaped
everything now in the city you have
jumps going on rooftops of New York
buildings because it's fun and you know
going through parking lots to find
shortcuts we really reshaped everything
in the world just for the fun of the new
vehicles and even for the existing
vehicles to be just you know fun uh
let's talk a little bit in terms of so
as a player what can I do like what can
I can I just go up to a family uh like
event and just take part in it or is
there some kind of story progression
that I can follow or can I just drive
around fly around uh and just find my
own path so we we going give more
details in the future regarding
progression I'm sorry I've been told not
to give more details I'm sorry no
seriously we have that very open
progression system where you can go into
the four families it's not a choice that
you are stuck in and then you have to do
all the stuff before moving it's just
today you want to do more off-road okay
go there you're going to do events for
the off-road family uh tomorrow you're
more freestyler in the in your mood okay
you can go there and I have new events
New Challenges for you I discover new
disciplines in that family so it's
really open really the the way you want
uh in that particular session if
tomorrow it's different it's okay you
can switch there's there's no
restriction it's more like a support for
people to understand the vast majority
of the you know the variety of of
content that we have so we have the
families the disciplines it's there for
you to understand but it's not a locker
you know you just you have you allowed
to do what what you want this huge
playground you've got is it is it kind
of segmented in in different areas or
can I literally drive from the west
coast of America all the way to the east
coast if I had enough time so you can
drive you can fly you can do it by boat
if you want we created actually a a a
river Network that goes west to east
coast the entire breadth of the United
States yeah if you wanted to buy boat
and just have fun and you can do it we I
think we even did it on North to South
because it's cool because even that
doesn't exist in real life that made
sense in the game so we said okay let's
do it because we saw the players in the
one doing it with the bikes and and the
cars which we need to support that also
for the new type of vehicles just let
the exploration uh uh exist and people
embracing it the way they want so yeah
how long is that going to take me though
if I decide to take a road trip from San
Fran to New York that's going to be
around 3 to four hours wow just constant
driving yeah that's amazing clear out
your schedule you can take the small
roads the big RADS whatever you want
Offroad if you want yeah uh another big
part of the first game was obviously the
social features like being able to group
up with my friends and race how are you
implementing that into the crew too so
basically we keep the crew concept as a
whole between the crew one and the crew
two so you'll still be able to group
together form a group of four
four players and do every activity
together so that can be more Co-op that
can be more PVP but basically everything
is playable by four so that's the base
that's the crew that's who we are uh but
we've re worked a lot on on connectivity
and network uh between the two the crew
one and the crew two obviously to make
sure that everyone is allowed to group
more easily uh than we had in the first
one so we really reshaped that uh to be
sure that you know people can embrace it
are there going to be any uh sort of
bonuses for veteran in crew one players
if they open up in crew two oh yes so we
love our community it's just like you
know they they love us they love them
it's just like okay we we thought about
a new system a new reward program for
them so we said okay what can be uh a
good you know measurement of their
engagement said well we have
achievements so we can unlock you new
vehicles in The Crew 2 waiting for you
if you have unlocked certain type of
achievements in the crew one saying you
are more an Explorer you have unlocked
those achievements you have vehicles
waiting for you in the crew two and that
can go up to 18 vehicles for free
waiting for you when you get the First
Time In The Crew 2 so it's it's our way
to say thank you thank you for playing
so hard in the crew one yeah in the
spectrum of racing games um they're kind
of defined with like an arcade style
that's for fun and a simulator style
that's like very tactile and very
precise where does the crew crew 2 sit
in that or have you kind of got elements
of both we we're much more on the AR St
definitely we don't want to go into the
simulation side there are all the guys
doing it really well and we respect them
for that but on our side is pure fun
accessibility take the pad have fun and
just drive you know Drive ride pilot
whatever you want now you know yeah so
AR card is definitely our main focus
yeah so is Ivory Tower the lead
developer the solo developer because I
mean a lot of the times with Ubisoft you
have so many studios and everyone kind
of pitches in so so we're walking yeah
we're working with a lot of people
inside of Ubisoft so we have people from
Shanghai from Bucharest in Romania uh
people from Paris from even a massive
studio in in Sweden is working with us
so it's a huge team that's the strengths
of Ubisoft here where we can put a lot
of people playing uh working and playing
actually together sometimes uh to really
create that huge powerful uh Team to
deliver this kind of impressive scope
you know yeah uh and in terms of engine
what are you using we're using our own
engine that was Al already used for the
crew one that we've biffed up a bit you
know and you see now the graphics that
looks amazing the vegetation have been
reworked completely also so we really
push the envelope here yeah so now the
crew one had hundreds of vehicles you
did a great job of really expanding that
garage you've added two more elements
the the entire ocean and rivers and the
sky how many vehicles we going to be
getting in the crew to
more the real answer is much more much
yeah no figures no we don't have the
real figures right now because we are
still working with the the licensers and
working that huge lineup that we want to
have and as much as we have all the
details we we'll communicate on that so
far we we're still hard at work on this
yeah how has that been working with a
lot of uh licensed like Motorsports and
engines and different man manufacturers
I'm guessing there must be some people
that you approach to be like you want to
put our weird vehicles in game because
like helicopters for example not a lot
of helicopters in games where like
McLaren and Fords I'm sure that they're
used to that sort of thing did you ever
get anyone being like um I guess going
to put a helicopter or play in the game
show well you know as soon as you show
what you want to do with those vehicles
in the game they are just like oh that
can be cool and they understand and we
value them you know we're not here to
destroy their vehicles we're not here to
make them look bad you know so they are
super happy to see their creation inside
of that huge world and the players
having fun with them so we really
respect those licensers those
manufacturers and they return the the
the favor they really like us and we
have a very very good partnership with
them now we use the words destruction
you are you adding much in the way of
Destruction physics into your game when
are cars going to end up beat up if I
decide to drop one off a cliff so we'll
still have a bit of distraction on the
vehicles but we we are a bit lighter now
because we we went very far on the crew
one and even the the community was just
like uh don't destroy my Porsches like
it's so beautiful I was like okay okay
so now the distinction aspect is much
lighter because we really want to
respect and and you know Embrace those
wonderful vehicles that we have in the
game so yeah is that also an element of
kind of keeping the fun and exploration
alive you don't want players to be
worrying about destroying their car if
they want to do something exactly
exactly we really want the players to
have fun in the world the way they want
so we don't we removed a lot of
obstacles will it be on progression in
the world everywhere it's just like
hoing the gates really the crw just
seems incredi ambitious and huge what's
been the biggest challenge in realizing
that Vision oh my God that's a tough
question I don't know uh yeah recreating
the world for us that was a huge huge
huge work because we wanted to be uh
completely refreshed so that means a lot
of assets a lot of work to be done on
the cities uh everywhere the landmarks
read on so it's a huge work but it's a
fantastic work because now we see the
result here we we are showing Manan
completely rebuilt and everyone is just
like that's not the same as before
exactly that's the point exactly yeah
how are you building your world when it
comes to to online am I going to be able
to if I if I want to take a road trip
and again using the example of San Fran
to to New York and a guy across the
world's driving New York to sanran are
we going to cross paths is it going to
be a whole connected thing or is it
going to be more of a party base yeah
it's definitely an up world and a
connected up world so you can drive solo
if you want never party with anyone but
you may cross other players we are
sessioning you with with other players
dynamically so you always feel that you
are online and you have players around
you if you don't want to do any activity
with those guys it's okay you're going
to be able to do your own experience and
if you want to party and create a crew
that's where an extra level of fun is is
coming so it's really up to you but
you're going to be always online and
always connected to everyone in the game
yeah if I want to drop into a race with
one of my buddies and say he's in like
the Central America like Texas area and
I'm stuck maybe far away I can just be
like all right I'm here and if even if
he's doing a race with vehicles that you
don't own a kind of discipline you don't
own we're going to loan you one going be
able to play it if you like it then
continue to enjoy it and replay it if
you want if you want to buy one and make
it you know we have a progression system
around the car you know leveling system
then you can purchase uh you know
entrylevel vehicle in that kind of
discipline and then continue to progress
It's really again accessibility have fun
you know opening the gates for everyone
you talk about buying Vehicles is that
going to going to be something done with
in-game currency you earn or is that
going to be a purchasable
microtransaction or is it something
that's naturally progressed it's
basically both we we keep the same logic
that we had in the Quan we have that
kind of dual currency free currency that
you can earn by doing any kind of
activity if you want to go faster you
have the paid currency nothing is locked
behind a paid wall uh un there is no
Unique Kind of vehicles that you can
only get for pay currency we really give
the players the choice and yeah it's a
so far the reaction in on the Kwan has
been very good so we don't want to
change anything that works it's okay is
it difficult to balance sort of um the
Pay to Win sort of aspect you know there
is I mean there is one but it is
difficult to sort of plan to avoid that
basically everything that is regarding
um uh gaml is not around
microtransaction so you cannot be better
just by paying more it's just impossible
in the game everything is planned as an
LPG system and so if you have time
you're going to progress if you have
money you're going to going to progress
we you're not going to be better by
paying or not paying you know it's as
basic as that you got to get good yeah
and we have some good players when we
are doing some tests like they're
they're crazy good like they're trashing
us it's so bad with your best players is
it going to be um like maybe seasonal
competitions or kind of like an Esports
element that you're going to be looking
into to really get the best of the best
in there it's a bit early to talk about
that I'm
sorry sounds like you got a lot more up
your sleeve then no seriously yes we are
releasing early 2018 so we have a lot of
things to discuss uh right now we are
really opening the gates and showing the
game and the huge world that we are
rebuilding and all the crazy vehicles
that we have but it's only the beginning
we have much more to talk about so we
just like okay can't wait to talk more
about all those kind of filaments here
so it's playable on the show floor here
at E3 yes when are the folks at home
going to get a chance to play are there
going to be some betas coming I'm
English so that really hurts to say
betas
[Laughter]
so yeah we already announced basically a
new beta program beta
beta that is uh now open basically you
can register right now and we're going
to announce the First Dates very soon uh
that's going to be you know we like we
like the players we want the players to
test that the game and give the feedback
so we can find tune behind so we're
going to have a lot of uh different beta
phases coming down before the release
yes stepan thank you so much for joining
us we can't wait to play thanks a lot uh
for more on the crew to obviously keep
your eyes peeled to gamespot.com but
don't go anywhere very shortly we'll be
speaking to Chris Chara from the ID at
Xbox program and player unknown himself
so don't go
[Music]
anywhere
this year in style with a real life
Bethesda Land There was Vault boy
statues Revenant statues and a ferris
wheel I missed it all but what I didn't
miss was the video games usually Jess
would be here to help me out but she was
hosting a live stream and speaking of
which make sure you're subscribed so you
see all of our news coming out of e3 but
for now let's dig into
it everything Bethesda spoke about at
their showcase will be coming out this
year and they started off with two
virtual reality Games if you can handle
the motion sickness Doom is bringing
massive guns to your virtual Space
Marine gauntlets and plenty of baddies
to point them at with doom VFR Gates of
Hell not your speed you'll be able to
walk the Wasteland build settlements and
battle super mutants in Fallout 4 VR
when it launches this October it's worth
noting that the entire game will be
playable in VR speaking a Fallout
there'll be a steady stream of new
content for both it and Skyrim via the
newly announced creation Club things
like new armor weapons and gameplay
enhancements made by Bethesda and
collaborating outside creators will all
be purchasable with coins when the
service arrives this summer on PS4 Xbox
One and PC if you're playing Elder
Scrolls Legends then good news the card
game is getting dark brotherhood story
content in-game tournaments and a chaos
Arena most excitingly a Heroes of Skyrim
expansion will hit the game on the 29th
of June when it arrives on IOS and
Android Android so soon let's keep that
Skyrim trainer rolling the long awaited
Nintendo switch version of Skyrim was
shown off along with some very Nintendo
features you'll be able to cosplay in
Link's breath of the wild tunic as well
as wield the master sword by tapping
your link amiibo there are also motion
controls for swords Shields and Bows
which looks pretty damn cool
unfortunately no concrete release date
has been announced for this one yet but
keep an eye on Nintendo's press
conference for that Dishonored to is
getting some DLC in the form of death of
the outsider it stars the quest Giver
from the main game Megan Foster as she
teams up with Dow from the original
Dishonored knife of dunwell DLC the pair
appear to be teaming up to kill the
outsider the source of the character's
Powers Megan Foster looks to be every
bit as formidable as Emily and corvo 2
as she teleports through walls and
skulls around behind enemies the DLC is
set for release on September 15 Bethesda
also used their showcase to position
Quake Champions as a major esport they
announced a sponsored competition for
August 26 during Quake con that will
have a $1 million prize if you want to
get some practice in the beta has been
reopened indefinitely and you can sign
up on the website right now go go go go
go go go go go Bethesda closed their
2017 Showcase with two new games The
Evil Within 2 and Wolfenstein 2 The New
Colossus The Evil Within 2 will launch
on October 13 this year and is being
developed by the devs of the original
Tango Gameworks it was revealed via a
cinematic trailer that looks as
psychologically freaky as you'd expect
from Resident Evil Creator Shinji Mami
the protagonist from the first game is
returning this
time out the show was Wolfenstein to the
new coloss and it just might be my
favorite reveal after a fake TV show
about a girl and a giant robot dog BJ
blaskowitz was revealed to be still
alive and Nazis have taken over America
there's crazy jewal wielding weapons and
a comrad who yep it's more of the same
crazy started with the New Order and you
won't have to wait as it releases on
October 27 this year BJ will also make
the jump to Quake Champions where he'll
have his
own now the
top we will see you
[Music]
tomorrow
he
[Music]
oh
he hey everyone welcome back to the gam
s stage here at E3 2017 joining Dave and
myself two faces you might recognize
from Xbox's E3 press briefing we have
Brandon green player on own himself
welcome thanks very much and Chris
charot from the ID at Xbox program hey
welcome so guys big E3 for ID Xbox big
E3 for Xbox absolutely where should we
grounds
coming that is a big get not only for
xbo
the Xbox One X has be anyway so yeah
can't on that you guys have been doing a
really great job at supporting and and
optimizing your game for for PC at least
you've had that Mantra of a of a monthly
update yeah is that going to be the same
going to console or is it like will
versions always be tied together um I'd
like to think so but again I'm not I'm
not 100% on our our development plans
for that but you know we we have a
pretty yeah as I said active development
we have weekly and and monthly updates
and you know I'm sure that will carry
over to Xbox as well so how did this uh
sort of new partnership come
about I we saw the game awesome um you
know we've um we've known the folks at
Blue Hole for a little while obviously
they do Tera and everything and uh and
then the game's fantastic so was over in
Korea and met up and
there you go yeah so do we know the
extent of the is it going to be XBox
exclusive in terms of consoles or is it
it's a conso launch exclusive so it'll
be in when it's in uh Xbox game preview
awesome uh so I mean what are the
challenges in bringing it to console
well again it's a it's a massive open
world it's like 8 by8 with 100 players
which in itself is a challenge but
onreal is a great engine for that and
and like we have it running on Scorpio
already and it runs relatively stably
right like we're getting a pretty solid
30 FPS on on which is like for a game
that we haven't really spent a lot of
time optimizing yet I mean it's it's a
great start yeah for a game that's it's
obviously heavily influenced by like the
online community like like twitch um you
guys have also been well Xbox been
talking about mixer are you going to be
implementing the whole mixer thing with
that as well and having elements of that
in there yeah yeah I mean we want to do
across all the the streaming platforms
you know we want to provide support for
them all I mean yeah I mean that was the
thing that you guys dropped was it this
morning that um because of that the guy
on was it YouTube who had uh players
like friends coming in to be zombies you
guys are now introducing zombies yeah so
we we saw this on on YouTube where they
had zombie modes in our custom games and
when we were in prag doing motion
capture we decided right let's capture
some zombie animations just to have it
and then myself and the animator sat
down over the 3 days before E3 just made
a quick video showing off the the zombie
animations we've no plans for them like
set plans for them yet but they'll be
player controlled which is going to be
interesting you know it's it's not just
AI it's 100 players running at you um
that's awesome right if we hope the um
the element of like the twitch Partners
when it comes to PC and they can create
their their custom games is that going
to be something that also carries over
to console are we going to be able to
join in with our favorite streamers
doing things like that not sure yet I
mean it's it's certainly possible
absolutely it's kind of thing we'd love
to include and so I'm sure we'll be all
be looking at it yeah we want to do deep
integration with all the streaming sites
so like e easy for Content creators to
play with their their fan base and stuff
like that and you know our our partner
program is like it's not just for twitch
Partners it's for like community members
that do a good job and for bigger
communities and land events and stuff
like that and you know it's yeah know
it's a it's a great way to see what they
come up with how has it been seeing the
community's reaction when you're adding
things that in any other game might be a
small change like just tweaks to
movement and weather and the community
goes nuts for it because those small
elements are actually changing your game
so much a a map when it's raining is a
completely different experience to a map
when it's sunny like how does that feel
oh no but this is what we want we want
like that sort of depth of gameplay that
like every match you play is different
and you know with we're adding three
more weather settings in and and you
know that's just again going to
guarantee that okay it's a foggy map
you're not going to be play able to play
as a sniper so much this round and and
really try to get people out of their
comfort zones and and challenge them in
the game yeah as a fan I it's a huge
deal right because like you would play
this game totally at least I play this
game totally differently than I would
play like a traditional First Person
Shooter or something like that like I'm
sitting there usually turtling hiding
camping depending what word you want to
I judge I play the same way and and just
like staring at the environment for
anything to move and so you know if it's
foggy or it's raining that actually
makes a huge difference so I mean I
honestly can't wait for foggy weather
and zombies you know that's just going
to be just yeah very even more intense
we play a lot in the office there's been
a lot of palms and shaky hands at the
end of a game there's been some Curt
words yes I am well known for swearing
at the end of a round I apologize for
that Soul brings it out in all of us
yeah exactly um how is uh how have you
had to adapt the game for for console
when you're when you're playing on PC at
least it feels like it's almost designed
for for a PC the way the inventory
system works the way the movement works
the way uh leaning around corners works
and everything like that how how are you
changing that for for console is there
any challenges any tweaks you've had to
make for like a game pad well no let it
like we're going to be talking with you
guys about like the best way to move
forward with this and you know we know
it's important to get a really good
solid control especially for a shooter
you know you needs good movement
controls and stuff like that I'm working
with these guys I mean they have the
experience of of doing it for many other
games so yeah and I actually tested on
Gamepad and I got a top five which is
actually the best score I've ever gotten
so maybe gam pad's like the was that a
game PC players as well
yeah I was actually playing against the
the theory of PC controls with let me
debunk it just up into this like I saw
you like I'm a I'm a camper and so I did
quite well I got top five then I
actually had to like came face to face
with someone else I did not get top
four well you're going to be
implementing things like assisted aiming
for when it's very much console then
we'll probably have to do something we
want to try to get it to a like I think
was a destiny have a really good feeling
and that's the kind of aim we're going
for is that it just feels feels solid
you know that it doesn't feel like
cheating you know but it feels solid you
know it's yeah so with Xbox um a big
thing that you guys are doing these days
is like play anywhere like crossplatform
play is that going to be implemented
with console
version it's up to these guys I'm sure
we'll try it I mean uh we'll see how it
goes like it's possible the Unreal
Engine allows you to do this you know
and it's possible to do cross across all
platforms so you know we'll see um yeah
yeah I think there's just a lot of
things about Gamepad versus mouse and
keyboard that you know you want to make
sure that no one has a leg up to the
other exactly yeah and you guys
obviously you're in Early Access at the
moment and you've you've said previously
you've not really given yourselves a
landmark date it's kind of coming out
when you're happy with it and when it's
ready but you know when abouts the the
console players are going to get their
hands on it well we said like later this
year I mean we don't want to give any
certainty because you know that comes
with problems you know you say this
thing and then you have to delay it so
it's later this year you know we want to
make sure that it's solid it's the same
as like when we were going from uh our
closed beta into Early Access you know
that we wanted like the game that was
sold in Early Access to be pretty stable
you know and it has been pretty stable
since launch so you know we still have
to improve a lot of stuff but that's the
same we want to go for console make sure
it's stable and playable you know um go
from there yeah so how long have you
guys ID Xbox been involved in this
project has it kind of been a secret
behind the things yeah it has been like
I haven't like uh I have like carefully
not tweeted about the game
playing a ton of it and because I well I
don't want to jinx things or you know
what I mean so uh so it's really nice to
be able to tell the world about it and
uh have you on stage and and it's just
been really really cool but yeah we've
been we've been fans really since the
beginning so yeah and what's your
involvement now are you kind of helping
these guys develop it for console
alongside the development for for PC or
is it kind of develop it for PC and then
move it to console these guys are the
developers and so but we're here to you
know like there's things like Hey how do
what's the best practices for controller
what's the best practices you know for
lots of different things on Xbox
achievements you know all sorts of
things like that and so we're sort of
here to consult on that but like we're
not the creators you know by any means
like these are the these are the guys so
I mean we have uh so the Xbox uh version
has been done by a company called antito
they're based in Spain they do the
character customization system we have
mutable um it's middleware and they're
handling most of the Xbox work um so you
know the the PC version has its own team
and the Xbox version has its own team we
have like our 3D replay system in game
and that has its own like we employed a
small Korean company to come in and be
on site and do that just that for us so
you know we're we're expanding the team
to be able to do all these projects
without having to split like you know
some of the PC guys go and work on Xbox
it doesn't happen like that it's like we
have our own teams for every individual
thing so it'll be good for development
one thing I love about ID at Xbox is the
the variety of games that you guys
always have unshown I think this year's
press conference for Xbox was a great
display of that what apart from
Battlegrounds what are the other big
wins that you guys have had this oh I
mean there's some amazing games I think
there was um well there was 42 games
that were shown in the uh the Xbox brief
just 42 yeah only 42 and I think uh more
than 25 of those were ID Xbox games or
you know titles from independent
developers and so just like you I love
the variety there's really something for
everybody on Xbox coming from the ID
program so you've got you know games for
people are really interested in
competitive multiplayer and you've also
got games like oetz which I don't know
if you guys have seen but it's just a
super beautiful uh like I a cute game
where you're it's like a farming
simulator and you're raising these cute
little animals and it's just it's just
awesome and but you know whether it's
adventure or action or exploration there
really is like sort of something from
everyone from from the program so it's
been cool when you reach out to
developers what are you looking for are
you looking for you know a game that'll
maybe fill a hole that you think the
Xbox lineup has or you looking just for
that that one great idea I think we're
really just looking for you know it goes
both ways we have a lot of developers
reaching out to us all the time and then
of course it shows like E3 and packs and
Gamescom and even smaller shows you know
we're out there constantly looking for
cool things and we're just looking for
things that are going to you know
honestly like Delight Xbox players and
and because there's such a wide variety
of players that can be anything you know
it can be a really hardcore game it can
be a really Niche game it could be a
game from a 200 person team it can be a
game from like a you know one man or one
woman team and um you know I I wish I
could tell you exactly what the formula
was for like Hey how do we find a game
that we think is really special because
if I could write it down would it be
it'd be easier but instead we just you
know you you just know when you see them
they're just like oh like that one's got
the something the the it Factor yeah and
and it's actually quite it's quite cool
to see that other Publishers are doing
the same thing you've got like the
squarex collective for example or you
have uh Sony's X Dev program what's it
like and why why do you think people
come to you because you've got some
really good good games on yeah I mean I
think it's it's it's amazing to see in
the sort of maybe like I guess almost
nine years since kind of the Indie Games
burst into the mainstream with that
first summer of arcade on Xbox Live
arcade back on the 360 um you know just
watching the growth of the industry has
been fantastic and watching the growth
of Indies and of course there's like you
know tons of great developers out there
and tons of great options for them
whether it's you know working with a
third- party publisher working with a
platform holder you know for us at Ide
at Xbox we see our job is just to make
developers lives as easy as possible you
know we want to make sure players have
this great variety of games and that
means make developers lives Easy Share
as much information with them as
possible and just you know and and and
we'll get the games and and so far seems
to be working and obviously there's
always lots to do we're always working
on improving but you know just trying to
be as you know as as as true to
developers as we can and as focused on
making life easy for them as possible
really seems to to to have resonated and
as a developer what's that like to have
you know this huge company like Xbox who
are right behind you like yeah we' I
know it's great I mean like I mean
having that support and having like the
help and advice that they give us is is
you know it's invaluable it really is
and now obviously this is like your
third game at this point well sort of
did mods and stuff in the past connected
to to armor and King of the kill what is
it like now it's kind of you've gone
from strength to strength you're now
your game is like the most played thing
on Twitch right now you've got like the
backing of massive companies how's that
how's that been it's pretty good uh no I
mean I I'm really like I mean I'm
holding my celebration like it's nice
the success we've seen you know we
passed 3 million copies sold on PC which
is insane to me but uh you know it's
it's really it's I'll be happy once we
have a stable platform there for games
and then I'll I'll celebrate you know we
have we've still got months work to do
uh you know on the game and stuff like
that and it's the success is great but
it's really just you know Made Us Baton
down the hatches and kind of go okay
let's get this finished yeah I was going
to say because with so many more eyes on
you the pressure must be oh yeah I mean
we're but we're happy like we have our
plan you know we're we have a really
strong development team like our
executive producer Chen Kim he he's just
a very clever man like you you've met
him and he just awesome he plans
everything down to like the finest
detail and as a result we've been able
to do this development at like a hair's
Pace well I was going to say uh like
Early Access kind of has almost a bad
reputation these days because some games
can remain in kind of a a fluxed state
for such a long time but I've I've been
playing your game for a long time now
it's it doesn't feel like an any access
game it just it feels like a finished
product but but that was our plan like
as I said like you know I saw a lot of
games going into Early Access and I felt
it was sort of like a poison in pill
almost that you know that if you say
this people are immediately going to
judge your game and it happens you know
it's it's natural but you know we wanted
to have a really stable game going into
Early Access you know because we're
using as like Early Access beta that
we're using it for optimization and
performance tuning and this kind of
stuff are you still holding true to that
original Mantra of you will build
optimization stability before adding
like big gameplay elements or things
like Cosmetics I I mean like we'll we
have focused on optimization so far
we're we're going to be adding cosmetics
after we launch we may have to add the
system in like a month or so before we
go Lo just to test it you know but in
general yeah we're focused on
optimization we're focused on finishing
the platform you know and then we'll
worry about monetization and all that
kind of stuff a question I have been
asked while streaming myself um people
have asked will you keep the Cosmetics
that you've earned now when the game
launches you should do yeah yeah that me
keep my nice Coke I was going to say
we're going to keep the coke yeah you'll
be able to keep that all the way through
and we may reset the points and stuff
like that but I comeing have already
access but the the skins we don't see
any reason to uh give away or take away
what is with that coat why is that
lorded so highly it's it's like worth
$800 on Steam right now what's the coat
about I don't know it's it's it's just a
rare coat it's like it was our pre-order
uh you know we had limited numbers and
as a result it's it's but this is what
want we want from our skin economy is
that you do have Rarity you do have that
chance to get a great skin from getting
a case you know that it's I think it
rewards people for playing the game that
quotes my re reement fund now I sat in
my steam inventory just getting
healthier and
healthier what was it like stepping out
on the on the stage at the Xbox PR
conference nerve-wracking as all hell uh
should have done in a ghilly suit I know
right uh no it it was great though
because we had like um what's his name
Dirk is it Durk uh someone uh he like a
speech coach and you know that we had
four or five rehearsals and you know it
was all done so clinically and so well
that you know I was really nervous it
cuz the the the the penultimate
rehearsal they had actually people
sitting out front and before that it was
just you were kind of doing it to an
empty Hall and that was fine and then
doing it to like people you're like
nervous but then when I actually did the
thing just a huge sense of relief you
know I was going all I can do is up
know it's like that's all I can do and I
didn't and I was just you didn't get MD
no I was happy no no big mistakes you
know it's don't be a meme it's like the
only advice you can give anybody but it
was great cuz in the green room we had
all the the speakers and you know when
we were going out big clap you know you
can do it and came back in and everyone
did their piece pretty much you know
perfectly there was no major screw-ups
at all from anyone which was was great
yeah was awesome yeah so you're not
really releasing any you're just saying
later this year you're when it's ready
basically yeah exactly when when we're
we're happy with the build we have but
later this year is the plan but in terms
of other ID Xbox titles we've got Tacoma
coming out very soon yeah Tacoma on
August 2nd cup SE 29th September 29th I
don't know what camera I supposed to
look at but yeah pre-order now it's
awesome we're super happy for those guys
uh and that game is just looking like
spectacular I still have to figure out
what what's the one um escape from oh
The Artful
Escape that game is have you guys seen
it have not watch that trailer and tried
to figure out what it's about it's
amazing it's playable in the uh in the
Xbox booth and it's just uh like a a a
just an
unbelievable Journey game it's like
Monty p
movie basically in the game it's
snowboarding an air guitar right
something that might be fun for you to
do we've got a player unknown
Battleground playable at our booth
downstairs oh really if you go
downstairs and get a chicken dinner in
front of people imagine my hero yeah
yeah no I I can't do that I I would fail
um you're not telling me you've never
got chicken dinner in your own game oh I
have but I've been carried by my
team that's the only reason I got top
five yeah exactly it's right well I
don't I don't mind I don't mind my
teammates if they're if they're good
chicken dinner's chicken dinner oh there
it is oh here oh yes I remember this cuz
I I thought it looked um like double
findy actually yeah uh it's from uh anos
the publisher and uh those are a great
crew and the game is just like it's
impossible to play this demo without
like just having a huge smile on your
face at the end and like same with
watching the video it's just there's
just something really special about this
when I saw the trailer I was like is
John Lennon somehow made a game pretty
much Johnny Galvatron so that's an
incredible name I might change my name
to that you can I'd go for that um
another one that I thought L really cool
is Ashen yeah ashen's awesome from uh
from Aurora 44 down in New Zealand like
um you know we showed that a couple
years ago on stage I think I teased it a
little bit everybody got really excited
and those guys have been heads down
since then just working on it and you
look at this game and like the art is
just unbelievable and then what they're
doing with just the environment and then
actually then you start to play the game
and it's like holy cow like this game is
going to be I think this is really
really something special and and uh and
super creepy and but it's going to be a
really really fun title M it kind of
looks like it has elements of of Dark
Souls but is also kind of adding a more
uh presence of Co-op to it yeah yeah
that's exactly right it's going to have
it's definitely going to have co-op and
it but it's definitely got that sort of
Dark Souls sort of vibe and I think it's
not going to be um a super easy game to
play like I think it's it's going to
have some challenge in there for players
is that the new ID Xbox Mantra where
you're getting games that are really
hard to play cuz player Unown you've got
this just stressing everyone out now top
head the Battlegrounds is is not hard to
play it's easy it's hard to win hard
it's hard to win it's hard to win
however I do recommend camping is a is a
good strategy if you want to get a you
know top 20 like if you want to win like
I don't care how many kills you get if
you came in the second you still lost
you know it's like you know if you win
it doesn't matter how you do it you just
win there is no bad strategy there is no
right way to play the game have you seen
the uh very outlandish strategies of
some of the players that been trying to
do different things like uh a pair one a
game of Battlegrounds without getting a
kill yes someone Beat It by only using a
car mhm are you expecting the Xbox
players to kind of get even more insane
with it then oh yeah I think they're can
be some fun achievement design too I was
just going to I was just going to say
there could be some some fun to be heard
some pun name punny achievement titles
cuz we I was talking with someone like
that they were they had a custom game of
just pans and and grenades right so
that's it was pans and grenades and I
was talking well maybe we should make
the pan that it can deflect grenades so
you can like bath the grenade away and
play some you know grenade handball yeah
yeah gr tennis there you go that' be
great that's a whole mode right Frying
Pan Is the End Game loot in that game
I've been saved before by being shot in
the back and hanging off my frying pan
and that was like a ninja commit by one
of our developers he told no one he was
putting it in he just worked it and then
the next day was like see your your
ninja Kami got made the the front page
of PC Gamer it's like oh okay do more
are you kind of embracing that that idea
in in your development team being like
just do stuff that is going to be kind
of outlandish but hey see if it works oh
yeah like we we trust like our our
various teams to kind of like if they
they believe in a good enough idea and
they bring it to us we'll run with it
you know it's like they we're very much
there is no right way to do it it's like
come with an idea and if it works it
works has there been any ideas that have
been even too outlandish that you've had
to be like all right we're crazy I've
had a few that I've had to politely tell
them why it's not a good idea but uh
give us a few give us your oh no not
just little things like you know having
the the Blue Zone Play Zone in different
shapes which a circle is good because
it's balanced you know having it like a
octagon and stuff like that I have to be
dead diplomatic and kind of go no no if
you're stuck in the corner of a square
just being like oh God oh
God well guys thank you so much for
coming on we're very excited to play
even more player on by grounds thanks
for that's basically yeah that's all my
computer's used for at this point thanks
for that guys uh but thank you so much
and uh make sure you stay tuned here on
the Gamespot stream we're going to be
going to the co-op stage on the show
floor at E3 where kind of funny you're
going to be talking to Marvel games
hopefully about Spider-Man stay
tuned
[Music]
sure I sure can oh look you got a whole
bunch of people to sign this already
man
ch
[Applause]
now
what's up everybody welcome to E3 2017
kind of funny games on The Game Spot
Co-op stage I'm one of your hosts for
the day Greg Miller alongside the pure
one Tim Gettys let's him
host the Bros from Marvel games Hello
friends Mike Jones
who and and my better half Bill Roseman
Bill Roseman creative director marble
games and a giant audience of people who
I said to go crazy and I'm not super
stoked yet so
again yeah all right all right all not
all right stop it I feel like you need
to like we need to focus your craziness
on something so ladies and gentlemen
give a round of applause for Tera Bruno
right there in the audience there we go
Terra Bruno
yeah now we're talking what an E3 it's
been Tim oh my God I think at the top of
everyone's list of amazing they've
amazing spectacular would you say I
would say ultim Ultimate Spider-Man oh
my God so many Des scriptors yeah right
many uh what do we think of Spider-Man
so far from what you guys are seeing
like it like it good footage good
footage it is unbelievable there it is
what do you guys what do you guys think
of the white spider good good now Greg
Miller over here has a lot of thoughts
on why I get I since you've debuted it I
understood when Insomniac debuted I
totally got it and today when we were
getting our behind closed doors demo
from Brian he drove it home like we want
you to look at it and say oh it's
Spider-Man but see it and say oh that's
not a Spider-Man I immediately know I
need to understand it who it is and now
it's insomniacs exactly for I mean for
all of our games when we work with our
partners we want them to bring their
Vision to the game uh uh and we want
when when they approach the Marvel
characters we want them to be very
familiar and identifiable but also
unique and ownable for each game so when
you see Spider-Man it's not just any
Spider-Man like that's Spider-Man from
Marvel Spider-Man on PS4 yeah we're
building a new universe Within oniac a
new Spider-Man you're telling a new
story right so we want to make sure that
it still feels right but it's new and
different you don't know what's going to
happen I mean we did a huge study of the
costume because you know we we think
Spider-Man is one of the if not the best
designed superhero costumes of all time
damn so if we change anything we want to
understand what the original suit did
what does the red mean what the blue
means the white all the elements even
the spokes on the mask how many should
there be so really we St studied it and
before we changed anything we just said
how can we analyze it how can we add
something to it but still respect Stan
Lee Steve dicko Jita senior and all the
great creators who made that suit What
It Is Well what I loved about them Brian
talking about it today because he's
doing the developer thing we're not
talking about this hey who else are
there any you're not going to get any
secrets from us I don't want to not
looking for the secrets I'm
complimenting you we protect the secrets
I'm saying what he was saying though
that kind of started bringing me around
on the suit on the white spider was he's
like somebody asked in the crowd how
much Liberty has Marvel given you to
play with it and he's like well as long
as we can justify anything we're doing
that's how we do it and he's like
there's a reason the suit looks like the
suit yeah and so I understand of course
I'm I'm saying stick with meing with
Uncle Ben had some kind of white spider
business it was his logo and now he's
keeping on right not canon not canon I
actually have a side white spider
business if you guys want to buy some oh
you're selling white white spider sounds
awesome so my favorite thing is uh so
Brian the creative director on the game
his passion was so obvious not just from
him talking about the game but showing
it in just every little detail how
stoked and hyped he was for how
Spider-Man it looked and felt like you
can just see looking at this you're like
oh man they nailed it like within 5
Seconds you're like they got it right
yeah Brian and the team and Insomniac
are incredible and they're all like
super passionate about and then from day
one just immerse themselves in
Spider-Man and we're lucky because we're
just right down the road from insomnia
games our office is like 10 minutes away
from their office and I or twice a week
get to visit them we get to see stuff in
progress we get to talk about the story
we get to talk about the gameplay we get
to talk about the suit design and it's
not just for the show it's palpable
every day yeah in there how much they
love Spider-Man and how much they care
we all care so deeply about I mean
everybody remembers when they first met
Spider-Man their first experience with
Spider-Man I had a cardboard standing of
Spider-Man in my bedroom growing up I
was an artist in a former life which
still hangs by the way in my mom's
seventh grade classroom um and so
Spider-Man's a very important character
to everybody and like none of that is
lost on on anybody in Insomniac and it
shows yeah I mean the the the first
lunch we we got together we were sitting
around talking about Hey when's the
first time you experienced Spider-Man
and we all realized that when we were
all six years old we all had the same
Spider-Man underu yeah so we we have
loved this character all our lives and
we really live and breathe that idea of
power and responsibility and and and
Bill's son's name is Peter just in case
you had any question go level of
dedication we're talking about yeah so
now we jumped right into this it's E3
we're excited Spider-Man what I don't
didn't do a good job for everybody
watching at home is to explain who you
guys are oh yeah let's rewind it your
Marvel games so we're Marvel games we're
out here uh in Glendale we are here uh
about two and a half years ago yeah uh
they kind of reassembled the Marvel
games team uh I came from the East Coast
I've been lucky enough to be working
with Marvel in publishing since the
early 90s 90s I started writing for
Marvel age magazine and then I joined
the staff and became a copywriter then
started writing comics and then started
editing Comics had that long run and uh
BS being modest he edited all the
Guardians of the Galaxy Comics that
became the inspiration for the films
yeah he did put that team yeah he did
Bill right so I remembered Rocket
Raccoon when I was 14 and there was that
Rocket Raccoon miniseries and I said I
want to bring him back everyone made fun
of me yeah I said come on he's short
he's furry he'll be our Wolverine he's a
rocket with a big gun in the jetpack
what's not to like attitude yeah you
made it happen and then the call came uh
to reassemble the games team and I
wanted to work with this guy so I jetted
out here and Mike Jones came from two
decades of of building games traveling
the world yeah so I you know I'm
lifelong Marvel fan and uh worked in
game development game publishing my
whole career and never thought I would
ever get a chance to work on Marvel
Properties or games and and uh you know
I worked at Capcom for a while which
which was a brush with Marvel yeah uh
but then yeah two and a half years ago
this opportunity came up and Marvel was
getting really serious about like hey
our games should be awesome as awesome
as all of our other entertainment prop
movies TV
publishing so we're like all right let's
do it let's partner with the best in the
business and here we are here we are are
and for years people are like where you
when we join they're like where are your
big games where are the console games
with it and it's like it takes time it
takes time you have to get there that's
the thing is it's like that time and
energy it's gonna pay off and it's
already starting to pay off I remember
when Greg and I got to go see uh
Avengers 2 uh back in the day and it was
uh because of Marvel games got us in and
there was this whole presentation before
and they're like we are Marvel games
this is our future we are building
towards this we're partnering with
Telltale for this we're doing like all
these different Partnerships and now to
see Spider-Man with Insomniac to see
Avengers with uh Square it's like we're
building this this Games Marvel games
universe that is so exciting and I feel
that the quality control is the most
most important thing and that's obvious
you guys get and that's what takes the
time you know we don't want to rush
anything out we don't want to do
Spider-Man the game that's a game based
on the movie and rush it out for a movie
window that's not what we're about we're
like let's just make the best Spider-Man
game and release it when it's ready and
yeah and think of gaming
as it's not a derivative business it's
another pillar of the brand you know
people you know the movies come out
twice a year starting three times a year
this year um we have our Netflix shows
TV shows that people love to binge and
watch Comics people reading the comics
weekly monthly but people are playing
our games every day and experience our
characters stories every day it's an
opportunity to tell new stories engage
with fans in different ways introduce
them to new characters they may not know
about as you've seen Mr negative Martin
Lee Miles Morales Yuri Watson AB right
we're going to keep mixing it up um but
games is a very very important
destination now for Marvel storytelling
Marvel fans and the quality you've come
to know and love from that Marvel brick
right right we want you to see that
Marvel logo on a game package and be
like oh it's gonna be awesome yeah
seeing Mr negative in this game I think
is such a huge selling point because
that shows that it is not just the Green
Goblin story we've seen a million times
this is really for fans and I think even
for people that aren't necessarily the
hardcore Spider-Man fans it's a good
introduction to The Wider world you may
not know who he is but you're going to
learn exctly we wanted to mix it up and
we're we're really inspired by like
looking at our Netflix shows and you see
Jessica Jones and most people did not
know like what's a killgrave what's a
man we knew what a purple man was and
they really put the spotlight on him and
elevated sool and so we thought this was
our opportunity to you know we're going
to have a lot of familiar faces in this
game but why not pick a character that
we believe in that's only been in comics
for the past five to six years but we
believe has a great potential let's put
the spotlight on him let's Elevate him
and then the world will be like I love
Mr negative he's awesome which to be
clear was not it's not like we for we
like oh this game has to have Mr NE that
was Brian and the team coming to us
being like we want to we want to take
this care character and put our spin on
it and like introduce them to the world
and we're like hell yeah let's do it so
that's an for me how does how did these
Partnerships start you guys two and a
half years ago we're bringing Marvel
games together we're only going to put
out good stuff is it you then going to
Insomniac is an insomniac coming music
and lyrics man like so sometimes
sometimes you write the music first
Sometimes Partners come to us and
they're like hey we have an awesome
pitch for a game we have a really cool
idea we'll talk about it we'll high five
we'll rock and roll sometimes we're like
we really respect this develop we really
respect you know uh what these
developers do these creatives do in this
space this genre whatever it is we think
this would be a good fit and we go
proactively talk to them so we're we're
actively planning what our portfolio
looks like what types of games we're
making what platforms they're on we're
looking at mobile console PC VR all
kinds of stuff right and we want to put
the best characters and franchises and
experience on the best platforms with
the developers that are best at doing
that stuff and that's the that that's
the fun that we get to have is we're not
just one developer or one publisher we
get to go out and work with the best of
the best right and I think you mentioned
it earlier about some of the
announcements we made towards the end of
last year and this year our partnership
with Insomniac and Playstation right our
Telltale Guardians of the Galaxy series
bringing back Marvel vs Capcom and now
our Square Enix partnership with Crystal
Dynamics The Avengers game and people
without us saying anything immediately
you're like four corners made a square
and they're like oh we see what they're
doing they're serious yeah right and
this is a very historic E3 for I feel
like I'm rambling now but this is a very
historic E3 for us because we've been
you know with our with our partners
Insomniac Capcom Lego Telltale we've
been working really really hard to bring
some awesome content to the four and to
have three big games at this conference
have our Telltale Series going on have
two games in Sony's press conference and
have Spider-Man close out the show what
an honored spot
like
it's incredible right and and and but
it's just the beginning oh that's so
excited being in that room today when we
did saw the demo there was an energy
where it's just like as it was happening
we just kept looking at each other being
like this is so cool well it's just
you're nailing it in the like you see
the demo whether it's you know in behind
closed doors or what we saw at the
conference and it's like right that's
what a Spider-Man game should look and
feel like yeah when you come in that
first time and she's like you got this
and he's like yeah I got this and it's
right into just pop po pop and using new
gadgets and doing all this stuff that we
haven't done in a Spider-Man game before
was like that's awesome this Spider-Man
he's he's been uh fighting crime for
about eight years he's experienced he's
like an athlete at the top of his game
and like you're right he he'll have Yuri
say do you have this and he may say yeah
I got this i got this but then in true
Spider-Man fashion a
human yeah right before he went the
helicopter like don't screw this up
right you know yeah so we're really yes
he's going to be experienced but we're
we're never forgetting the humor of
Spider-Man and that's part of the huge
reason why we partner with Insomniac on
it because they really bring the humor
they bring the personality and the the
humor that Spider-Man has it's it's I'd
say it's almost part of his powers you
know he could stick to walls he has a
Spider Sense he has the agility he has
the strength and he uses webing he
builds builds web for got his mind and
he also uses humor as a weapon when he's
fighting a foe that may be more powerful
that than him that's older than him to
get them off their game he may use humor
but he always uses it with himself too
just as we do as we go through our daily
lives and we kind that voice in our head
as we talk to ourselves so hopefully
you'll see that that fun fun and humor
throughout it all you guys get it that's
the thing is like when I was watching
the demo like yeah the the parts we had
seen of you know don't screw this up and
all that but there was in the behind
closed doors demo a sec a part where
there was a a steel beam that was on a
chain and they you could have fought all
the guys and not done it instead you
went that and did that and P it and hit
them all and everyone in the room
laughed was like that's combat I mean if
you look closely and hopefully everybody
will get a chance to to go in the
theater cuz they're playing it
differently and they're trying different
things like that little uh web uh trap
that he uses you can actually use it
between two guys and they'll they'll pop
together uh when you web them up with
the impact webs you when you in the demo
that we showed at the uh press
conference he knocks them up and sticks
them to a wall you can swing them around
stick them I stuck a guy to a parking
meter one time or to a car that was
driving by and so it gets really really
sort of dynamic and organic when you
start getting in there messing with all
your spider powers and your Tech and
your web abilities but something that we
haven't really shown much of but we get
asked a lot about is that human side
that Peter Parker side this game is very
much going to show I mean Bill loves to
talk about how the best Spider-Man
stories are the ones where Peters and
Spider-Man's Worlds Collide right and
that's actually one of the reasons why
Mr negative is such a great villain
because his philanthropist Persona
Martin Lee where Aunt May works at his
Feast shelters yeah and Mr negative as a
super villain foil to Spider-Man is just
a perfect
Nexus of we're going to bring Peter and
Spiderman's worlds together in a way
you've never seen in a game right the
original Spider-Man creators were so
smart you know before they made
superhero comics you know Stan Lee Steve
dicko Jenner Senor they were working on
like teen romance Comics right so when
they created the first Spider-Man comics
they didn't leave that behind it was
revolutionary that it was a superhero
story and they brought that soap opera
element it and you had that awesome
Supporting Cast H and as Mike said the
best stories are where Peter's civilian
that he's trying to protect are in
danger because of his costume lives and
they're smashing together so here you
know Peter and in every Spider-Man story
is a Peter Parker story he's always
Peter and he's always Spider-Man and
it's when these Worlds Collide you have
to make decisions like wait if if Martin
Lee is Mr negative do I take him down
that's going to ruin antm's life because
she's finding meaning her life she her
life will be all right or or what if
volunteering at the soup shelter isn't
like everything gives her meaning it
gives her purpose go to the library but
more importantly what if Martin Lee
finds out who he is then is she going to
be in danger this great escalation of
drama that and and world's cling that
only I think come in a in a in a true
Spider-Man SCH that story I think is one
of the main reasons we're so excited
about it uh thank you for bringing it by
2018 correct 2018 don't you better hit
2018 I'm sick of waiting already uh it's
like Spiderman saying don't mess us up
Don't Mess us up don't screw this up
don't screw up unanimously right
absolutely one of our kind of funny
approved games show you need to go give
this to Insomniac and take a photo with
them all right we'll do it oh we'll
do it one of our can can we get a round
of applause one of
[Applause]
our kind
approve there you go guys awesome thank
you congratulations guys thank you so
thank you so much we've been we've been
waiting a long time to do this we've
talked about getting on the show and
we've been hard at work on Spidey and
Capcom and everything else but thank you
so much for thank you guys got to make
it happen you guys on the gamescast on
the big stage here all right be done
thank you all right now get off stage
thank you for watching you guys thank
you that was our first of many segments
today Marvel games I can't wait for
Spider-Man oh my God it looks too good
it's unbelievable def I mean the thing
that the fact that we're seeing gameplay
and we're seeing it being played he
talked about playing it it gets me so
excited yeah well Tim are you ready to
get right into the next thing yes I am
uh ladies and Gentlemen please welcome
to the stage Sony Ben and day's
gone give me the real thing good to see
you what up man good to see you good man
how are you good to see I'm a hugger
we're doing it I'm a hugger we're doing
it Sony Ben Sony Ben Sony Ben how the
hell are you oh we're awesome introduce
yourself to everybody I'm John Garin I'm
the creative director I'm Jeff Ross I'm
the game director on days
gone who
I don't it sounds insulting but stick
with me what a difference a year makes
last year you guys came out you showed
that first Cinema trailer with were on
the bike looked great all right zombies
we're shooting zombies that's cool and
then this demo this year I was like I'm
all in because last year you guys had
talked a little bit about systems
Mechanics open world out that jazz I was
so blown away with this demo and then
you went behind closed doors today yeah
and I got to see a bit more of it and it
it what blew my mind was the demo that
everybody saw on the the PlayStation
showcase that was awesome the demo we
saw was the same Mission but it was
snowing because the the season was
different or like just the weather was
different and that totally changed the
gameplay of what we were doing so the
scene that you saw where there was the
rope that uh kind of choked him out and
he like fell off his motorcycle in this
thing he totally avoided that and went
around killed the guys Cut the Ropes so
he didn't have to deal with that and the
ambushes he dealt with and the
situations were totally different and I
was like this is so much more Dynamic
than I expected it to be yeah and that's
really what we wanted to emphasize this
year is just the open world Dynamic
systems yeah so you know things like
like you said last year we showed the
horde which is hundreds and hundreds of
of freakers and it was a life and death
sort of Chase for Deacon just running
for his life this year we wanted to show
how you could and I think this is a term
Jeff came up with weaponizing the horde
you can actually use right enemies
against each other because you know we
introduced you know Marauders so human
enemies this year and just the idea that
it's an open world system where
everything's alive everything has its
own needs everything has its own faction
and it can be used against each other
yeah so if we said a lot of mumbo jumbo
last year like systems and blah blah
blah really what we were trying to say
was it's a deadly world that's going to
try to kill you a lot of different ways
yeah that's that's a good thing that you
have yeah and I mean speaking of that
like another thing I noticed about the
demo is it is extremely violent in a way
that kind of makes you feel
uncomfortable but that's the point like
this is obviously an apocalypse
obviously things are really bad um but
seeing some of the the the death
animations there was a moment in the
demo I saw behind closed doors where uh
after he cut the rope he killed one of
the guys runs up on the other guy like
Shanks him in the spleen he falls back
and he's like please no no and then he
just Stomps on his face and his head
explodes and I was like whoa okay but I
mean that's the world that they're in
yeah it is and and one of the things
that we really wanted to do and you can
see that kind of happening right here is
this is that same Ambush that in the on
the media showcase demo Deacon was
distracted by Runners which are infected
wolves and so he's dealing with that
then he gets clotheslined and just bam
he's on the ground and these guys are on
him and in in the alternate demo that
you saw he's able to go around them and
you know it's like what he it's like
what he tells that guy when he's begging
for his life he's like no he Stomps him
and he says you just paid the price yeah
you know you had your chance and that's
yeah that's the world we really wanted
to kind of explore was how you know it's
like how Savage it can be how brutal it
can be you know but keeping it real so
you know we're trying to keep it as
realistic as we can another thing that
surprised me was how open the game was
like in the the demo I saw he's riding
his motorcycle around and it was a
really vast open world and it seemed
like there was a lot going on where even
if it wasn't like side missions and
things like that there was like World
building going on like there was a tree
with a a freaker attached to it by a
chain and one of the Marauders was
giving him and kind of like like oh
you can't get me can't get me and then
you as a player can shoot the chain the
freaker goes and kills the dude he's
just like you shouldn't have been
talking you got
shot you know and we love that moment
because is one of those things where it
shows the depravity of the world and how
you know there's we Stomp the guy's face
in but there's no great people left in
this world I mean people who got this
far did some all did some nasty stuff so
and and these guys would have killed
Deacon if he didn't get the upper hand
on them so but the depravity and that we
can witness we also want to make that
interactive which is why you know the
the player had the tools to turn that
situation around and again it's not a
prescribed way of doing it the player
can choose to engage it or not or or try
other techniques but we just want want
to give the player a set of tools where
he can be as violent as he needs to be
in the context of this world because
it's it's a kill or be killed to the
extreme yeah and and like you were
saying it's open that's the thing so we
really wanted to show off that this is
one small part of the Cascade Wilderness
which is one of the regions in the game
and you know Copeland's Camp which is
where the demo starts is one of the
encampments where you find um you know
survivors who are sort of sort of law
abing so not everybody's depraved
probably there are still some people who
have a shred of decency a shred of
humanity and you know that's kind of one
of the things the game is about is that
you see Deacon's character at the start
when Copeland is telling him hey our
supplier just got hit we got to go get
these guys and he's like not my problem
yeah you know and if that were the whole
story then this would be like why the
why the hell would you want to play
as this guy yeah right but instead we're
like no there's a shred of humanity in
there and he you know when it's his
friends and that's sort of where the MC
comes into it is Brotherhood and loyalty
and there are these sort of deep traits
within Deacon and that's kind of what we
want to explore over the course of the
game is like you know H how do you why
do you want to survive in a world like
this what gives you hope what makes you
want to continue
what is I mean what you can tell us The
Narrative of this game CU is it is the
MC still intact is that how he's been
surviving is what what are what are his
driving motivations because that's
always the thing when you get a bleak
landscape like this right where it is
yeah everybody's a horrible person why
would I want to hang out it's two years
after uh day zero right yes where this
starts yeah so well you know so again we
said it two years after this event the
pandemic you know we're really not going
into a lot of detail about that yet but
you know the in terms of the timing and
the setting of it a lot of
post-apocalyptic experiences are you
know 20 years on or 20,000 years on and
we wanted it to be just after so there's
still a lot that's sort of there's still
a lot of resources that can be found and
gathered you know the roads aren't
complet the buildings aren't completely
destroyed they're still mostly intact um
and you know and that's that's kind of
why we chose that setting and you know
and then the same thing with the High
Desert like you can see it's snowing
like crazy here and the reason is
because in the high desert it can be
July this is the high desert is where
Ben's studio is um pure coincidence um
right what you know but it can be but it
can be snowing in July it's like it's
very extreme we get extreme weather we
have extreme um all kinds of
environments within a very very small
area so forests and deserts and and lava
tube caves they can all be in a very
small area yeah I was also really
impressed by so going back to what we're
talking about with the different skill
trees and stuff where there's the
motorcycle and over time you can build
that up so you can like Drive farther
and go faster and all that but in
addition to that there's like that uh
detective mode esque thing thing where
you kind of can see the tracks and that
as you play through that kind of gets a
little bit more advanced and you can
mark the the different uh enemies and
like see where they are in different
ways and uh what what else is there like
that uh well one of the things you can
see on the alternate path is that we we
show a lot more of the motorcycle going
off-road burning fuel taking damage so
you've got to make you've got one bike
in this world and it's it's Deacon's
bike it's it's part of his personality
and uh you can't whistle for it to come
to you you've got to keep tabs on it you
got to find it people want it uh and you
got to manage you got to maintain it too
and you got to upgrade it so that's part
of the motivation for him working with
these camps is that he can they can help
provide some of the upgrades that he's
going to need to survive yeah we really
wanted to you know again the vision mode
you're talking about we call that
survival vision and then when you bring
up this wheel it's a Survivor wheel so
we wanted to give Deacon a whole range
of tools and abilities that again are
part of our experience system and part
of your ability to like choose how you
want to play the game so you can do it
stealth and like in the in the
alternative path that you saw you can
running gun uh there's just any you know
you can you can play it the way you want
to play it yeah and so with all the
enemies it seems like so there's the
Marauders out there there's the freakers
which are the the zombie style things
but then there's also the infected
animals so we saw wolves in the the demo
but then there's also that bear at the
end is there any other animals out there
so yeah you saw we call it the rager so
that's the infected bear you saw the
runners which are infected wolves which
by the way if you hadn't if Deacon
hadn't shot that wolf on the on the
media showcase demo it would have
knocked him off his bike so that's kind
of another example of how we how the you
know we say the world comes for you um
and we you know last year we showed the
horde we showed swarmers we showed NES
which were adolescents um when they were
infected um and uh I think in the alter
in the alternate path demo you we Al we
also showed crows interesting what I
also liked is how this demo that that we
saw kind of took last years and like
instead of it being this massive swarm
of hundreds of them we saw kind of just
smaller mobs of them you could kind of
control them and shift them using Noise
by like uh like in in the demo I saw
there was a a dude you put a bear trap
down you threw a rock to get him to go
over to it he got caught and he started
screaming and all of his friends were
like dude shut up you got to shut up
they're going to come they're going to
come he didn't shut up cuz he just got
his leg bit by a freaking bear trap and
think he gets shot in the head by his
friend and I was just like that is
insane but that's thing is that was the
right play too for the friend to do
that's our world and it's such a cool
use of then seeing the the Swarm kind of
come in and you as a character just kind
of stealth hiding in the grass and just
letting them take over for you yeah you
know the horde is The Horde is real and
it's like I said it's hundreds of
freakers and early on in the game by the
way at least more than a couple hundred
you don't you don't mess with them early
on in the game you run for your life
that's what you do but swarms are way
more common so what you see in the media
showcase demo when Deacon goes through
that Clift in the Rocks he's like hey
this is a swarm that you know that can
be engaged really really early on
they're way more common they're still
almost as deadly as a horde and then you
saw also when he was looking over the
railing down at that valley below you
know again that just on the one hand
that shows how big our world is because
you can actually explore all of that um
but it also shows you how dangerous it
is because these swarms are everywhere
yeah my question would be this it you
you debut it last year you you get to
you get to see chuckleheads like us talk
about it non-stop what's the biggest
thing people have gotten wrong about the
game I feel like the more we talk about
it right the and the more more we see of
it the more my impression of it changes
right where it goes from so many people
are like oh looks a lot like Last of Us
the more we talk about it I'm like this
seems a lot more like Horizon and then
what for you is the biggest
misconception that everything's fake you
know
that uh you know last year we did The
Horde thing and it was live I mean it
was it was the real deal and you just
can't win with this crowd or when you
play it one way people think it's linear
and that's the only way but and that's
why this year we wanted to show the
alternate path where it's like no this
is the same Victory conditions but we
let the player go at him any way he
wants and it's that's the thing I want
to message more than anything else is
that it's play it your way uh figure out
a way that you like to play and just do
it and the game will
respond well I you know for me I think
it's a you know we're number one we're
flattered because you know all these
games that we're being compared to we're
huge fans of those games you know and we
were in development alongside you know
most of them um and you know and we're
Gamers so what we want to do is craft an
experience that you know at least for me
I want to craft an experience I haven't
played before you know so I think the
you know probably the biggest
misconception is that you know if we're
trying to create are we trying to create
an experience that's real are we trying
to ape something or mimic something and
that you know that's just not the case
we're trying to create days gone which
for us is a brutal open world dynamic
system and to me it feels very different
than than most of the games that that
I've played up to date I think the other
you know interesting thing coming away
from this right is talking about my
misconception of it you guys doing it
but then you had a really interesting
story from behind closed doors where
they were asking you you know like how
does all this work like what's the
biggest change from last year and what I
liked from what I heard from Tim was the
answer was like well nothing's changed
there hasn't been a drastic we're just
building on the systems we have has that
been for you the story of the
development of days gone having this
idea and then just m because like I we
know we always make fun of Eric right of
how long it's taking for you guys to put
out another game and where is it Sony
Ben and where is Sony Ben and it's one
of those like when you look at this and
you see and start talking about when you
talk about the mechanics you see it in
on the screen it seems like you've been
working on one thing for a long time and
you want it to be really good I
you know I think one of the things that
hopefully is you you guys can just see
from this year and last year is that our
one of our original goals was to make a
AAA console quality in terms of the
characters and the cinematics and the
environments because the PS4 the PS4 and
the PS4 Pro let us do that yeah and you
know it's like so the production values
are really really high probably much
higher than they need to be for an open
world game and we really wanted to
deliver on that not and not just the way
it looks but also the way it plays the
amount of detail in the AI and the
amount of detail in the missions and the
jobs so yeah and it's a big game right
so it's like any other open world game
it's massive there's a lot to do um and
there's a lot of story to be told which
we're not really talking about yet but
but yeah it's just it's just going to
take a while to get there yeah it's very
exciting stuff last year I was
interested but now I'm totally sold I
think that mixing that crazy mob stuff
with the more open stuff where there's a
bunch of different ways you can go about
things this is going to be a really fun
game awesome thank you so now when's it
coming
out we're not talking about that good
try nice try dude nice try nice try it's
all him well thank you guys for coming
by uh Tim you had fun watching it today
I did I had fun watching it this is one
of my approved games so I'm going to
give it another two for two two for
two cracking up the fragile
box pass it over there we go thank you
guys for congratulations guys thank you
man thanks guys everybody should come by
the Sony booth and see the alternate
playthrough in person if they want to
it's right over here definitely that's
pretty awesome well thank you take care
guys thank you now awkwardly leave the
stage uh ladies and gentlemen give it up
for days gone Sony Ben Eric Jensen made
it all by himself these guys were up
here taking credit for no re how that
how that treat you Tim that was good
yeah that was real good happy with that
one yeah yeah okay cool yeah are you
ready for the next one what is next the
next next one is a Greg Miller game if
I've ever heard of one uhhuh p who no no
who like life is
strange who's excited for more life is
strange ladies and gentlemen you want to
get out of here I'm going to get out of
here out Tim doesn't know a goddamn
thing about life is strange he has no
taste I say Hella a lot though yeah you
do he does say Hella a lot ladies and
gentlemen for a very intimate
conversation please welcome to the stage
the one of the men behind life is
strange before the storm come on up deck
nine
thanks for coming out thanks for having
me please now we've never met sir we we
actually might have met you're going to
throw me into the bus right now no it's
fine it's okay that you don't okay don't
you that you don't remember when did we
meet uh past E3 I was a lead designer on
a on a game for Sony called Warriors
Lair for the vaita I think we you might
have interviewed me very
briefly what well now this now this
interview is taking a completely
different turn does everyone remember
Warriors
lay no no you one person did what did
this it was going to be Diablo and the
Vita it was going to be loot we'd all
have it was going to be amazing but
because you guys didn't support Vita
enough it didn't happen so I hope you're
all happy it's on you that man
has a Vita I appreciate that a lot no
well what's your name introduce yourself
to everybody my name is Chris Floyd I'm
the co- game director at deck 9 games
and we're working on life is strange
before the
storm man what an E3 surprise I thought
it was weird when don't nods like oh
we're putting up this video we're not
going to be any3 work on to life is
strange 2 then life is strange a
Playstation Plus game I'm like
something's cooking here but then this I
didn't see it coming I have to say you
know working on the game for uh more
than a year and just knowing the fan
base that's out there for life is
strange sure you know keeping that
bottled up for so long that moment at
the Xbox conference when we finally had
our trailer up there just letting
letting Chloe out of the bag as it were
was a fantastic moment for us okay so
you you I think hit the nail in the head
for the first part it's a game that's
beloved it's a game that has changed
people's lives there are so many
cosplayers out there how terrifying was
it to actually get this it is such it's
it's a lot of pressure for us you know
what don't nod created is spectacular
and it's such a unique Vision yeah right
so so to be asked to come in and
contribute to that it's a lot of
pressure but it's really such a great
privilege to be able to work in this
same universe and work with characters
and environments that they created so
you said a year and a half you've been
cooking on it yeah over a year okay so
how does this happen how you I I I'm not
I'm unfamiliar with deck N9 sure what
else have you worked on so deck 9 games
uh is a set of Veteran developers we've
been building a team actually for the
last three years uh and a set of tools
to make cinematic adventure games okay
so we brought in storytellers from film
and television as well as video games we
made a great team of storytellers and we
made a tool set of tools we call story
Forge that really unleashes those people
and lets them bring their Creative
Vision into the game and we just had uh
Square Enix come to us and start talking
to us about cinematic adventure games
next thing we know we're we're making
the next life a strange game we couldn't
believe it we wanted to play the next
game we didn't imagine
we so I mean I I I say this quite often
I know how to play video games and talk
about them but the business side of
games I never truly understand so you
took a meeting with square and they at
some point does it become obvious that
they're interviewing you I mean what
they did you know we actually talked to
them about uh some other possible games
we might make we showed them our
technology yeah this technology has been
uh really making some waves to everyone
we show it to uh that's made these kinds
of games Veterans of of adventure games
uh they see it they go oh we wish we
could work with these tools okay so uh
that was the first point that really I
think caught their attention and then
honestly they put us through the ringer
they made us uh recreate scenes from the
first life of strange they made us make
our own scene from our story and really
show that we could capture that unique
Vision that the visual quality the
feeling of life is strange so then what
was the Mandate from them or the order I
guess they put in is it like hey we want
you to make a life is strange game
that's before life is strange or did
they leave it up to you or well we knew
that fans wanted to return to Arcadia
Bay and there were a lot of fans who
just wanted to spend more time with
characters that they uh that they knew
and that they loved from the first game
so other than that uh Square was was
gave us a lot of latitude to consider a
lot of different stories and where we
landed was Chloe as our protagonist and
telling this story that's really about
that special person that just comes into
your life at the right time and just
changes everything for you and for Khloe
that's Rachel Amber tell me about who
Rachel Amber is I think you know being a
fan of life is strange she was this
character obviously she was a motivating
factor I but you we never got to know
her in that game she's like a mythical
figure in the first right everybody has
something to say about her they'll have
their own interactions everybody loves
her it it's still true in our game three
years before the original game she's the
most popular girl girl in school she's
super successful at uh at school at
everything she does she's kind of
everything to everyone yeah Chloe on the
other hand totally different she's an
outcast her father just died two years
before in a tragic accident her best
friend Max taken off lost touch she's
really alone against the whole world so
when Rachel shows up it's really going
to be a transformative moment and these
two kind of oil and water are going to
come together and they're going to find
that they both need each other to lean
on during this period of our story so
when concept art leaked and we're all
like started getting what's going on
here I started crafting a story of like
how would this work how would they do
this and I'm like it'll be we play as
raciel Amber she has the rewind power
but she understands she has to die and
to make you know blah blah and then you
guys just flat out came out like no
you're playing as Chloe there's no
rewind that's right we we absolutely
like I say we considered a lot of
different options and playing Rachel was
totally one of them one of the neat
things is that when Rachel is the person
you have a relationship with the way you
did with Khloe in the first game that's
the character you kind of really
actually get to explore it's kind of a
paradox there of exploring who she is at
least through the lens of Khloe and
seeing Rachel through Khloe's eyes given
what she said about Rachel that was
really really really appealing to us
sure so yeah I mean there's so many
other things about Khloe that also were
really interesting partly how different
she is from Max right she's a little
spiky she's got a lot of attitude Max is
very timid and cautious and that just
really appealed to us too we think it
brings a whole new tone to the
game so I understand story Forge you're
talking about how great the mechan the
tools are what makes them special what
makes them stand out well it really has
it really has two parts it starts in a
tool we call playright and that's like
uh let's basically like writing a
screenplay our writers can write a
screenplay except they can also add in
all those branches and consequences uh
and all those those moments that make
the game play what it is they build that
straight into uh into that uh screenplay
then we suck that over into a game into
a a tool we call Storyteller where we
start to build our cinematic sequences
that's like a giant timeline you bring
in a character you give it animations
you get in there in the the facial uh
the facial expressions we literally have
sliders that you can grab and turn up
the sadness and turn down the surprise
or mix them however you want to it's
just a sad face and a smiley face on a
slider and you go somewhere between it
literally that's what we do yeah wow
okay that's interesting were you worried
about fan reaction to first off a
prequel but secondly hey there are no
rewind Powers this is just going to be
how Chloe interacts with all these
different people sure we knew we were
making some bold decisions but we also
uh one felt that ultimately the real
Beating Heart of life is strange are
these relatable characters these
realistic relationships and the real
world issues that they deal with in
their life now of course we're going to
have you know life is still strange sure
we're going to have some strange and
Supernatural elements in there but the
power in particular to address that it
just really didn't make sense for one
thing Max is a character the that that
timid cautious character the the the the
rewind power really was an expression of
who she was and what um what her sort of
issues that she needed to to deal with
were uh as opposed to Khloe that's
that's not that's not her so we felt
like uh uh breaking out of that a little
bit was really what was appropriate for
Khloe's story of course and so
then what's don't nod's involvement like
are did you you get the job from Square
are you talking to them at the same time
are they approving what you're doing so
don't nod is very very busy busy as they
announced a few weeks ago working on
their own followup uh to life is strange
and like everybody else we're really
excited to see what that's going to be
we've been very very busy working on the
first episode of before the storm but we
did get opportunities to share what we
were working on with don't nod we've
collected some of their feedback our
headwriter took our first episode out to
them sat down and played the game with
them collected up a bunch of really
fantastic feedback and that's really
informed how we've uh how we've gone
along and and tried to stay true to the
original that must have been so
nightmarish of sitting there just
wincing every time anybody said or did
anything just like I don't they set the
bar colossally high right and and
there's no doubt about that so we're
just uh we're just really proud to have
the opportunity to live up to that so
why three episodes three episodes you
know we could have gone uh with more uh
we maybe could have gone with less uh I
I really liking it you know in these
days of of of Digital television you
know with Netflix you now have creators
that really get to Define they don't
need to hit those 47 minutes or whatever
with commercial breaks anymore they get
to Define how long um you know their TV
show should be same with us we had the
option to uh we just had to look at our
story and say what did we need to tell
this story and three episodes felt just
right and then I thought it was
interesting you guys came out you talked
about the three episodes but then you
talked about in the deluxe edition right
this farewell episode you want to talk
about that yeah that's right we knew of
course that fans wanted to return to
Arcadia Bay we also felt like a lot of
fans would want to play Max just one
more time yeah so we decided to add a
bonus episode the three episode uh
before the storm is self-contained this
bonus episode goes a little further back
with young Max and let you play Max for
just one more farewell episode I'm
assuming it's when she leaves am I
correct is it her farewell Arcadia B
we're not ready to talk too I think it's
right after the death am I right are we
saying farewell to the dad that could be
the other thing is it Chloe's father I I
I plead the fifth yeah you know though
you know so how are you guys guys doing
episodic content cuz what's always
interesting with episodic is the fact
like Telltale is able to change and
adjust do you guys feel like your three
episodes are locked and you know exactly
what's happening or is it episode one's
going to come out and there's time to
take what people say and change we
constructed an arc uh of the whole
storyline uh very early on yeah but of
course as you get in and you really work
with these characters and you work with
individual scenes and you start to see
what's working and what's not it's
absolutely true that things change so we
started with a lot of attention on our
first episode um and and we and we move
on to each episode we know basically
what the main points are but things
change and we even may have some
opportunities to react to what the fans
see in episode one and uh and and touch
up some moments in episode two and three
if we're lucky what I'm requesting in
episode three is the final thing I do is
dye my hair blue just putting that out
there duly noted just out there would
you like to dye your hair
blue there we go there we go because
then it's you know it's we're setting it
up for the next one now you're
definitely going to see that
transformation in many ways uh in in
terms of her personality at least of
Chloe turning into that character that
you know from the first season I guess
then my next question would be how did
you at what point do you go back and
play Life Is Strange again is it that
you sit there and go you you obviously
play it the first time because it's
amazing you get the job you play it
again you write your script and you're
playing it while you do that then after
you finish your script
you go back to play it to see how it
would actually add like how many times
have you played life is strange we look
at the game all the time as you say when
we started the project of course we went
over with a fine tooth comb we looked at
it in some cases literally frame by
frame to see how you create you know the
visuals and the Cinematic uh moments
from the game to really break it down
and understand it we return to it all
the time because it's so important for
us to hit it just
right where the thing about the episodic
narrative Adventure right is that so
many people like to hate on it it's not
a game I'm just watching a why do you
love
it I love I love these opportunities to
take these characters in some really
radical directions you know life is
strange dealt with some some really
heavy stuff right and uh and and made
you make some choices that you really
felt and you knew the consequences you
knew they were coming at some point and
they were going to hit you uh and
especially now for our game with no
rewind power you can't take these back
we're doubling down on those
consequences Chloe has to live with them
the player has to live with them you're
going to feel them in your gut life is
strange before the storm episode one
comes out August 3 31st that's right for
Xbox One PlayStation 4 and PC on Steam
and then it'll end with me dying my hair
blue and the farewell thing is me
leaving right we will see God damn it
everybody round of applause for life is
strange deck n gam thank you man another
round of applause for warriors layer too
on the
vaita the vaita is dead and it's all
your faults you could have saved the
Vita but you chose not to you could have
done it but you didn't do it did
you shame on all of you but speaking of
things that are saved Tim way Tim coming
upic who did you save who did you save I
Sav the you saved the Bandicoot you say
now it is who did you save the Bandicoot
who loves
crash you're my people I'm this is about
to be good Andy let's go Candy
Andy Round of Applause Candy Andy who's
been loving Andy Cortez there we go
there's there's a lot of people that
don't know who I am right now and that's
it's kind about to meet him he's
fantastic kind of a good feeling all
right about to let all of you down trust
me ladies and gentlemen we got something
really special for you right now this is
Crash Bandicoot the insane Trilogy we're
going to talk about it I'm Tim Gettys
this is Andy Cortez sure we have Dan the
director of the game and Jen the head of
vicarious
Visions then when I last saw
you crash warped and I was very excited
about it since then E3 has happened
there's been launch trailers there's
been announcements of Coco being
playable in one two and three who's
hyped about Coco I am I'm very hyped
about Coco how are you feeling feeling
pretty good
it's it's really exciting to be able to
actually now share all the things that
we've been working on at this yeah no
couldn't couldn't Spill the Beans
exactly of course I've been seeing a
whole bunch of little Easter eggs and
stuff on Twitter and I'm really really
excited about it if I can spoil a couple
things here seeing the these pictures I
don't know if you've seen them who who
played Uncharted 4 Jes ever heard that
game there we go there we go for people
that did not clap play Uncharted for
yeah uh there's like there's a scene of
Coco with her laptop from Crash warped
and you can see uh the scene from
Uncharted 4 where Nathan and Elena are
playing Crash it's fantastic I love
stuff like that yeah no we buried a lot
of Easter eggs in there so the the game
has all the original Easter eggs and
obviously now some extra ones for uh
people to discover so yeah I love it so
Jen yes Crash Bandicoot how big of a
deal is it to you that you save the
Bandicoot you're bringing it back into
all these people's lives oh my gosh it's
a it's a huge deal um just the amount L
of love that the fans have for for crash
and it's been 20 years you know since
the first one came out now is the
perfect time so we thought you know what
a perfect opportunity we're big fans
ourselves so uh we're so grateful that
we got this incredible opportunity yeah
so CR when's it come out really soon
really really really soon on your
birthday counting down the day it's on
my birthday June 30th so we brought you
a special birthday gift here oh my God
oh you shouldn't have oh my God and this
is how it all ends yeah don't burn down
now is it gluten-free Tim I is it
gluten-free oh I don't know or am I
going to crash and burn you'll have to
find out eat the candle wish happy
birthday I would make a wish but the
wish already came true the bandic the
candle eat I'm not EA I'm not eating the
candle I will take a bite though Andy
how do you feel about Crash Bandicoot so
I am a what you would call a fa weather
fan when it comes to the franchise it
was the first game I played on my PS1
right U so I do have fond memories of it
the thing that I'm really really excited
about I came from game development I
came from the from the art world so
seeing the enhanced visuals how much how
much time went into developing the
visuals and re like trying to find The
Sweet Spot of yeah crash looks really
good right now yeah yeah no that that
took a long time I mean um we pretty
much had to build rebuild everything
from from scratch right and so you know
we got a hold of the uh original gray
meshes from Sony mhm and that's about
all we had to work with and so uh a lot
of it was just this iterative process of
going over and over again trying to
figure out where that sweet spot was
right and um you know we went back to
original concept art we went back to
even the things that inspired naughty
dog in the first place you know Looney
Tunes
Animaniacs uh Who Framed Roger Rabbit
because you know the original game could
only take us so far sure you know um and
when all else failed we said you know
what we trust our artists We Trust our
audio guys we want you to add your own
little stamp to it awesome awesome now
how do you all feel about nearly giving
Tim a heart attack when the reveal
happened yeah it happen you survived I
survived and now I'm excited now it's
coming out and get to play it so you're
saying three trophies in this game three
Platinum trophies platinums yep three
Platinum uhhuh pretty exciting pretty
exciting so uh the level I want to play
most I was telling you last time is the
Great Wall of China level is that
playable here on the show for okay good
everybody when you're done with this go
play Crash Bandicoot and play that level
Lobby in the South Hall aw uh has
basically the first 10 levels from each
game playable so aw you can play or
Express to your heart's content great
yeah you can eat all the chumba wambas
you want good good
than knocked down get knocked yeah there
you go um so I saw that Crash Bandicoot
himself is here roaming the floors
around he's definitely I hear that the
suit is the original suit from the
commercials is that true or false that's
that is not true actually I've been lied
to the suit from the original
commercials was in pretty bad shape
that's sound sanitary you know 20 20
years of uh we actually have it yeah
it's just it's a little old it's it's
belongs in museum I say perhaps it
doesn't Dr clean very well but but I saw
him walking around he has the megaphone
and he was saying all the same
catchphrases from the commercials yeah
this attention to detail is important
and I love I also saw a Sonic the
Hedgehog mascot and a Mario mascot if we
can get those three together for a
picture I feel like that's going to be a
pretty important moment that's a
paradise right there yeah yeah it is
people out about that do now can we get
crash to visit to visit our Sex Dungeon
do you all know about our sex dungeon
that's an interesting segue there
we we're staying in an Airbnb and it's a
it's a whole thing there's a a sex swing
crash bandic should come through
though so if you can give me his number
later arrange that I don't yeah figure
it out that in sure yeah so what are you
most excited for now that the game is
about to be
released um let's see outside of
vacation um well deserved yeah I don't
know I I'm am super excited for Coco but
outside of Coco I think uh the thing I'm
most excited about is that we've got you
know time trials across all three games
now and we can announce that time trials
also have online leaderboard support
okay so you know for our hardcore fans
the ones who really just want to you
know get the best times on each of the
levels I mean that's 80 plus levels of
leaderboards um yeah that's going to be
a lot of gameplay for folks so I'm
pretty excited about that yeah yeah in
general it's like you know we've been
talking and talking about Crash showing
lots of levels seeing the fans actually
get their hands on the game I think
that's what we're excited to see and and
I hope they can see the the level of
love and attention to detail that the
team is given it yeah so back with the
team at home how had they kind of had to
deal
with remaking something that is so
cherished while adding their own flavor
but still staying true to what crash
is it it it's a tough balance to strike
I think um it really does start with
kind of
really knowing the franchise in and out
and let you know the
franchise sort
of
Boom you can sort of uh oh man boy some
of these questions are so boring holy
some of these things are so
boring pardon me as I crash the hey this
guy yeah watch out oh my God all right
I'm Star Struck right now I think
there's a a person named Tim here my is
that is that the handsome area right
here that's the handsome Tim from
everybody here we all know it's his
birthday right we're going to give you
the biggest happy birthday it's not
going to be a song I'll take it cuz it's
copyrighted okay so it's going to be one
big happy birthday for you okay but with
a song like voice are you guys ready one
two three happy
birthday yes all
right bring it in oh my
God I love this I love this that was man
that was man hug true man hug hey you
want you want to you want to do it yeah
I don't know you know the dance can you
teach me the dance I will teach you the
dance do you guys know the Crash
dance do you want to see the Crash dance
yeah all right here it goes all dance
right wait a second do you know a dance
too I know the Coco dance you're kidding
me yeah can we have a moment of
silence I'm so Happ I'm so glad that
you're here that wasn't awkward this is
awkward make out that was awkward okay
okay dance time are you ready yeah we're
ready all right I'm going to start it
pay attention Okay I'm paying attention
all right hey it's going to start off
real nice and slow you're going to count
it five four 3 2
1 it's like he he's right
here him all right thank you guys all
right thank you one more hug
unbelievable I got a hug too I come to
the South Hall and check me out because
the polygons of the 90s you know those
Graphics finished we've been completely
digitally remastered so you can play the
insane Trilogy all three games in
absolute HD FK technology I'm see South
guys thank you happy birthday buddy
thank you thank
you all right that was awesome guys all
right yeah so when he was doing the
dance I I thought I was watching get off
the stage I'm sorry that's fine it's
fine bye crash be careful when he did
the dance I thought he was doing I
thought I was watching in-game footage I
was kind of transported the FK was too
real only possible on the PS4 Pro like
that I was actually surprised he knew
the dance that was great that was that
was amazing everything about that that
was not planned still here at least not
by me still here I guess so yeah I mean
I I guess I'm out of questions I don't
even like know how oh God there's so
much happening right
now still still here oh I love
it you did you came back and now I don't
knower he's just eating up the crowd I
love it so I have a question um this is
a little bit inside baseball when you
all were making the three games right y
did you how were the were teams divided
up to work on a game a game a game or
was it all sort of evenly spread out no
we worked on uh all three games in a row
so it was one team starting with the
first one working all the way to the end
but then you know to really make it a
cohesive package I think you know the
team spent some time figuring out hey
there's some lessons learned that
obviously naughty dog had in the second
and third games maybe we should bring
some of those things back to the first
so I mean it's 20 years of hindsight
really there so you know like Jen said
we developed each of them in order and
then we we were able to take the lessons
and the foundation from each of them and
build on top of the rest kind of like
how NAU dog did awesome very very cool
each of the games have a different feel
to them right when it comes to like the
jump height and like how fast it is and
just all that you know we originally
thought we might unify the jump and so
that would have upset people so we did
that initially and we were like yeah not
working yeah so uh there were certain
things we did where we did make the jump
height in the first one a little bit
higher and tuned it down in the second
and the third awesome so what are the
changes like getting into it like what
are the things that you did fix like
with crash one in particular um so we
really looked at a lot of kind of
quality of life issues first and
foremost I mean there there are things
that you know Gamers really just expect
these days like a proper save game
system instead of passwords things like
that so those are pretty obvious ones um
but then you know there's there's some
more uh subtle things as well um you
know we wanted to present deserve the
challenge but sometimes they weren't
communicating the challenge well enough
you know you have an AI come up and
you're not sure how to defeat it and you
just die and die again until you figure
out how to defeat it so he made sure to
give certain AI tells just so you oh
okay you know they're about to attack or
you know in the case of even like uh
we'll take penstripe as an example with
his Tommy Gun you know we found that
certain players who were playing didn't
realize that he was vulnerable in
certain periods so we just added a
little more VFX to illustrate that yeah
he was sorry sorry I'm distracted but
Crash Bandicoot is hugging shui oshaa
right now yeah my dreams have come true
this is it's a weird show it's a weird
show how every going I'm not competing
with any of this
i h i love how excited are you that Coco
is playable in all three games because
that I is a really awesome announcement
yeah super excited yeah Coco is very
iconic big fan favorite um you you know
we really didn't have time to add any
features at all but this really came
from the team they they a number of the
team members really wanted to bring her
back into all three level all three
games and have her playable different
team members would come up to us each
week and pester us so they would just do
kind of this hey can we put her in the
schedule no we don't have time but um
you guys know what game jams are I hope
yep yep so we did a game Jam at some
point those guys just ran off into our
corner
and prototype playable Coco that's
awesome and they came back and they said
hey we made playable Coco and it works
and we're like ah okay I guess we got to
do this awesome awesome so you know at
that point we really then had to figure
out what it took to actually get her
into the game it's no small it's no
small effort because we weren't going to
just reskin crash with Coco we had to
have a whole new set of animations
there's lots of dying in this game so
you want to make sure that there's some
for Coco that are unique to her person
she has custom anim her own timeouts own
Des okay well Dan Jen thank you so much
not only for bringing crash insane
Trilogy back into the world world team
racing too no one day one day but also
for bringing crash here to wish me a
happy birthday and it's not my birthday
everything's great about this I hope
everyone has a happy E3 thank you guys
very much thank you thank you J now next
up we got something you guys you guys
can go thank you we got something very
very very special for you guys
Greg Miller and shui
Yoshida happy birthday Tim happy
birthday happy birthday Tim hi everybody
how are
you how are you enjoying the show so
far shout out to the man in the wing
wing
shirt keep it keep the dream alive uh
ladies and Gentlemen please welcome to
the stage Shu
Yoshida
grab a su right there sh thank you for
coming Shu oh yeah you need a microphone
don't you there you go
yeah hello there you go yeah you know
that I was one of the producers of the
original Crush Bandu game so I I cannot
be excited enough I had a chance to play
Crash one two and three on PS4 the other
day and like they are saying uh they
made Crush one a little bit easier
because it's a too hard
you know I struggled as a producer but
every well stop right there if you were
struggling as a producer did you think
about dialing down the
difficulty actually we did we did for
the Japanese version okay the US and
European version came out in September I
remember but we had three months uh we
released the first crush game in
December in Japan so I worked with Mark
and na dog guys to make make it a little
bit you know easier for the jaanese ver
we're happy to reunite you and your
former employee over there crash bandic
uh let's start with the biggest
PlayStation story of e3 2017 which was
you're in everybody's golf
yes as if I couldn't love the Hot Shot
SL everybody golf more you put shoe in
there I got to play as you today it was
fantastic thank you thank you so I was
uh at the boo and I I saw someone pring
as me and I was like uh
know so how sh how is sh
doing here there this is you right there
they talking about it how did that
happen did they just come oh yeah so the
this character was made just using the
same uh edit you know character edit to
that they have in game so you can create
anyone and as a developer made this to
they wanted to demonstrate how versatile
it is so they created me and Sean Len
Andrew house and all those bunch of
people just using the same tool and one
of the pr person you know suggested why
don't we use Just sh character for the
E3 demonstration that might attract you
know people's attention just a little
bit Yeah is it shipping with you you're
going to be in the game uh I could be
yeah saw an AIO you want him in the game
everybody's
goal uh in the earlier version I saw me
as one of the galleries you know
watching uh you know people play yeah
you got to do it I think I think for the
people who love everybody's golf if
you're a Hot Shots fan like me you know
Shu Yosh it makes perfect sense thank
you so shu How how has how has it been
how has E3 2017 been for you in
PlayStation it's been very relaxing yeah
no no nobody asking questions nothing
happened yeah yeah like like you saw the
show right yeah I did just sh came came
came up you know spoke for one minute
and all the presentation was like you
know video game game game yeah yeah so
there's no like a technical issue that
we don't have to you know worry be
worried about and there's no like a
switching people and uh so the rehear we
didn't have rehearsal yeah there's just
one run through at at the you know night
of the day before night before the you
know show that was it we didn't do any
rehearsal on the same day so cuz
somebody had hit play pretty much right
walk off much however however if um yeah
you are in the auditorium right no I was
watching from
home did you notice there there's a
people coming down when there's a zombie
know Freer yeah yeah yeah for days gone
yeah and uh they moved they are people
yeah you yeah you hired real people to
hang like zombi yeah yeah it scary so
all those things that water came down
from the ceiling and became the display
just so so amazing to be inside you guys
nail presentation last year with the
orchestra this year with again more live
music the water was amazing yes so how
did you feel about your game's lineup um
pretty good yeah how did you feel about
PlayStation's games
lineup thank you thank you yeah so um
the if you had
noticed we had to put many of our games
coming out this year in the pre-show of
e3 media showcase because we wanted to
make the actual show within one hour
games like you know Grand chis sport
everybody's golf KN two and all the you
know new play link yeah I was going to
say the party game you were in yeah yeah
yeah all those things we have to show it
before the show started so if you have
not noticed we had another show one hour
show we aired uh live right before the
uh E3 press you know uh uh media
showcase and it's it's on our YouTube
channel so please watch there are lots
of new information about everybody's gos
and gr Turismo and play link and all
these games so found it interesting no
pad upon in there where was he where you
know where's coming it it better come
quick all right yeah the local Roo's out
good for them now give the people what
they want they want Pat up
on it's now playable from beginning to
the end you know awesome 4K graphics and
uh the team is making sure that you know
so it's now on in the final consultation
stage Japan Studio because the original
cre creators are there still there to
make sure that you know game is prep
preserved the original field and look
I'd be very offended you know if it
wasn't preserved if it came out and it
wasn't what I want yeah you would tell
that I would let you know thank you that
and the the golf game you know that you
know these are like you're talking about
it's my you know a decade in the
industry yeah we're literally reliving
like the 2007 2000 PSP era that I like
that I love so much 20072 2008 so I'm
stoked with what you're doing but I'm
talking about the every go did you
notice that this time around we have put
the developer was able to put nine holes
together one break up yeah yeah so you
can walk to or you know use a c to move
to any hole you don't have to follow the
you know in sequence oh I didn't see
that and you know when you start a game
you are automatically matched up with
other players you know playing at the
same time so you just see other people
uh wondering around why you are playing
the golf or you can watch other people
play uh you know online and you you can
craap or you can do you know some you
know dancing orct other players I expect
you to be dancing for me when I'm when
I'm playing golf yeah yeah so it's a
very Lively you know golf game it's like
a open world oh yeah I can't wait to do
it I can't wait to get hands on with or
get like deep hands on with it actually
have it at home yep um so I think the
only criticism I've seen of the
PlayStation conference right was the
fact that there was a lot of games from
last year and a lot of them didn't have
like solid release
dates what is your what you a lot of
them were the worldwide Studios games
you're in charge of these people the top
of the pyramid actually that was really
intentional yeah um like a Grand Turismo
sport coming 4 2017 go to war coming
already 2018 because
um we had uh announced uh release dates
of many games that we had to apologize
and push back in the past so we and got
together um and discussed seriously
because the PS4 games are so big and uh
all the teams you know very veteran
teams making games for the last 20 years
still miss calculate how much work is
done at the very last part of the
development being you know polishing or
debugging uh so we agreed to not to
announce a release days until very very
very very close to the release date so
that put a lot of challenge to our
marketing and the sales team but they
understood and agreed and allowed us to
just say the Windows like a season like
a fall or spring or early uh until the
we are so close to like a beta finish so
that's not really reason that we didn't
announce the actual date is that does
that make it a a really tough decision
on what to show when like to you know to
show something like days gone last year
and show it again this year and not have
a date or anything like that and which
is fine Eric Jensen working his his butt
off I understand but I mean is that like
it feels like you guys have had a
changeed strategy I guess um well so we
have uh you know uh portfolio games you
know we are in development and we share
that with our marketing and the pr teams
and uh and every game has a certain
point in development that's optimal to
show and announce and uh you know
because uh we have many uh events in the
year uh so we have to kind of yeah uh
strategize like uh to place where to put
you know what content so yeah so where
are you strategizing to play sucker
punches game cuz I'm sick of not seeing
it I think it was two years ago on this
stage you told me you had played it and
I still don't see anything about it I I
think I have played many many more
times God oh such game and every time I
play
I I I I shouldn't be talking
anymore okay I can respect that yeah so
it's it's a game it is a game Sucker
Punch is making a game they are not
making movies uh you know thank you good
we start knocking it out it's like guess
who now we're just knocking it out it's
now very narrow exactly exactly right on
top of that right on top of that um what
you how many e3s you been to youu I I
remember I was there at the very first
one when the uh Steve Rays came out and
just said 299 and as you know to announc
the price of uh original PlayStation
that was a huge so so I think that was
the very first E3 so I mean to E3 every
year every year what do you think of
this year being open to the public
that's uh lots of energy like feel a
little bit like uh PSX you are there
yeah so um I I I think I like it in
terms of the atmosphere and energy uh
but uh it's going to be much more
challenging for like a media people to
play games and we have uh media room so
you know hopefully they have uh have
enough time to get their hands on the
games but uh uh I I hope people are
enjoying are you enjoying being3
yeah they're doing all right don't worry
about them they're having a fine time so
for you right
now what's it like to have so many games
coming that people are super excited for
but then still to be able to come out
and announce something like Shadow the
Colossus
yeah how long had that been in
development how long has that been a
thing there was no I had no idea that
was coming yeah so this is a complete
remake of the game every asset every
everything is you know made new for
changing the control scheme um we doing
some tweaks okay okay I can live with
that I can live with that yeah because
it's been a long time since a very
original game and uh there are certain
things that people like expect in terms
of like uh interface yeah so uh we uh
develop um blueo and uh Japan Studio are
experimenting with something I'm not
allowed to talk about details but the uh
if you as you know Blue Point made the
PS3 uh HD uh version of uh shadow of the
crosses and Eco so they know the game
inside out and there are people in Japan
Studio who worked on original as well so
they are really making the game
preserving the original game the feel
and game play however to really
recreating the game with the
contemporary current gen PS4 uh graphics
and engines so for people who have no
idea about this game our goal is to uh
make this game look like any other new
PS4 sure you know brand new PS4 title
that's why we didn't put remake or
anything in the title we just call it
Shadow of the
Colossus uh I feel I would be R so sorry
sorry to answer your question so they've
been spending over they've been spending
quite a long time yeah as you could tell
yeah yeah making this game yeah yeah so
it was going on in parallel with the
Last Guardian development you know yeah
so yeah they've definitely been working
on it for quite a while uh I feel this
is a golden opportunity to catch you up
with you we get to talk quite a bit but
not as often as I'd like anytime you
want to leave Sony behind come work for
kind of funny let me know oh yeah so I
can take the Colin's uh we'll bring back
PS I love you XOXO if you want to
co-host
it
uh we can get Andrew gorer back and CRI
back sure we have infinite money the
patreons are doing really not as well as
you think no no my question for you
would be talk to me a little bit about
PlayStation VR I was so thrilled to see
PlayStation VR up during the conference
you guys had the five games that I
predicted good good job and thank you
for doing the live stream of moss I
watched it oh yeah you played through
and do watching the game being played by
a person and see the actual game uh
screen and the person play sure that
really is a good way to communicate what
really is the experience of playing the
game you know I mean like our audience
loves PlayStation VR and they want to
see more and more stuff about it so
we're happy to get out there but like
for you we talked so much leading up to
it how have you felt post launch for
about PlayStation VR yeah so the um well
from in terms of uh number of units you
know we couldn't keep up with you know
producing now so you know because going
in because it was the very first year
the consumer level high quality VR has
been possible uh it was very difficult
to read the actual demand you know the
$399 is not cheap at all so it's an
expensive system because we want to make
sure the experience is amazing when we
come out because VR takes people's
senses away and put them into different
world so we really really really needed
to put the very high quality Advanced
Tech component component that which we
did uh so there are challenges in terms
of producing enough unit to catch up the
de demand but now you go to the stores
you should be able to find uh the so so
we've been holding back our marketing
and sales teams has been holding back
promoting the system because we didn't
have you know enough units but going
forward because we have enough unites we
are you know uh uh moving into the
retails uh we will leave start promoting
the system and games coming out that's
all I want to hear and that's why E3 was
such a positive move for it because it
was the fear right of it got launched
and then it got quiet and it was is it
doing well is Sony going to still
support it are they going to make games
for it you guys still are yeah yeah that
that reason as I said was because of the
you know retail inventory situation well
great ladies and gentlemen this is Shu
Yoshida thank you sh thank you get up
get up here ah yeah thank you for for
coming by all right now get off the
stage
um what are you Greg rice what are you
doing over here you struggling is
everything going okay I need to get in
here I need this all right ladies and
gentlemen does anyone know what's in
this
bag I don't know what the hell is
somebody just not a pizza no ladies and
gentlemen what we have here is the kind
of funny World
Championship now if you've been
following
the coward Nick
scarpino boo boo
him Nick scarpino made the belt defunk
the Nintendo World Championship defunk
that was the most half-hearted boo I've
ever heard in my life and I'll tell you
why because you all love me and I love
you
back and if I had time I would love each
and every one of you individually
personally
tonight kind of funny live three the
kind of funny World Championship moved
around round all willy-nilly like Shawn
bowlan from game attack W it however
then the kind of Honeys came in and
stole it and then they remembered that
they don't play video games so today
we're going to Crown a kind of funny
nint or kind of funny world
champion to do that we brought Tim
Schaefer on
yeah now Greg yeah does Tim get a chance
to be the world champion if he wants do
I just take it now we have enough
controllers for Tim to get a chance to
be the champion I think so fine you want
you think you win the kind of funny
Championship you think you're man enough
to hold on to this belt I don't like it
I've already won it in my heart you
haven't won anything very violent not
yet God this thing it's a real belt we
a't screw we ain't screw it around yeah
here sir will you touch the belt confirm
that it's real kind of heavy very thank
you very real he said very real uh today
we're going to play a game called Gang
Beasts who knows Gang Beasts yeah
yeah I think
hello I I feel bad you have these tape
here CU I always feel like maybe you got
like a future of some sort weird so Tim
yes yes am I working I don't know can
can you hear me hear hear you you can
hear me can you hear me can you hear me
a little bit quiet barely can we bring
me back up your mic fell out of your uh
pocket maybe it got turned off when you
put it back in it's not
off you can't hear anything fix it Nick
fix it it's over here it's on can you
hear me I don't think I can hear you
either you trying to kiss me no I'm
trying to hear you oh I'm talking got
controllers Goa okay what's going on you
you you're walking around the headset
doing this that usually means trouble
thank you huh we're fine check check
check check we're going to do this not
play gam on PlayStation 4 I'm going to
make sure it works will be for the kind
of funny Nintendo World Championship Noe
kind of funny World Championship sorry
I'm still used to saying the old thing I
mean Nintendo got really mad at us did
they Mr Nintendo S A ceas and assist on
that one they're going to be watching us
they're behind us they're behind us they
are they're watching us it's a big red
wall over there it's all are you playing
am I playing do you have a controller no
oh okay yeah I mean again the way you
prove you're the best Greg is by not
playing at all how done how you've won
the championship Point am I controlling
it why don't you do this why don't we do
this you play one with him yeah and then
I'll you he'll warm you guys up okay and
then I'll come in and I'll show you guys
how it's done how press X to get
in so now what up and down to choose
your costume we got customization new
build okay and then you get the bumpers
to change your color like here's my
question Tim Schaefer when is this game
coming out cuz I've been hearing about
Gang Beast on the PlayStation 4 for
quite some time you guys keep having
this on the show as long as it never
comes out so I figured uh never why not
yeah well you're welcome on the show
whenever you want even I'm gonna be tie
clip guy I'm TI I am the
purple oh you gotta yeah you gotta be 7
guy are you 70s guy I'm going to be
Grandpa blue this guy he looks like he
maybe works for H&R
Block he looks like he looks like your
your father passed away a few years ago
this is your's first new again sure hit
X again yeah pay attention to Tim yeah
yeah yeah yeah uh we're having a show
Nick we're having a show okay so who's
who uh ever
heard we just went through who are the
colors I'm purple explain it to people
I'm red I'm green I'm blue I have a tie
and a tie clip I am cyan clear not for
the kinding Nintendo World Championship
this is our warmup to see how it runs on
PlayStation 4 and again Tim when is it
finally coming out on PlayStation 4 come
out after if you win we'll just release
it ow okay that would be amazing you why
you punch me to your own death oh oh the
camera no no no this is the new blimp
level it has a few
oh done just let go
just got do it again more all right yeah
okay that's the warm up that's how we
warm up the money here I'll get on the
ground wait where is that belt is that
like a ONE XL like a
that belt seems like a hard one to throw
people off of Tim well you can bounce
them off of
it no no that was the reversal of the
century No we can be friends don't do it
oh do your taxes
Greg Andy are you the one with a toupe I
already forgot who you
are this an impossible
level you can't build this it's a sphere
for Christ's sake how do you throw
people Advanced it's Advance it's for
the adance why you start on the advance
you got to dodge and weave man just
dodge and weave Dodge and weave Harry
the blows I thought it Bob and weave is
it Bob yeah can you dodge it was named
after Roberto oh Roberto we I didn't
know that that's where the that's crazy
see the funny thing about hiring Andy is
that he teaches you all sorts of cool
stuff that you never would have learned
oh there we go was that you
that was me wait winner Tim hold on
we're still here hanging out side Wim oh
you're f and you it's oh I'm
gone I'm
gone I won it said it all right all
right so we got the warm-up victory for
Tim yeah going to the GDs oh is it my
time is it is it goon my time my time oh
no I can't now push him off I'm G to sit
back up sorry guys no okay come on Andy
this is the match up everyone wants to
see oh Jesus Christ nice what the
there you go okay so let's get Prett
it's inspiring see competitors of this
level so are we going to get Nick on for
the actual all right is is this it are
we doing it for real we have to do it
for one we can do it like the buildup
right same where it's like you you
decide how many victories so you have
the three round matches best seven out
of 18 yeah that how math works you can
jump and kick that's not how it works
Nick there's a kick there's a kick how
do you kick what kick it's one of the
buttons one of the buttons I'm going to
say x thanks for the great demo turn
here
first I'm I'm just chilling I'm just
going chill you know what
no damn it oh God I'm going for it get
in there jump over there Jump For Your
Life Care you were not close careful
jumping jumping's risky yeah you got to
risk it shock get how you do that I
don't even know how you did that move
Greg does anyone know how to play this
game no that's why it's not out it's
never coming out
oh my God I'm the winner already no no
no come on no no no no no no no no no no
no no you are the one going out you are
the one going out not me not I no this
is just I just want to win run
round oh my God that was so perfect get
out of
here there we
go I'm out Tim no no Greg that's what
everyone wanted to see Tim versus
Greg Tim get him get him get that ego
get that ego up
Tim raise your hands all the that
Greg talks to you at work dude he's
always like un
unconscious stupid Grandma you can't get
him now all time he mentions mini
chlorians jump jump five minutes no
we're going we're going to need 50 more
minutes on this this is the
kind I'm ready I'm ready put the belt on
the line Nick
here we go ladies gentlemen that was
inspiring to borrow now how do you want
to now Tim how do you want to do this do
you want to set it because you we can
bounce out right can't you send it for
like win conditions of like four wins
three wins Greg rice make that happen
all right every round of applause R uh
let me take one of these he's another
main reason this game's not out I don't
know what is the release date put it out
already it's you know this being made by
a small family in Sheffield England
family's working three brothers and
they're friends like they're working at
the paper mill and then they get home
how many lives how many lives three
lives three lives you have to win three
times huh you'll have to win three times
we have five minutes oh maybe two maybe
two nine nine I like how you went to
nine do you have a preferred stage not
the blimp yeah we we I think we like we
we've enjoyed uh I think the yeah
incinerator incinerator do incinerator
okay let me get back to that uh my
favorite you love to
incate they're all my favorite
that's my secret I'm always playing Gang
be for the kind of funny world champion
three people in oh they were they were
building suspense
okay now what I feel bad forg in baby I
feel bad for Kevin that he's not here I
don't feel well I do feel bad for Kevin
for quite a few reasons but yeah this is
him not being here is that's a good
point great Point
Greg what do you think the Kevin's sweat
factor is Right Now High EX intable yeah
he's sweating as if he's actually
playing on this level right
here no no no
no CU here's a tip don't jump into the
fire yeah no I'm try not to do that for
no reason oh jeez I just got clogged the
Shadows are new that's another reason
hasn't come out yet Greg new Shadows oh
you broke the window penalty for that no
no don't jump into the fire oh my God
stop real quick now the manager's coming
down from upstairs to see why the are
what's going on going on down here
draging that pole enough grab ass get to
work you're going in the fire see Tim no
Tim
no don't worry about me don't worry
about me get him Tim get him
Tim oh God no no
together you're still holding on now got
to press a to jump let's go
boys
all right no Tim yes Tim get him tag
team him no you're playing too
round how did I get knocked out I
don't know what's happening oh just
take him with you jump in there with
what color are you I'm red you're red
okay I don't know I could be purple FR
no you're red no I'm purple I'm purple
no get him TP get him no h reversal get
him Nick get him out of here we got two
take out the trash Nick
him in together take out the trash
sleep he was laying as a trap the
monster don't let the monster
win yo this H it could be anybody get
him get Greg no all the time for all the
times he's inappropriately touched me at
work all right all right get him the
truth comes out those are supposed to be
Daddy secret no no s wrong one one wrong
one
no
what were you thinking we had him the
strategy was clear cheat we were
supposed to cheat like we have one
minute you have one minute if no if
there's if I if I win with one I win
with one and I'm the world champion were
those the rules they are the rules
now on chicken
Christ bring in you guys oh my
God God I hate this game no oh God get
him Tim get
him Tim don't we can't let him win he's
just up there Tim a coward like
Halloween candy where you know you
should stop playing you know it's bad
for you but you just want to keep that
no finish him stay up there Greg just
wait what I we am get out stay out of
this I'm Greg you're such a coward look
at you up there on your little high and
mighty platform pretending like you're
better than the
world DN camping work not even a
metaphor we're not even being
metaphorical this is just happening
right now this is just what Greg does he
sits on his high kill each other look at
him looking down there we know we know
we got to end we're going to do this F
but there's a championship on the line
have you seen this belt that belt cost
at least $10 maybe maner upstairs to
team up on
Greg Greg three some three that means
double team him double team him elbow
concussion just stay down Andy TOs like
no I'm not going to church no no Greg
just give it up you got to lose at some
point yes yes yes yes no oh no
what's wrong with you we talked about
this I tried doing a little sneak attack
you were a sneak attacking no get it Tim
Tim Tim Tim Tim grab
him throw him away oh no Tim Tim Tim
Tim I win I win it's how it's got to be
ladies and gentlemen I'm I'm the kind of
funny the winner and new Champion Greg
Miller that is some
Greg you have to wear this belt
for the rest of the day oh no problem
every party don't worry about that give
it to me I'll put it around you thank
you ladies and gentlemen this has been
the first part of kind to funny on The
Game Spot Co-op stage a round of
applause for game Beast Tim schaer Greg
rice
that this is this is the best you could
do this is the best you could do it's
not even remotely tight you don't
deserve the belt Greg we are going to
take a break kick it up to the Game Spot
stage upstairs we'll be back here in an
hour with more cool stuff until then
it's been our pleasure to serve
[Applause]
you
yeah
welcome back to the gam spot de demo
stage here at E3 2017 a slightly more
populated stage than we are used to uh
joining Dave and myself we have Daniel
from Nintendo Treehouse we have Christa
Joey Jake and off screen we have Sarah
here to play Splatoon 2 Guys what mode
are we going to be playing so yeah so
this is a new mode added to the game
away from the main mode the 4on four
Turf more people are familiar with this
is called Salon run this is a
Cooperative game of up to two to four
players um and we're going to be showing
it off here with these guys taking it on
uh choosing different weapons uh
Splatoon 2 does have that new weapon
called the Splat dues which Sarah's
picking right now right there showing
off her cool outfit as well a we have
these little aprons kind of out going on
there so we're going to get it going um
start starting from 5% difficulty to get
it going from there as everyone picks
their weaponry and presses a to get
ready going so the the different um comp
depending on which level you play it on
so like we're at 5% now difficulty yes
uh the difficulty level how difficult
does it get it gets difficult pretty
fast the goal of the the goal of this
mode essentially is to defeat these
bosses that keep coming out at you in
different Waves by defeating them
they'll turn into golden eggs you take
the golden eggs to your little home base
area which moves around the map
differently and you have a quota based
on the difficulty level so right now you
can see in the upper left corner this is
wave one there's three waves yep to
survive this first wave they have 100
seconds to get three golden eggs okay
usually when you defeat a boss you get
three golden eggs out of them so has
same familiar play that people are
familiar with who know split soon like
basically inking everything you want to
cover much of the ground with ink as
possible so you can move around and
reload your weapon as you need to and
then you basically start taking out
enemies as they start appearing out of
the water so here comes these little
characters coming out of the ground
there these Chums these are not the
bosses yet no they got to see where
they're going to come from they come
from a different angle each time there's
different ones like one called Ms which
is like a shark that pops out of the
ground there's a fly fish that's a
different kind of enemy as well so you
got to see so we haven't found any of
the bosses yet oh there's one I think
they found the drizzler that's where
that ink is coming from in the air so
you need to find out
he's over here so is the ink now a
strategic thing of of movement and
Supply rather than a point system yes so
there they defeated the drizzler with
that umbrella that that iron umbrella
guy now they take the those golden eggs
right to that little basket right there
and they should they already hit their
quot already so they actually pretty
well on their first try through for wave
one we'll see how they keep doing you
didn't mess up guys they didn't mess up
don't worry if they do well we'll see
how they do on the next difficulty so in
another 40 seconds they can keep
actually getting more golden eggs they
want to to keep going above their quota
and keep loading up more with more uh
with more golden eggs more points and is
this a limited wave thing or is it just
going as long as uh three waves three
waves this is wave one for another 20
seconds and we'll go to w is it up up
top so if you if you get more golden
eggs in this wave do they carry forward
to the next they don't carry over but
you get more points so this is the
Stinger right there they took out nice
hopefully they can see if they can get
some of these golden eggs up to the top
before the timer runs out theol take one
egg at a time one egg at a time per
player so but if you leave the eggs on
the ground though too sometimes they'll
actually snatch them up and run away
with them so you have to be careful that
got my egg in guys they got four eggs in
there wave one cleared so now they'll
all reset back to the start back to a
starting
point as they all start and now a new
wave of enems will come I think the ca
will go up to four now they have to try
to get four which means you have to at
least defeat two of the bosses yeah the
water rises so it changes the stage
constantly now they're playing over a
local network right now they're playing
over local Wireless essentially at the
moment but it normally to play online
you can always play anytime you want
over there's Moos you can play over the
over a local network anytime you want if
you want to play online it's going to be
like a Splat like splatfest it's a timed
event a Time based event so it'll be you
have to find out when those times will
be we'll announce them and then you can
jump in and play thank you so much this
is Co-op how does it work if if one of
these inklings get like what happens if
they if they yeah if someone gets
basically splatted out from the enemy
they turn into a life preserver they can
then float around and then their
teammates can shoot ink on them to bring
them back right so it kind of builds
from there as well no one's gone down
yet you're all too good I know the are
actually pretty good we probably should
up the difficulty on them yeah like to
100%
no well we'll jump in based on their
plan if you might go at least we'll try
50 or 60 see how they that level when
they get through that so they they're
already on Wave two so we'll a few more
minutes of this and see what other
enemies they can discover and find I
think we need one more egg meter quot oh
you need to find you need to find a boss
then I know boss salmonoid or alert and
is there like an alert or an indication
of where the boss might be no you got to
find him and then they gu talk up there
he is oh they got to talk teammates have
to talk to each other you can hear them
talking next to us right now Joey
Christa and Jake and Sarah off off off
screen come on guys they they got 30
seconds to get one of those golden eggs
in there got him and it's a game over if
they don't meet if they don't yeah if
they don't get the qua they they fail
okay they have to start over oh we beat
the qu now beat the six eggs they got
six you can as high as you want with
that as you want to so yeah that's the
fun part of this one it's all just
working together and that communication
there any advantage to to beating the
the qua just's more points you get you
get scored at the very end of the whole
thing to see how you guys use score wise
you also do have your specials so you do
but you only use it twice for the entire
wave okay that's steel headit over there
that's another one of them we good he's
hard like he basically has a little
grenade that inflates on his head and
you have to destroy it before he shoots
off that grenade off his head and the
Water Rising I suppose that's the way to
keep the map Dynamic and create some
difficulty to bottleneck the players
really high the water's really high cuz
you cuz England you remember can't swim
they die when they fall in
water so and the home base can also move
sometimes as well so now there's less
space move around it makes it hard for
them there's a scrapper so if you go
behind so you can shoot him from the
front or you can Sak behind him and
actually find his weaker point from
behind nice and he was right next to the
basket which makes
it so it's also working together like
sometimes you got on when we get to the
next we get to the next difficulty which
we'll do in just about 60 seconds um
we'll get a chance to see what it's like
when um you have to more communicate
sometimes one person should be covering
the ground while one person's woring
with taking out the the The Boss
characters definitely fell into the high
tide the high tide makes it a challenge
for everybody so so far so good they
only have three eggs in there so far
they still need two more eggs how many
maps are you looking to so far we're
only showing one this the only map we've
shown so far so have to stay tuned this
is a steel so the front of him is
Invincible but if you wait to the back
there's actually a little driver in the
back of it got him that's terrifying oh
Sarah drowned but now she see now she
turn that life preserver one of her
teammates can to shoot her and boom she
com right back need one more egg guys I
got you I'm kind of C back here so
they're all working together you guys
are actually really good really easy
it's a good cohesive team so about 20
seconds we'll get a chance to see the
next level difficulty so that'll be fun
to see how well they do with that yeah
that's what I'm kind of how high do you
want to make their difficulty go up to
oh no oh I don't want to be too f are in
their hands that's not good Dave does
how where do you want to put it up Dave
uh say like I reckon they could handle
60% 60% okay look how well they're doing
what will happen when you have the
difficulty too is like the water level
as you see Chang it they'll start adding
fog into the game you can't see It'll be
dark at night good job guys yeah he
succeeded the boys now they actually
jump back to their home base which is a
little boat little tug boat off to the
side and then they basically got all
those S those uh golden eggs well done
GG guys yeah point so you be every time
good job good job team they're all
cheering themselves Luigi Maro Yoshi and
Peach by name for this this one but
that's not really
them and now we're going to jump the
difficulty up to see how they
did yeah let's go for 60 oh boy feeling
he feels confident you guys confidence
come on I believe in you I believe in
you all and you know how they it even
changes it's another overachievers good
job overachiever changes that achieve
all everyone hits a to get in there
waiting for Yoshi yep now we're all in
and now we'll see how they do in this in
this next mode oh boy this this an all
this is just a new mode to the game and
there is still that classic Mode the
fouron four online multiplayer game that
Splatoon is known for basically like
Turf War covering everything in ink or
tower control or Splat zones all those
kind of modes are still available in the
game with new maps and new weapons as
well and new gear and you just got a
random color Yes they get a random color
so now they're all playing with pink ink
and we'll see how they do this time at
level 60 see it's starting to turn a
little darker now oh yeah oh you got to
get eight eggs now to get eight eggs in
100 seconds in wave one so sorry
that mean and each each boss us you
three eggs okay so that means they got
to defeat at least three different
bosses and not lose any of the only can
lose only one egg good thing is it's not
high tide so yeah that's true a little
bit so who's playing as who Sarah you're
play Sarah's playing as as Mario yes and
then I'm not sure where you guys are
playing as I'm Luigi
Chris so we got Jake playing as Peach
Joey as Yoshi and Christa playing as
Luigi nice so let see how what these
guys do so far so far so good there's
one of That's So what other variables
are there when you increase the
difficulty like more enemies from
everywhere is it it is it a better
strategy to sort of avoid the grunts and
just go straight for the boss or are the
grunts going to really make your life
the grunts will make your life a living
a
[Applause]
problem um yeah CU sometimes people
start IGN you get overwhelmed they'll
start bringing up a lot of them the same
like you know so far it's been four they
only they've used half the time they
have no golden eggs
guys yep get that and I'll try to cover
you a little bit
the kind spawn on a timer or they is it
down need help go help out in the action
over there there is the action going on
over here so these are like explosive
crates
here yeah they is that just another way
for them to spawn rather than water if
you notice now they've been trying to
get rid of these guys they only got they
have no golden eggs yet what are you
doing guys so they're about to fail in
seconds I think they can still get eight
in 10 seconds me an optimist still one
there you go there's one no one died
though which is impressive yeah we like
cover oh the enemy in slows them down
huh yeah yeah yeah they got oh
go EG okay maybe not 60 bump it back
down they scored well we guys try we you
guys want to try with 40 so you guys do
see if that bring more enemies up there
our just right the right sweet spot to
see you guys succeed see from there
success rate is there kind of like the
weapons you take on is there an
advantage to having different ones
depending on the map or the enemy or the
enemy so yeah I to me everyone's going
to come with their own strategy what
their weapon preferences are what they
like to use um I'm a big fan of the
splattershot splattershot Jr um I know
Sarah likes the Splat du so does Christa
right now there a cool new move with the
Splat dues too that while you're
shooting if you jump you kind of do a
roll so you can dodge it's pretty cool
um so yeah just kind of figure out what
you want to do what works best for your
team like people are just better with
different weapons it's kind of their
play style just kind of figure out what
works best for each team Dynamic and how
you want to play through that this is
dark this time yeah not dark this time
so we'll see where it goes from there so
far so good when it's Misty and dark
that's when yes the flog kicks in that's
when you're in trouble so now we'll see
how they do this time so as again there
they're they're trying to cover as much
as they can with ink now so they can
move around more easily reload uh more
easily as well because as those as the
enemies start coming up they do start
changing the color of the ink ah yes
which make slows down your movement and
you can't refill your own uh your own
own weapons as well so they need seven
eggs this time oh there's Mo right
behind them
someone got splatted oh no Joey up and
there's there's Mo
again oh he's back okay m is going down
pretty soon I think no lost somebody
somebody went down that big
fish nice they got Mo there's
three take those eggs back to the home
base they got three so far they need to
get seven where do okay right now yeah
yeah I think you got those guys yeah
these are MO is coming back MO is coming
this a couple people and some people
have really died pretty quickly on 10%
so it's actually good to see these guys
doing so well as a team has anyone beat
on 100 yet I have never I tried it and
die like in 30
seconds uh from what I've heard I think
Chris said the dev team's actually done
100% your game I hope they can do it if
anyone can so so far two guys are down
oh they're all back up okay everybody's
back up and we got an egg here
egg one person down Sarah's down Sarah
uh got a lot of eggs down here Sarah Ste
head Qui oh my goodness now there's a
lot happening on the screen I just got I
just got splattered here but I'm
carrying like was it like two bosses on
the screen already yes it can be three
something's four five w got it hit the
qu they hit the qu see more intense than
the
highy well they were yeah they were is
everywhere say
alive get one of us them yeah he's
running trying to get theam oh they sa
they surv the first wave oh that was
close you get this do you get a moment
of rest fight between y like the 10
seconds to 10 seconds to basically Rec
clear up the screen get ready get that
ink they they lost covered back up and
ready to rock and roll so we'll see how
they do this
time does the egg basket change location
or is it this one say the same some they
can move to different location like
there's a little beach head it can go
over there which actually is one of my
least favorite spots for two toe because
then it gets hard to get out there oh
got the enemies here oh there's M all
right little warning
oh driz coming out yep the
umbrella pan everyone's still alive you
guys are good oh lost
somebody I
know did I get
you nope oh little help sign I got you I
got and more eggs yep oh I just got sped
but there's two eggs next to me so
someone should uh there you go thanks
Mario oh oh noio down got splatted again
two people
down peach peach out and you can move
that's a good thing you can move while
you're in the life preserver mode too so
you can actually
teammates and if you leave the golden
eggs see he just took him he's running
away
with got it back you got it back nice
tried to steal oh what a jerk what they
do come on now there's two steel heads
on the screen wow halfway there really
crazy steal yes I saying Ste little
what's that up no a grenade you can't
defeat the steel head you have to wait
till that you have to destroy that wall
it's on his head oh okay careful oh no
two down M's coming out oh oh no oh 20
seconds 20 seconds to get two more
golden eggs
intense
oh the Valiant Last
Stand help can they get golden egg oh my
God they just getting swarmed that was
just
coming
oh covered it and they all just died so
close we're very
close yeah two waves one wave but yes
that s and run right there go guys
really like fast and frantic and like
the difference between was so much more
than I expected a lot more yeah a lot
going on that's great at one time 60%
will be fine yeah fine no it gets really
intense you get higher in those
difficulties for sure well guys thank
you so much for uh coming and playing
the game yeah July 21st July 21st not
very not for all yeah for sure uh and
for more make sure you don't go anywhere
we're going to have total war Warhammer
2 right up
[Music]
next
in
[Music]
e
one
[Music]
all
oh
[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to the gam sad
stage here at E320 17 live and joining
myself and Dave is Al Bam from The
Creative assembly good evening welcome
the Brit the British are here all three
of us we're here in force we're taking
over uh to talk about total war war
hammer 2 uh Al what's the show been like
for you uh fantastic um uh particularly
given I think that it's um it's open to
the public again this year yes it's been
absolutely rammed very Buzzy and uh yeah
amazing really got a little jungle down
there hav't you yeah you got a great
Booth yeah yeah we have we got a jungle
we've got a um uh the the eight foot
head of a carnosaur um hanging over the
stand ready to bite people on the head
so want one for my living
room isn't it yeah pretty much so I
understand you've got a a battle you're
going to walk us through between the
lizard men and the high yes this is the
battle we've had playable at the uh at
the show it's called The Battle of the
Fallen Gates and it's a quest battle for
Croc gar who's one of the uh legendary
Lords that's playable for the Liz when
you play campign all right let's take a
look yeah so this is kind of the the
setup right at the start of the battle
you start with small Force um you see
cocar riding the carnosaur which is the
T-Rex style beasty down there in the
middle chap at the back yeah exactly and
and this is this is actually uh a new
battle type to to Warhammer um that
we've we've sort of used in historical
games before but we've never built into
Warhammer it's a choke point battle so
the whole point is there's there's a
major choke point on the map so whoever
you know if this was a predal battle
between two armies that you would
generate on the campaign map then
obviously everyone's going to want to
kind of try and control that choke point
because it's a it's a good kind of hot
gate setup to to defend you you put all
your you know your toughest melee troops
along that bridge to defend everything
coming and put all your archers behind
effectively so but in this situation
it's the lizard men who have to sort of
breach the bridge so to speak so all the
beasties charging in full Pelt and they
do a lot of impacts these things they've
got play pretty much every attack they
do as a sort of AOE smash damage attack
which knocks loads of guys flying over
so so this is the section just sort of
after after the bridge where they
they've they've beaten their way past
the first um Ela Defenders and they're
sort of cresting the Hill here um you
see the dragons just blowing its fire
breath down there so we the dragons you
know we had them inside War Warhammer
but they didn't have breath attack so
we've now given all dragon breath attack
so they're much more multiroll now they
can do you know big flame damage to oh
yeah man lovely we got quite a few new
um synced animations like combat
animations between large versus large as
it um so both of those guys have special
attacks against each other and and and
special combat moves so the tail swipe
in the face the the classic tail swipe
in the face there um and you'll see yeah
you'll see um you'll see the carnosaur
shoulder barge the uh the dragon to the
ground at points it's really good fun
lizard men looked like you've always had
monstrous units but that seem to be a
core thing yeah it's it's really it's
really kind of what they're all about
and um it's it's funny I don't I don't
think I don't think lizard men are
perhaps one of the better known R es in
the Warhammer world and as whenever
we've shown people this they've just
been you know humming the Jurassic Park
theme tune
and and um yeah and and just laughing
with Glee when they see those those Mass
those high mass units smashing into into
units of sort of Franken F troops
there's a load of kind of red red Angry
flashing going on there which represents
those those units there are certain
units especially theal units in the in
the lizard man army um when when they've
taken enough damage and they get angry
enough they they go Rogue basically and
they blood lust yeah exactly they just
charge pel towards the the nearest enemy
and and in order to eat them essentially
so um this is one of the um one of the
lizard men's um well the sort of flying
Skirmish unit really um they're called
pteranodons mhm and these guys are
fantastic
for zipping around and taking out
archers at the back of the enemy line or
um or actually ganged up like this they
can actually do quite a lot of sort of
classful damage at the same time CU they
they have uh what they you see what you
see them firing there are called fire Le
Bolas um thing little creatures that are
sort of buried in The Jungle which they
which they dig up and throw around and
basically work like a form of magical
Napal um and they can also drop bombs as
well so you get the reticles pop up when
you want to drop the bomb and then they
can uh they they they carry you know big
lumps of rock into battle with them so
you got a couple of rock attacks that
they can do throughout the course of the
battle so soften them up with the uh the
these bash and then you know drop a load
of rocks on them and they start rting
they yeah um so you know a relatively
lightly armored unit like this they'll
see a couple of units of these guys will
see them off real quick um and when it
comes to it you know if they're out of
ammo you can charge them in as
well you know they're not the best melee
units in the world but they they they
will you know they will um cause a unit
to think twice uh about about where it's
standing coming at you yeah exactly away
they don't look very big you know from a
distance and then you put them next to
uh a single unit and you think actually
they are quite large yeah they don't
really want flapping in your face yeah
um so yeah that's the um that's the
pteranodons um so that was just a brief
uh you know that was just a few sections
of that battle that whole battle last
about 15 minutes um and we've got it
playable here on the show floor we've
got an easy version for for newcomers to
Cal war and a hard version which I've
never seen anyone do better than a pic
victory at so far which so it's a good
challenge um that's what I got I got per
Victory I'm not quite as good as I used
to be but um you're saying that's a
that's a quest battle what can you tell
tell us about the reason behind the
actual battle itself so it's it's um
it's kind of a almost a challenge or a
right of passage battle for um for Croc
gar and it's delivered by Mazda Mundi
who's the who's the the oldest of the
living slan Mage priests and big fat
frog people might have seen exactly the
the floating Toad on the throne yeah um
and he's uh he he essentially gives this
quest to um to crck guard to go and
prove himself and he gets a he gets a
you know a unique magical item at the
end of it so he's got several stages to
go through like Quest battles we have in
the game which culminate in that big
battle there and what and the whole
objective there is the High Elves have
turned up they they they're kind of
diddling around in this ancient sight of
power um that was that was um it's
essentially an ancient teleporter for
the old ones who who were the Gods uh
the sort of the the earliest Gods um who
actually created the liab Ben the first
race of the Warhammer world and they
used to zip around the universe using um
using teleporters and giant pyramid
spaceships so um so that's like that's
the very very early days of the
Warhammer Universe they're not around
anymore um uh but all these relics are
left behind so the high Alves come along
they they sense some kind of magical
energy there and the the lizard men spot
that they're digging around in the ruins
and they're like no Noob not no no so
they they that's the quest that's the
the ultimate objective that Quest battle
is to is to out the High Elves from
their act activities so how is the world
different now because Total War
Warhammer one it was almost kind of
recognizable there were humans involved
and it was all kind of connected to
history it you could recognize like
swords and armor but now it's dragons
and elves Dark Elves and giant lizards
how has that changed the Warhammer world
now it's even more eclectic than the
previous one was so um in a number of
ways really I mean all the races all the
playable races are in in a kind of in a
race uh so to speak to control the great
Vortex which is a giant magical sort of
tornado that sits on Ulan which is the
island the homeland of the High Elves
and they're all after that so they're
all in they're all intentioned to get it
and and um what that creates
is um throughout the throughout the The
Narrative of the campaign you're you're
you're performing these these rituals
and hoping you can keep them going for a
few turns that you need to keep them
going before being attacked and then
that gets you one step closer to to to
dominating The Vortex and Achi your your
sort of ultimate Victory conditions and
throughout that it really brings those
races together and you start seeing the
differences between them um and we've
really I mean one of you know one of the
things that we did with the first game
which initially was a bit of an
experiment fingers crossed I hope people
like this was to make the races
completely different and right and have
fewer but much deeper um races with much
different Camp you know vastly different
campaign mechanics and that work very
very differently in battle you know and
and you know to be honest a tabletop
game just gives us that in the Army
books we we know that those armies are
going to play differently but reflecting
that in the design for their campaign
game mechanics is is very important as
well and and with that worked really
well so we're doing more of that we're
doing that more so than we even we did
in the first one so so the various the
various races have have completely
Unique Mechanics um such as the lizard
men can access this thing called the
geomantic web which is a sort of ancient
network of lay lines that runs or runs
beneath the um the surface of the Earth
um all set up by the old ones back in
the old days um and and they can they
can re reenergize these by capturing
cities that connect across these lay
lines they can re-energize them um and
it it brings like some some really major
bonuses to those settlements and their
ability to raise resources raise taxes
and that sort of thing um and defend
themselves as well um so they can really
they can really exploit the landscape in
a way that no other race can you know so
so this this is where those differences
lie it's in those fundamental differen
between the way those factions work so
we've always said that you want the
you've got a three- game plan how are
these games going to interact now now
that Total War Warhammer 2 is near upon
us how is it going to interact with
people who own Total War right so
so the sort of basic of it is is you get
a new campaign with with every with
every part of the of the triny so part
one you've got the old world campaign
part two you've got the new world
campaign setting the the Americas if you
like of the of the Warhammer World um
and the third game again will will will
bring you you know a new place and and
new places and new faces um and so you
get those individual campaigns um so you
can play those they they're the proper
big campaigns but shortly after launch
of Warhammer 2 um we're we'll be
providing as a free update um a sort of
grand combined campaign map which
attaches those two parts of the world
together and lets you play as any of the
races that you own across either of
those um either of those uh games so you
own Warhammer 1 and you own Warhammer 2
and you get the combined campaign map
and you own say the wood elves because
you got that for Warhammer one you can
then play them in the grand campaign and
take them right over to meet their to
meet their long lost cousins in ulwan
and nagaro in in in the in the um in the
new world so um and the the way it
differs is that so as I explained we've
got this this um this sort of narrative
Drive uh mechanic leading you to this
cataclysmic end game which which The
Vortex represents the great vortex
represents we won't be doing that in the
combined campaign map it's it's it's
pure sandbox although it still does have
the the sort of chaos Warrior Invasion
from the first game um it it you know
we've decided to keep the vortex out of
it because we want that to be the
ultimate sandbox game you know this is
it's it's like the Holy Grail of Total
War Games having all those factions
which are so hugely different and being
able to play as as any of them so and
that's that's we think that's the best
way of going about it and um people seem
people seem to be agreeing so that's I I
think we're doing right you mentioned
the vortex I understand that that's kind
of your new mechanic to drive the armies
forward and drive your progression kind
of kind of a pace that's you feel like
there's always something lingering
behind you yes exactly um uh you'll see
you'll see that we we've got a specific
piece of UI which tracks the progress of
each of the races so if you suddenly see
the High Elves darting ahead you're like
I might have to kind of break off with
what I'm doing and go and take them down
a peg or two and oh look they they're
casting a ritual and it's you know which
and rituals are sort of connected to
settlements so you can you can see it
happening on the campaign map and you
can go and try and interfere with it and
stop them from performing their ritual
and it creates this tension because it
might be driving you away from your your
your sort of single-minded I'm I'm
expanding in this bit of territory right
now and I really want to put my
resources into developing these three
cities and making a nice production
Center over here or something like that
um then that happens so it P it pulls
you away from that and gives you you
know gives you a new and quite quite
time sensitive and crucial objective
that you you know you don't want those
guys to get too far ahead cuz they could
win the ultimate Victory because and if
they do that if they get that far ahead
you'll lose the game we can actually
have there's a discret point at which
you can now lose the game I mean
obviously you could lose a total war
game four but that's if you lose your
last settlement you're out of the game
you've been knocked out effectively but
now you can be knocked out by letting
the other Racers beat you to the vortex
and and similarly you can you can um
well not not so much ignore The
Narrative of that but you can choose not
to engage with it with with with the
Great Vortex stuff and if you want and
you you think you're able to and you've
got the you know and you've got the you
know the knowledge and understanding to
do it you can expand your Empire and
just try and destroy those races and
knock them out before they can do
anything with the vortex so you can
still play in the traditional way um
it's just that you've got that extra
level of challenge of of they're all
they're all driving towards doing
something that that you're not
necessarily on that racetrack with them
you're just trying to smash up the cars
you know so one of the draws was that
you could play these vastly different
races through these campaigns with with
friend friend how is the the interaction
between Total War 1 and 2 going to going
to change that if if I want to play with
my friend but he doesn't own the first
game I'm assuming that he won't be able
to really play as things like the Empire
yeah exactly you need to own both games
to get the combined campaign map that's
the that's that's that's how it works so
um so if youve if one of you owns one
and one of you owns one and two um then
you won't be able to c i you still be
able to C between in in the old world
with with your because you're on you're
both playing the first game effectively
but you access the the combined campaign
map through the second game and it
understands you've got the first game so
you get the map sounds like quite a
tricky way to to organize thing must
been quite challenging to link all this
stuff together it is so you know I won't
joke you know I won't I won't um make
any bones about it is it is a challenge
and it's it's and it's big and it needs
a lot of a lot of time play testing and
balancing you know because it's it's
it's massive and it's going to get
bigger with the again with the third
game so um so and that's one of the
reasons we're releasing it slightly
later than launch because we want to
give it its own time we needs time to
breathe and and be tested and be tested
and be tested some more so so yeah we
you know we're quite confident it's
going to be tremendous Fun by the end is
that going to be a thing you learn from
like the first few weeks of 12 World
Warhammer 2 you're going to see how the
community reacts and plays before you
create that combined campaign well to be
honest it won't be too far off the
launch so it will be some way down the
road of of getting it done by then but
yeah I think there'll be it'll be useful
feedback to see how people are playing
what factions they're preferring what
particular tactics or strategies they're
using which mechanics they're really
involving with more than others they're
really involving themselves in with more
than others so and I think that's
particularly true of Someone Like The
High Elves because they're quite they're
quite um yeah High Elves are are hay
arrogant and they're very political
creatures um so they've got a whole a
whole set of bonus bonus activities that
they can do in diplomacy they can diddle
around with other people's um other
people's diplomatic activities so so in
some senses you you might want to play
The High Elves and just be a total a
total politician about it and just
manipulate all the factions around you
you know into go into war with each
other and um you can't just you can't
just do that you I mean you need to you
need to gather influence which is a sort
of you know you need there's certain
activities you you can do to go out into
the world and you gather influence so
once your influence is increased you can
do these things more and more so you
can't just do it at infin item without
actually engaging in the game but um but
yeah it just means you can play in a
very different way and I think that's
going to be interesting to see how
people you know when the game comes out
see how people play play the games and
see how they focus their factions to
other races to um you know to try and
Conquer their way through the world so
are you doing s like the your long-term
strategy is it going to be similar to
Total War Warhammer 1 where you've got a
mixture of DLC fre LC exactly that and I
understand you've changed based on
community feedback you're changing your
launch add-ons approach after the chaos
Warriors Yeah well yeah this time around
we decided to try something different um
so we're yeah we're actually
releasing uh a race pack for Warhammer 1
so and it's quite a significant piece of
content as well
um um yeah we you know we we we want
people to feel that their game is
complete when they get it um and you
know War 2 will have its DLCs as well
and its free LC's as you mentioned but
yeah we we and we spotted an opportunity
to do something that we've um been
thinking about but haven't been able to
get into Warhammer 1 that we think would
be a really good addition as well so um
so it's not and it's nice to not just
leave the game behind to know that we
can go back and and still add more to it
so yeah I think it'll um it's a yeah
it's it's a new approach for us
definitely and we'll see how it goes and
surely it's a big uh win for your
community as well to kind of proving
that you're still going to support the
game y long after launch exactly yeah
yeah yeah and I think I mean it's
Warhammer is massive like War the one
world is big and I think we could be
making we could probably carry on making
the games for years the game for years
and just keep adding stuff to it so um
you know we've we've we've got our we've
got our kind of three- game plan with it
and there's there's there's lots of DLC
and FC you know characters and factions
and all that kind of stuff we we know we
want to add to it but there's there's
still more to do you know if we wanted
to so you know there's there's I'd say
the sky is the limit to some extent you
know now one question keep evolving so
one question I get asked a lot from
Total War fans and strategy fans is they
ask me for a reason to get into a total
Warhammer because the hobby itself and
the LW itself is seen as quite
inaccessible what would you what would
you say to get them into it yeah um well
I'd want to show them dinosaurs firing
lasers uh being ridden dinosaurs
obviously but um um I I think it's just
that it's the diversity the content um
then and the the the rich character that
each of these races has um and when you
you know if you play Warhammer um you
know if you play Warhammer if you play
40K if you play tabletop games with a
range of you know a range of different
sort of factions you you pick one that
you feel you kind of fill your gel with
right so um so I play ogres because I
quite like they're big and Stompy and
they eat everything and you know so I'm
an ogre player on the tabletop because I
I just dig them other people play other
people play uh green skins cuz they like
that kind of kind of jokey like jokey
comedy element they have and the
randomness of how they work on on on the
battlefield and you know that's
definitely something we tried to reflect
in the game um and I I just think
there's there's there's so many there's
so many flags in the game which you can
kind of which you can kind of hoist as
your own as it were um that I think and
then there's so much depth to the
there's so much depth to those to to
those um those races and there's so much
Variety in the different Army builds you
can go for um I just say that it's it's
just a great game you know it's it's
it's um it offers almost endless
diversity and fun so so you play ogres
but I play scaven do you and I know at
the end of the trailer there was a rat
that looked I don't know if he was tired
but he had the red eyes and he looked a
bit
scavy I I don't even know what that
happen scaven what what what are scaven
you know you know what I'm talking about
give me scaven no no I me you know I've
heard rumors yeah I've heard rumors um
about giant you know man-sized rats but
it's clearly utter codswallop so
uh yeah I don't I don't I don't I don't
really know where you want me to go with
this cuz um
it's it's like it's like you're saying
you asking me to believe in a lie you
know is that what I'm asking yeah I I
think you are I think you are live here
right now asking me to believe in an
urban myth I think you just like teasing
glad I'm in the middle to separate you
two yes I don't not like teasing you
um so uh yeah we'll see as as a
colleague of mine said recently the
fourth fourth race in the game has not
yet been ratified interesting right
interesting choice of words well I'll
than thank you so much for joining us uh
the game is playable on the show floor
when can the folks at home get their
hands on it uh September 28th we're out
um pre-orders are open now and we talked
about you know what you get for that
some some great Warhammer One content um
so yeah September 28th is the release
date and it's not long to go so we've
got um we've still got a bit of work to
do um but we're getting there and uh
yeah we're looking forward to the launch
awesome awesome well thank you again
thanks uh guys make sure you don't go
anywhere we're going to be going back to
the E3 show floor where Pal's kind of
funny have special guest Brandon Jones
from Easy allies so make sure you don't
go
[Music]
anywhere
this
e
want want to go
br
for
no
is this is
a
what's up everybody welcome back to kind
of funny on game spots Co-op stage at E3
2017 how are you
audience that's what I like to hear you
were loud enough that the one guy
playing Tekken was like what and turned
around but now he's right back to Tekken
s asking his questions I'm one of your
hosts Greg Miller alongside the P one
Tim Gettys let's him host and from Easy
allies Brandon
Jones love and respect thanks for having
me is your mic on talk into it well not
if you don't talk well yeah I think so
get someones I like it I like it how are
you excellent how having a great time
has E3 been treating the Allies really
good uh yeah no no no big complaint so
far I think we're really digging
everything that we're seeing so all
right awesome awesome now Tim yes what
you wanted to bring to this segment was
arguments yes I want controversy oh
let's do it you want to argue about who
had the best conference the best press
conference of e3 2017 now real quick who
had the best conference this
year that's not even a question get hyp
everybody Nintendo is back they brought
Mario they brought Metroid Prime they
announced a new Pokemon yes thank you
where's Nintendo there's Nintendo
they're behind us you probably can't see
that section's over we're
done Brandon do you agree that Nintendo
ran away with it well I I still have to
see Ubisoft in its entirety and I I
thought that was the that's what I hear
as the front runner a lot of people
saying that really Rooster T thinks that
they're the winner for sure rooster te's
paid
off I said it so so challenge you want
to debate so what what did you like out
of Pokemon from the Nintendo like what
just the fact that we know that it's
coming I understand that sounds empty
we're getting a core console Pokemon
game made by Game Freak this is a poke
tournament this isn't some you know
Pikachu and Magikarp friends or whatever
the hell this is a core Pokemon game on
a
console H come on although it's it's way
you think it wasn't happening like did
you were you concerned that like oh
they're finally done with that Pokemon
FR it was I don't think it was the
concern that it wasn't happening it was
the belief because they lied of just
nothing like that would happen at this
confence well I'll tell you about a lie
this is something that pisses me off
when I see in press conferences I hate
the like oh I I just happen to be at my
desk thanks for coming by like let me
tell you that like I ha the staging of
just like I was just drawing Pikachu
here presentation is very very important
but let me take you back Brandon the
reason I'm excited about this the reason
it's important for them to announce it
cuz you say oh obviously they're doing
this right do you remember the Wii U not
many people do I yeah I remember when it
first came and it was like you know what
this launch doesn't seem good next E3
we're going to get our Metroid games
they're going to announce a Pokemon
console game we're going to get the next
Mario like the next big thing no we it
never happened we didn't get that so now
that the switch has come out we've
gotten great launch games launch game um
you know there's a couple other things
happening we know we're getting the next
big Mario and it's awesome yeah we now
know that the Pokémon's coming right
like all their major franchises are
coming soon or than later which is
awesome I'm going to hit you on a
technicality though because uh the
Metroid return of Samus was technically
not in the Nintendo Spotlight which I'm
okay on the stage I'm totally you try to
just sneak that in there and I'm not
buying it no I don't no no no Metroid
Prime I'm Prime yeah yeah no the return
Sam that's awesome I agree honestly I
think was the more exciting announcement
not that like that game's going to be
better than Prime but like we saw it
they played like a lot of it DS it's
dead to me I don't need it I hear you
I'm I mean I won't be playing it but I
am excited for Metroid fans now here's
the thing taking my fanboyism back a bit
I understand yeah a fanboy of Nintendo I
understand that uh a lot of the
announcements made of the Nintendo thing
that I'm really excited about are things
that are years away and are just they're
just kind of empty right it's logos or
literally just a guy trying Pikachu I
get that but on top of that we get Mario
we get fire and bom Warriors coming up
we get all this stuff and I feel like
they did a really good job of kind of
letting us know what the rest of the
year looks like and giving us a glimpse
into the future and I think that was a
really important question that I had as
a fan that they answered yeah now
getting off of Nintendo for a second I
feel like a lot of the other conferences
I don't think there was a bad conference
this year I think they were all at least
good sure EA was a little frustrating
and Bethesda was super short yeah but
EA's was just so traditional in terms of
like Hey we're EA and here are all the
games you know about and we'll promise
you Star Wars we'll promise you Star
Wars here's way too much Star Wars yeah
oh yeah the trailer is great here's 30
minutes of multiplayer I'm like know if
I need to see 30 minutes of M 30 minutes
of Battlefront 2 was a bit much in the
cont but it was one of the only like
honestly live we have no control over
how this is going to play out demos that
we saw in any of those example why you
shouldn't do that in a press conference
you don't like that excitement that VI
that guy legitimate that Darth Maul
legitimately got 34 kills live and
that's that's awesome we saw him own
that match that was not rehearsed but to
me that is a postc conference if you
want to see this here sure I keep saying
the press conferences are kind of like
when you watch a movie and see all the
trailers before it you don't have a
choice of what trailers are put in front
of you but that forces you to watch all
of them and be exposed to things that
you might not have ever clicked on or
seen before but with the press
conference I feel like they're coming
out and they're going to announce games
announce games announce games when they
focus for way too long on one you're
alienating so many people and I feel
like EA still doesn't quite get that uh
when they come out cuz I understand that
Madden needs to be there and that NBA
Live needs to be there and all and FIFA
obviously
but why does that take up 45 minutes it
could take up 10 what what's the impact
it's it really hard for me to gauge is
that like I know FIFA has a huge
audience I know they're really excited
about getting updates but are they
really tuning into this conference like
are they really like the audience is is
now the time to really focus on them
yeah was trying to juggle that pre-show
post show how do you do it because it's
Sony did the same thing Nintendo did
which is just like you have this
conference where all eyes are on you but
then Sony used their pre-show to
announce announ you know release or Show
everybody's golf show all these
different things that people wanted
announc super massive games one of their
three or whatever and then Nintendo at
the end is putting the return of samis
there it's like I don't taking all these
announcements that you would
traditionally see as just a Sizzle reel
I think you would have had more eyes on
it you know Shu sh was on the show early
and he was talking about the fact of
like if you didn't watch our pre-show it
is up on Youtube We announced a bunch of
games there and it's like well that's
maybe the problem in terms of marketing
that information like there got way to
deliver that in a fast here we go see I
I disagree because I feel like uh
especially with the Nintendo thing I
think that putting it after the
conference gave Nintendo another Spike
of news stories and it was another
moment of like but wait there's more
yeah but they I think they let that
message not get out the right way right
we it was people tweeting about it of
like hey I work for Nintendo you need to
see this you it seemed it seemed to be a
last minute sound the Clacks on
everybody get over here and look at it
right in the same way that then EA had
it misbalanced I think of having that
giant P piece of Star Wars there that I
think would have been better served of
awesome trailer for Battlefront
then hey everybody we're signing off but
if you want to watch 30 minutes of
Battlefront stay right here yeah then
I'd be like oh yeah right and I think
even Nintendo's thing should have ended
then like hey Mario's Great everything's
thank thank you all we're going to
legitimately announce five new games in
this post show at treeh house to stay
tuned yeah whereas PlayStation even used
I'm a pretty big PlayStation fan and I
totally missed the messaging that they
were going to announce stuff during the
pre-show like what audience are you
serving do do you think that is directly
combating like Jokers like us that do
our own pre-show son's like no we're
going to like you can talk about what
we're going to do but we're actually
going to do stuff so you're going to
watch us and yes no I think it's the
Ever Changing landscape that is video
games where it's like we people are
learning the power PlayStation knows the
power now with PSX of activating your
fan base and they will come and they
will support you and da da da how do you
do that at E3 I think next year they're
going to have a hey there's the press
conference but in the parking lot there
is an open to the public thing where we
will announce stuff and you can watch
along live with us cuz they need to
manage this where now we have 15,000
fans here who are treating it like a Pax
or like a PSX you can double down to
that use that a really interesting way
and I think it's interesting to see
people struggle with that what do what
do you think about like you know
comparing something you know like uh
Aluma being like Oh I have the master
sword in my hand how did that happen you
know versus like Ubisoft like mamot
running on stage with the Cannons and
like just that like that was I thing I
think liked about Ubisoft is it had
heart it had character you know it had
passion like it would there weren't just
like a couple of like legitimate
emotional highlights like it just kind
of felt the commment I really felt it
the whole way through my my thing is I
feel like presentation for a press
conference is one of the pillars one of
the most important things obviously the
games presentation important to you Tim
is that something that you focus on
absolutely I I think I think I think
when it comes down to it that the um
Bethesda conference did such a good job
of getting in and out and making things
fun and to just segue to things and we
might have known everything from it but
it was presented in a way that I feel
respected our time and there wasn't
stupid gimmicky stuff and like the
Bethesda land stuff was the glue that
hold it all together whereas I feel like
Nintendo directs they still kind of have
those awkward moments that don't isn't
that what we love about Nintendo I feel
like that's part of the charm Reggie
coming out and being like look and like
everything's falling down around him in
this weird computerized world and he's
got a switch you're just like all right
you're Nintendo still oh I have a sword
interesting like here's when the
Splatoon tournament's going to happen
it's like maybe not in your only 25 why
why doesn't that double back I would
think to hey that's part of a tree house
announcement we're going to really talk
about what that is or a pre-show thing
of like a Sizzle reel telling you over
and over and over again like this is
this tournament this yeah I don't know I
feel like in terms of content Nintendo
is the clear winner I think in terms of
presentation they're not I think that
it's a tossup between Bethesda and Sony
I thought Sony really stepped up their
game this year uh in terms of making it
entertaining to watch and yeah they
lacked a lot of the gut punches that
we're used to the last couple years for
them I mean Shad out the Colossus remake
like that was a genuine surprise for me
where I would have never thought that
was going to happen awesome that was the
I was talking to somebody about it today
right of like oh man you didn't like the
PlayStation press confence like no it's
not that I didn't like it it's just
after Grand Slam after Grand Slam after
Grand Slam to hit a home run you're like
all right yeah good job hitting one you
know I I mean like it's like yeah it was
a it was a solid conference I liked all
those games and especially being here
now and seeing those games and like
being able to look at them and like see
behind closed doors it's like these
games are going to be amazing in terms
of conferences like personally it's the
library I'm most excited about it's the
one that where Mo the majority of games
spoke to me but I can't you know when
I'm watching the Nintendo one be taking
back by they when they surprised us when
it was that first game that was 2018
they were like whoa you said you weren't
going to do that and then like n no here
it goes yeah that was awesome that was a
cool moment what was your read on
Microsoft uh I thought it was fun I
think we were talking about flow like I
think they they actually do a good job
of I love the theater I love the the
shrine when Sony had it there because it
really gets a sense like we're at the
opera video games now uh but it does get
a little you know Relentless and kind of
tiring when it's just like another
trailer another trailer another trailer
and I do love that because it gets right
to the point but like I know some people
that hated the Bethesda land you know
Motif but I liked it because it does
kind of guide things you know there is
like you can see the transition moving
from one thing to another and I think
just presentation wise Xbox does a good
job of that like now we're up in the
corner over there and now we're over
here and now we're going to bring player
you know unknown over on this side yeah
so I thought it just had a nice flow
that way and I thought I thought they
did a great job of having quantity of
games like there was like when they came
out they're like we're going to have 42
it's like oh man like this is this is
getting real they mean business with
this I feel like they did a pretty good
job of getting out of the X conversation
pretty quickly where it's like here's
what it is you either want it or you
don't let's get to the games who's going
to buy an Xbox One X L of Applause for
the 1 2 3 four no one no one let me try
it again clap don't raise your hand
don't do this shrug thing who's going to
buy an Xbox One
X golf clap what what you what do you
think about saying 42 games ahead of
time though because like that that is
one thing that irks me a little bit is
like the Cockiness like that's why I
didn't like Battlefront because they're
like we got The Campaign now it's like
well you should have done that before so
don't get too excited like I I I it just
doesn't sit well with me when people are
like this this press conference you're
about to watch is going to be great it's
like just do it and we'll figure it out
afterward show don't tell I I feel like
Bethesda did that in a lot of ways where
there it was the show don't tell and
again they didn't show anything that
made people go what but they I liked
that they kind of gave us the
forewarning of that image of there's two
work in progress things and they got
people you know predicting and talking
about it and then everyone guessed what
it was so that's why people were
disappointed by it but then when we got
it I was like all right cool they gave
us what they said they were going to
give us and I feel like when it comes to
Microsoft I enjoyed them saying that
because it let it was a message that
they are cocky about this and I feel
like they're in a position where they
need to believe in what they're doing
because other people as judged by the
collaps here they're not buying
it and that I mean I guess that's maybe
what's it is like if you announce it
beforehand I get the sense of maybe you
don't believe that you're kind of like
saying it before that just like in case
you don't believe it we're saying it's a
fact right now so you can't dispute it
because I just told you yeah but I I was
proud of Xbox for not like going on and
on and on about XO like I was I was
concerned I'm like they're probably
going to get into that right off the bat
and like man I don't want to spend 20
minutes just going over all of the the
nuts and bolts yeah then it was the
thing too of like you know we're talking
about 42 games that was awesome but then
it was like to finish the conference be
like well of the 42 what ones do I want
to talk about like right now right St K
obviously move on from there like but
that it's personal preferences but it's
like it I said it on the live show right
it was like Adam boy years ago described
to building a PSX conference that they
wanted everyone to walk away from their
10 announcements with like three things
they were excited about right and I felt
like Xbox was one was like a little
harder for me to come down with even
that out of 42 right yeah know that
that's true I mean but I mean I don't
know is that true like for me some of my
games of the show in terms of like wow
factor Anthem and and the last night and
both of those were in the Xbox thing and
those are two games well last night I
hadn't heard of before and Anthem I was
totally not interested in I'm not a
BioWare guy but seeing that I was like
oh I'm now interested like they sold me
and I think that the presentation they
did at that Xbox was awesome true true
that was a good point so can there be a
case well Ubisoft really people are
saying they won oh yeah just because of
Beyond Good and Evil well no I feel like
Ubisoft had a really good showing of a
lot of games that spoke to different
people um Rabbid surprised people the it
was nice balance it had a little bit of
everything had like and it had a
surprise the the teaser projecting
something we're probably not going to
see until 2019 2020 something that we
are going to see recently like like
having the affirmation of rabids having
like surprisingly looking that being
like this kind of looks difficult and
and charming and like I don't hate these
rabid you know Mario characters as much
as I thought I would yeah exactly yeah
that's what I thought too and then I
watch the gameplay I like oh it's XCOM
on switch with Mario all right yeah okay
I could play that yeah I don't know
again I do think that this year there's
been a lot of negativity about the press
conferences in general of just like oh
man it's kind of a shitty year for E3
and I think that it's not shitty it's
just not this
fantastic uh event that it was in Prior
years I think one of the big reasons to
that and one of the points you're
driving at is the same reason Nintendo I
think clearly won is because Nintendo
caught us off guard PlayStation came out
and Shadow was the big thing right Xbox
came out and it we knew Crackdown you
knew State of Decay you knew about the
Xbox you knew about Scorpio is what we
called it we knew Anthem was being shown
exactly and so it was like you knew like
coming into all these things Destiny's
already had its event there's all like
we're getting in there it's like yeah
I'm excited to know more and see more
but it's not going to blow my hair back
this isn't something coming this isn't
Shemu you know coming back no I I think
that overall though it's like it's the
surprise factor that was lacking in a
lot of it but what they made up for is
the fact that I think that there is more
quality gam shown across all the
conferences than in E3 history ever wow
bold claim I think so okay what do you
think challenge someone look through
every year make a list check it twice
I'll give you this about Nintendo Tim
like that Mario reveal was probably the
giddiest I I was during all of those
press conferences like we saw that
coming dinosaur thing what got again and
I was actually going to make a point you
know when we were talking about it
before the press conference I was like I
bet when we see Mario it'll we won't
know it's Mario right away they'll do
that again because you saw the city
before and you saw like new don city
like wait what you know I'm like popping
out of the street and it's like if you
if you were to like grab the average
Nintendo fan and be like what is the
absolute opposite of Mario and it's like
a prehistoric Beast clearly like the
last thing duh everyone know next sh
Yoshi all right so we all agree send one
I I will acquas I I I again just have an
opinion easy allies he wanted aate you
can't be everybody's friend he wanted a
debate he's bringing it bring just let
me know when the debate's over and then
I'll you know then I'll you know debate
the debate is we'll do Nintendo Nintendo
one Ubisoft
one
wow okay Bethesda one Bethesda
PlayStation wow Nintendo one yeah Xbox
all right wow would you say box and PS4
were pretty even you know no no okay hey
whoa offending some people that's a
topic for another day Brandon Jones
thank you for coming on thank you guys
so much for having you can't try to have
an opinion now easy allies get out of
here we love you love you bye Brandon
Jones Brandon Jones everybody what a
nice young man thank you all for
watching along with us here E3 2017
thank you all for coming in person um
you can clap for yourselves at that
point oh wait what what was the uh Jeet
Bush please clap
uh next up state of De k 2 okay you're
getting out of here I'm out good thank
you when it's a Greg Miller game Greg
super excited before I kick everybody
else out got do so yeah who's excited
for State
K2 yeah all right good good good sir why
don't you come here you seem to know a
lot about state of DEC
too good everybody this is Jeff from
Undead Labs he's going to tell us about
it sit on
down State of Decay 2 yep very excited
who who played State of Decay
one man a lot of you suck you all need
this is your homework assignment go home
and play the original State of Decay
it's on 360 it's on Xbox one it's on PC
if you're one of those dorks thank you
no problem well you know I'm such a big
fan of it right yes you talk in the
microphone yep okay good um what I want
you to tell me I want to start
from what is it like to be backstage at
Xbox's press conference you know that
your game is about to go out out there
with this huge trailer that's going to
show all this new stuff cuz like Undead
labs in State of Decay I've been behind
since me and Ryan mcaffry were doing
let's plays at IGN of it and for me it
always was a small XBox exclusive right
like every time I I talk to your PR lady
like you or you not you're Community
woman like you know you guys are a small
team and that's how I always think of
you so for me personally as a fan to
watch you guys go from that just a table
at a px I remember walking to your table
outside of you know just at the top of
the staircase to seeing you on that show
what's it like to be watching that
happen
terrifying yeah I mean State of Decay
was a uh a labor of love Yeah by a you
know very small passionate team in
downtown Seattle uh we were entering a a
genre that's crowded yeah you know uh
you know when you announce that you're
making a new zombie game the the
reaction is do we need another zombie
game right and uh the answer is always
yes by the way well you know we we
thought it was because uh we wanted to
capture something new right we wanted to
focus more on the survival fantasy
aspect rather than the the zombie
killing aspect right and make it more of
a simulation so we punched above our
weight a little bit with with the
original State of Decay uh I think that
uh uh you know the the the game brought
a whole lot of new uh Play Elements a
whole lot of new systems and features
that people hadn't really experienced
that kind of blend between third person
action and RPG and Base building and
simulation before um but it was as you
say a small team and uh you know we're
we're fortunate to be able to do the
sequel uh it's bigger budget bigger team
uh much more fully supported by
Microsoft our Publishers so you know but
still we are not a 300 person Juggernaut
team you know uh making something that's
been a 10year AAA franchise and the you
know fifth installment of it right uh
and so being in that room uh at the Xbox
briefing and seeing it up there on the
big stage and of course all I can do is
focus on the warts right I yeah of
course see everything you don't like
about it in fact I can't even watch it
right now cuz I'm just going to see
every flaw and it's going to drive me
crazy uh but uh it's an amazing feeling
it's exhilarating to be kind of swimming
in the in the big ocean with the big
sharks uh but it's also terrifying
because uh we have our work cut out for
us to be able to uh kind of punch at
that weight how how much bigger is the
team this time for Undead laps uh
original stated at a k team uh I think
by the time we released we were 20 22
somewhere in there yeah uh you know
we're somewhere between 60 and 7 at this
point with another probably 40 people
external to the studio working on it so
wow quite a bit bigger yeah now was that
always your vision for the team and what
you wanted to do or was it Xbox really
believing in you guys and wanting you to
be a big part of the Xbox One well I
think it's a combination of both uh you
know we still aren't done right we uh we
very much believe in the power of what
we call the survival fantasy genre right
this is not about killing zombies it's
about giving you the tools in your
toolbox to go put your own Survival plan
into action right I mean I I know that
you've probably sat around with your
friends and talked about what your plan
is and I I think everybody here probably
believes that in the zombie apocalypse
they would survive right he's got a
zombie plan he's got a zombie plan
exactly all right stop for so so the
goal was stop for one okay you got it
okay everybody we got to get it real
clear real quick all right I understand
it's the end of e3 day two whatever you
want to count it as if you're going to
be in the audience and I'm going to ask
you a question you got to clap
or Boo or whatever but this this doesn't
help no don't boo no don't boo no bo so
again who has a zombie plan there we go
thank you these kids you know what I'm
saying all worn out they've been putting
VR on their head they know what they're
doing so the first game was kind of a a
first swing at that yeah at realizing
that survival fantasy have given you
those tools um and and it was a big risk
I'll be honest with you right I mean
there's some things in that game uh
perade death yeah uh is a big one right
when you're when your one of your
survivors dies they're they're dead
forever we sat around when it first
released and wondered if people would
Rage Quit uh and it turns out they did
uh but the question we weren't asking is
will they come back and it turns out
they did right um so there were a lot of
kind of uh game design one-onone rules
that we broke and you know Microsoft
blessed their hearts stood behind us to
release that that first one even though
they couldn't quite figure out what it
was either um but it all came together
and uh you know somewhere between four
and five million sales at this point
that thing took off like a rocket and so
now uh they can see very clearly that
there's an appetite for that blend that
formula sure um we're excited to take it
the next step and and they are too and I
think they're proud to have it on the
Xbox platform as an exclusive title so
for the fans that are watching at home
that are fans like me what are the big
differences for state of dek2 because I
basically I've seen the two trailers and
I've read what you guys have put up on
the blogs but how do you summarize
what's different this time around you
know
um we didn't decide to take it in bold
new directions yeah right we have a
formula that works and you always
straddle the line when you're making a
sequel to a game that was successful
between uh just Recycling and rehashing
what you've already done sure uh and
doing so much new that you kind of
disengage and disenfranchise from where
you were so fundamentally we wanted to
listen to what the players said they
wanted and make that game we had this
Grand Vision way back in the day you may
have heard class three class 4 uh and
class four was going to be a big kind of
open world right and the success of the
of of State of Decay we thought no let's
let's let's not do what we think we want
to do let's do what our fans are asking
for and what they were asking for was uh
more polish yeah right uh larger
world uh deeper simulation deeper
mechanics of uh character uh and base
options and Co-op multiplayer by far and
way the number one thing that people
wanted to see so state of k 2 is that
game it is a uh you know we had the
opportunity to say what works what
doesn't work where do we want to
innovate uh and kind of blend all that
together with the feedback we got from
our fans and and make a uh you know a
full uh a full sequel to the game yeah
so how does multiplayer work this time
how does Co-op work is it drop in drop
out am I starting a game with you am I
taking my stuff back to my game right
you know it is drop in and drop out we
we put a lot of thought into the
concepts of um you know people
co-sharing bases and being part of same
community
uh or building a party at the beginning
kind of uh MMO style uh and and none of
that felt right what we wanted was very
seamless very smooth and quick pop in
pop out I can come play with you you can
come play with me but um one of the
cooler mechanics we have is the flare
system where it is true that I can if
you and I are friends I can just pop
into your game sure uh if I'm you know
or you can pop into mine but what we
wanted is to also have capture that
element of like it's a big world out
there there's lots of people right and
so in the game if you get in trouble you
can shoot a flare gun and anybody who is
also playing the game who has checked
the box that says I'm willing to be a
volunteer if they'll get notified that
you need help they can just click the
button jump into your game they're right
there where you are and they can help
bail you out the game will reward you
substantially for helping people out but
you're also taking that risk of putting
one of your survivors into a dangerous
environment Perma death counts I'm
bringing over the Survivor I'm playing
as per death always counts all right wow
that's interesting that's interesting if
I and if if I drop into your game with
my Survivor I bring back rewards if I
get stuff or take that's right okay
awesome awesome yeah so we'll reward you
for sticking your neck out uh just like
in the actual game if you decide you're
going to build a farm right uh you're
taking a risk you're sending survivors
out there putting them in Jeopardy
you're making noise at your base which
could invite a Siege uh you know a
zombie horde to attack your base it's
all about balancing that risk and reward
and that's why it's truly a uh kind of
survival simulation what I loved about
State of Decay was the base game
obviously right and building out my
bases getting stuff I'll never forget
the first time I had to drop a ruck sack
because I was over encumbered I thought
that was the coolest thing in the world
still do uh but then you guys did so
much different stuff with the DLCs where
you did like the Army encampment you did
like a a hoorde mode were those things
you wanted to try or were those things
that you were looking for input on from
the community or were they just things
you wanted like what has made its way
from that into state of the too it's an
astute question um I'm a student of the
game big fan of this game did you know
that you knew that yes you
do so uh you know the answer is that
um there's a spectrum in these games
between being a pure sandbox
simulation uh at one end of the spectrum
and at the other end being a very uh
linear lead you around by the nose
narrative right uh which is to some
mechanics in between and um and state a
k was successful because it's a at least
partially because we Blended between
those two right and breakdown the first
DLC was just the pure simulation for
those of you who just want to play the
game see how long you can survive here
it is Lifeline was almost the opposite
it was much more narrative heavy telling
a a very specific story uh and the great
thing about those is they they kind of
defined ends on that spectrum that we
were able to then extrapolate see how
players played it see what they liked
about it what they didn't and it really
heavily informed what we're doing with
State of Decay 2 with State of Decay 2
there is still a story that you follow
but it is much more driven and
influenced by the simulation and by the
way that your particular base and
survivors interact with that simulation
so we're not talking a whole lot about
it right now but it's something we're
super excited about interesting and then
in terms of you know the game's bigger
it's this you bigger map is that we're
dealing with more things to investigate
longer Play Time absolutely bigger uh
you know right now there are three Maps
roughly the size of the original game oh
wow okay yeah that's yeah that's good
yeah and you know beyond that uh uh it's
just deepening of the system so you have
more options even as you play Within
those Maps uh for example the traits
that determine each survivor's unique
abilities and skills uh in the first
game there were couple hundred maybe
there's well over a thousand in State of
Decay 2 uh and the common at toic
effects of that pretty much ensure that
every Survivor you find uh and invite
into your community is going to be
unique and they're much more tightly
integrated into the base mechanics and
the overall simulation too so you'll
feel like the impact they're having on
the world is much greater
how long did you start on dead labs when
what yeah um I started on dead Labs uh
probably early 2010 did you expect it to
go this way like to that you'd find
success with something like this or was
this the plan to stay with thing or did
you want to jump around different
projects you know when I started the
studio uh and especially uh brought in
uh you know the first uh colleagues of
mine who were going to be working on
this with me uh we we had a pretty
singular Vision right we we built that
studio to make this game yeah um now
that doesn't mean it's all we ever want
to do right you have to have your your
kind of uh starter house right um and
this has grown into a mansion which is
fantastic um but I think that that far
beyond even the zombie genre we've
really tapped into something unique with
the survival fantasy yeah uh and when we
think about the future there's all kinds
of places I could go right that I won't
talk much about but uh
you know did it go according to the plan
I had not exactly yeah right I mean I'm
thrilled to be in a situation where you
know we've built a thriving company uh I
think that the people who work there are
are happy and healthy and enjoying what
they're working on uh and there's a a
lot of Pride and satisfaction in doing
that even beyond the games you make uh
but as far as this exact plan that we're
following here it's nothing that I
foresaw precisely this way uh but I'm
thrilled that it's happened this way
we're getting ready to wrap up so what
for you is the most exciting thing about
State of Decay 2 like what when you talk
about it what really stands out that
it's something new right this blend of
third person action and RPG progression
and Base building and simulation the
whole notion that you're in a world
where your decisions have consequences
and that your decisions determine what
you're doing as you play the game um I
think it's fun to be able to sit down
with people like you and and kind of
talk about it and not really to find how
it's differentiated right it's not that
it's you know more guns or a little bit
prettier or uh you know um has kites
right uh at a very profound level I'm
proud of the fact that uh in an industry
where there's so many great games so
many fun experiences we were able to
actually find something that people
hadn't seen before and I'm super proud
of that that's awesome yeah when St the
K2 coming out spring 2018 give a real
date what is wrong with you my my
Microsoft people are out there watching
me with the eye of saaron I can't say
anything more than that I love you guys
thank you well you just subscribe to him
as like the ultimate Evil but okay yeah
no big deal Jeff thank you so much for
coming on man get back Greg get get back
and finish the game now all right love
you ladies and gentlemen one more time
for Jeff and state of the k please
that's what I'm talking about energy
let's finish strong everyone you still
having a good
E3 good thanks for just joining us I'm
Greg Miller this is The Game Spot Co-op
stage I'm from kind of funny we're
streaming it people are playing Tekken
and they're looking at us again that's
what I like to say Tekken players who
wants to talk about
XCOM thank you well they were like who
wants to talk about XCOM all right
ladies and Gentlemen please we give it
up for Mr Solon himself Jake come on
Jake come here no hugs hugs all the hugs
No No hugs don't let go I don't I've
missed you don't ever let go you were
one of my favorite up and noon
interviews of all time and now you're
back and I'm so excited don't ever let
go okay that's fine now it's getting
weird is it weird now okay while making
eye contact with Rahul too it's very
awkward everything's going on how are
you sir sit down better now yeah that
was good yeah so you're making another
XCOM yes yeah yeah making another one
what's this one called uh This Is War of
The Chosen this is the expansion to XCOM
to uh oh hey look oh what what time look
that hey look there's a trailer yeah
okay cool yeah what's happening in this
one uh in this one we we have the chos
these uh these uh lovely ladies and
gentlemen you see here these are sort of
like the ultimate enemies they're three
very powerful enemies they have
personalities um and they they're sort
of hunting the player from the beginning
of the game gotcha and so the those are
new enemies and here are a new toys for
the player to play with we've got three
new Soldier classes as well and so these
Soldier classes kind of pair off against
the Chosen and give you a weapon to
fight them
with why uh does XCOM yes continue to
exist um well uh I mean in a positive
way XCOM I like XCOM you know this
people love XCOM where they play it
nonstop what do you think it is that
makes your fan base so
engaged um I guess it's I guess it's
overcoming challenge I mean you know
xcom's kind of known for being hard um
for being kind of a challenge did my
voice break there it didn't right no not
at all you're you're a grown ass man
your voice doesn't break thanks for
having me on you like XCOM I have done a
lot of talking um yeah I think it's it's
the what we offer is something that kind
of looks like other games but it's very
different when you play it you know it's
it's all about taking your time and it's
about tactics and
strategy um and and yeah it's just a a
sort of different way to have an action
experience but you know you kind of
think about it you get to feel clever
hopefully yeah how long have you worked
on XCOM oh
geez it has been almost it's been over
10 years that I've been working on XCOM
now was that the plan when you got the
job oh my God what was that the plan
when you got the first gig of work uh
the plan was to make it to the next year
to the next year to the year after that
and so here I am and but I'm blessed I
mean I'm the kind of guy who I I don't
take this for granted um like the
ability to be here to be up here with
you to be at E3 like it's it is such a
gift um and so like in this industry and
I I've said this before like it's you
know it's every game if it's if it's not
a great game it's probably your last
game you know and that's how it works
and so for me I just feel very very
blessed to be here to be in front of all
these very very beautiful people hi
thank you
um it's just it's a gift to be up here
and just talk about it to talk with you
so yeah it's how do you keep iterating
on it though how do you keep making XCOM
new cuz that not at its base level right
it's you know strategic
combat it is and so yeah I mean that's
the struggle um but there's so much it's
nice because there aren't too many
people in this space and so it's not
hard to to come up with new ideas and
say this would be a really interesting
Twist on it this would be a way to make
it fun you know with the expansion pack
we added characters with personality
we've added a lot of new toys but we've
added a lot of personality of the game
and that's something we haven't done
before enemies that can talk to you can
remember things that happened before who
have kind of grudges against you and and
I think it it it adds a whole new
element to it hey that's XCOM hey xom's
on the screen right now yeah looking a
lot more colorful than usual yeah it's
very colorful you know we we use the
whole palette man it's a rainbow it's
it's uh yeah and and you know what when
you customize your soldiers you can make
them look however you want you know were
you surprised to see XCOM finally
success it has on
consoles um for a long time this was a
game strictly for PC works that's right
that's right and I think that people
sell I think people sell Gamers short in
general people sell us short right no
matter what no matter what platform you
play on people tend to sell a short or
they they Market as if we're you know
we're not capable of loving lots of
different things I mean look I'm not
going to lie I watch The Real Housewives
of of Orange County um that does not
mean that does not mean that I don't
also now I'm struggling to come up with
something smart uh I don't know I chop
Lumber I also chop Lumber and I read the
New Yorker and I watch The Housewives of
Orange County you're a renaissance man
over here is that what a renaissance man
is um but no I think that people you
know there's
[Music]
a there is some condescension and I
think that that's not true so for
console Gamers like what they need is a
a good game a fun game and it's on us as
creators to say look none of us have a
lot of time now we need to make sure
that it's understandable that it's
palatable but as long as you make a a
good game then I think it doesn't matter
what platform it goes
on you said something interesting there
you know we don't have a lot of time now
right so many things are pulling from
for our attention have you ever thought
of not dumbing it down XCOM but making
it easier cuz one of the best videos
I've ever seen promoting a video game
was the one where you were inside the
game store and they they did this viral
video where he was just walk up to
random people who are looking other
games be like what about this what about
XCOM or whatever and there was one where
you're like uh you can play 30 hours of
it and and lose the guy's like no I
don't want to play that at all and uh
that guy did not buy a copy oddly enough
my sales pitch was was not laser sharp
so no yeah I think that and it's funny
because I think that I've what happens
is that you hear oh XCOM that's so hard
and then I had moments in the past where
I would lean into that and be like Oh
hard everybody wants hard and but that's
not true I think what what we all want
is to be put in a difficult ult oh my
goodness look at the customization on
that robot it's have you watched your
own Boll here what it you don't haven't
watched your own b-roll no I I I assumed
you captured all this no I don't know
what that's from that's that's
beautiful so yeah I I think that instead
what you like what we all like is to
feel a sense of challenge but to have a
way out of it have it be more of a
puzzle and so I think that yeah I think
that there are ways to make the game a
little more not not accessible that's
not the issue but sort of make it more
of a puzzle and we did that a lot with
the expansion like we worried we didn't
worry about making the game too hard or
or not hard enough but we tried to give
the player lots of tools so they can
play it how they want no I understand
what you're saying I think that we all
play games to overcome challenges but
when it's infinite continue and there's
no big deal you lose that right it
doesn't matter as much but at the same
time we all have so many games we could
play and so I have a very low
frustration meter right and so if I run
into something and I'm like they're not
explaining what I'm supposed to be doing
next then you know then I'll give up
because I have 10 other things I could
do exactly when get to that point of I'm
going to take a break a break inevitably
turns into 3 months later oh man I put
that game down never I think I like that
game but I yeah I stopped at some point
yeah yeah I think that's what was
interesting for me with XCOM is like
when it came to console the original not
the you know what I mean the HD one on
PS3 Xbox 360 or whatever like that was
the one for me where I hadn't played I'd
always heard of XCOM I Charles on yet at
IGN at the time had loved it forever
jump in and play it it was that thing of
like I've heard this game's really
intense but it was it was intense in the
I'm going to name all my characters
after the podcast be on guys and then
Ryan Clemen is going to get shot to
death and I'm going to feel terrible and
tell him the next day that that happened
terrible but it's fun to tell people
right exactly yeah I have some bad news
you didn't pull through you got scared
on the battlefield I should you did make
it should have got you but your wife is
still surviving and I will comfort her
for you well that's weird yeah that's
then you took it and made it really
really maybe everybody that's everybody
right is that everybody you know what
I'm talking I guess that's everybody
yeah how big is the team right now
working on X uh we're about 60
internally um so you know we're
relatively lean for I don't know I mean
some teams you hear about nowadays I
don't know hundreds thousands of people
villages entire Villages are making
games nowadays 100% um states there
entire countries and I was going to say
Mike Biffle had all of the UK behind
making Thomas Was Alone and volume
that's right that's right an enormous
team um so yeah we're about 60
internally and then we have some
external stuff as well and so it's fun I
mean we we get to we get to make what's
fun I think for the team is we get to
make a game that's different and so it's
fun to go out and talk about it because
you know we can say well this is
something different we we get to offer
people a different experience and so you
know it's just exciting to get out there
and talk about it has it made it hard
though to offer a different experience
right you're not the you're not the AAA
firstperson shooter or third person
action so like are you getting as many
opportunities to go to IGN Gamespot all
these different places yeah I mean you
know I'm on kind of funny and so that's
like a you know Top Line top of the
pyramid right there no and and I think
that what it comes down to is that it
has it has fans at at you know again it
it sort of has like hardcore fans at at
every venue and so we we get a lot of
opportunity to talk to people and it's
certainly popular enough that you know
we get to talk to a lot of people and
it's great because to interface with
fans we get to show it off to a lot of
new people and and and um it's been
exciting to sort of be up here and be at
E3 and and um yeah it's so you talk
about not having a lot of competition in
the space
sure what was your reaction at the
Ubisoft conference oh did they did they
do something they did something
interesting where they took Mario and
Rabbids and gave them guns okay yeah it
was I was watching I was watching the
stream and I was like okay oh rabbits
and Mario okay and then they're like
walking around they're like and this is
the point where we enters the Tactical
combat and I was like the what
what like and we are passing around and
Luigi has entered half cover and I'm
like
what I was like I I I think I might be
having a stroke like I it it blew my
mind it was awesome I mean yeah you you
see things like that and it's
it's very exciting because obviously
those are the kind of games I love and
so seeing Mario like walking around and
like flanking people and they're like
Mario has OverWatch I'm like that's
amazing so I I think for me it's an
opportunity to like play a tactical
combat game actually with my daughters
who they they've never seen XCOM you
know so for me it's a it's a great
opportunity to like introduce my
daughters to that kind of game and so
then to me it feels like like well maybe
more people will play that and then if
they're like yeah but what if Mario died
forever I'd be like oh if that peach
rabbit never got back up right that's
that's me in the shadows being like Hey
kid you like you like Mario plus rabbits
yeah you want something a little harder
yeah you want to do autopsies on those
rabbits yeah we we got that we got that
over here we got the hard stuff so yeah
no I like that that was my takeaway and
Hope from it too watching Switch fans
get excited for it it was like cool yeah
it can be and I don't mean it sounds
insulting to be like it's babies first
or it's like first you know I have no
idea how deep it'll be right but it is
that idea that once you wrap your head
around that combat to say oh man I'd
like more games like that what is that
and then that's pretty much you and
that's the Ben of it too is that we all
borrow from each other and so if if they
can do some things in the Tactical space
and I see that I'm like because they got
a lot of awesome stuff they got the
jumping they've got the the the pipes
and I already see things where I'm like
that's awesome you know that's really
cool that sounds like a really cool idea
and so turnabout's fair play I Was yeah
now you're going see it so XCOM plus
rabbits that's right see what Happ I
think I I think yeah I think I can
legally put Mario maybe he can be a
super character in XCOM who knows so do
you worry about running out of ideas for
what to do with XCOM um no I mean I
worry about everything I think that if
you're a creative type right you you're
always worrying you feel like a fraud
you know and you're always worrying
about oh you know how can I how can I
ever do this again how can I do this
again and then you get into it and the
ideas just start coming and I and again
I think that this is a space that's
underserved and so to me I I think
they're
just look at them they're hijacking your
your you're trolling me yeah there it is
and here they are they are moving to the
Tactical combat space uh we will we will
destroy the rabbits uh they have invaded
s and yeah
so um yeah so no I think that whenever
you start thinking about a new idea I
mean you know how it goes right yeah you
once you once you start thinking about a
newa the ideas they just start coming
and I I I don't think I could ever
Implement all the things I want to by
the time I'm going to retire which you
know hopefully isn't soon you think
we'll ever stop fighting the aliens just
fight somebody else maybe you know uh
rabids maybe no don't mean I'm not I'm
not I'm not dialing back to the rabbits
don't worry about the rabbits everybody
it's not what we're talking about talk
about XCOM yeah I mean I think that the
the type of game is it's perfect for not
just what we've done for a lot of
different thematic environments so you
can imagine a medieval space you can
imagine a modern combat space I think
all those things would work I think and
in my head and I should nobody T those
are copyrighted now those are all
copyrighted we've already registered
URLs no one else has to do anything
that's right and so no I think that that
XCOM is more than just the story it's
certainly more of a system and so you
could take that and you could drop that
in a lot of different environments and I
think you could tell lots of new stories
make lots of new games out of it and so
that's certainly exciting to me uh when
is XCOM 2 War of The Chosen coming out
August 29th it's coming out for PC PS4
Xbox One smart smart okay cool yep how
much is it going to cost don't know yet
damn it I thought I could get you on
that one I I I truly have no idea I'm
just a I'm just a your's the idea man
you don't worry about the finances just
a poor creative type I I don't know they
guide me from place to place and I'm I'm
a man baby I honestly I I do only one
thing so that's fine well it looks great
thank you for coming by thank you it's
always great to see you now hug me again
hug me again come here come in for it
he's a good hugger everyone should try
to hug this man after the fact buy his
game too because that'd be nice thank
you for
coming
oh XCOM huh I'm telling you there's a
lawsuit there against Mario and Ubisoft
and anybody else who wants to get in the
way uh have you had fun ladies and
gentlemen
here thank you for joining us Believe It
or Not we've come to the final segment
of kind of funny on The Game Spot Co-op
stage Tim can you believe it no not at
all yeah it's went by really quick it
did go by really really Qui good though
I lik it Tim you brought somebody up who
you I did this is my friend Dan hi Dan
he brought something here you go oh my
God hell yeah let's play samario let's
go right into it
everybody oh my God yeah yeah so here
yeah we're actually doing a live
gameplay demo with our friend Sarah over
there on the side you can't see her on
camera but she's playing for us
here apprciate it she's playing games
for us all day but yeah we're just
showing off one of the two stage we've
been playing uh new donk City in the
Metro Kingdom kind of Show gameplay
there all that good stuff I heard you
guys you guys got a chance to play the
game also right we did get a chance to
play uh there's a let's play going up
later on youtube.com/ kind of funny
games subscribe like share uh but I had
a lot of fun with it we played for about
15 20 minutes and I I'd say about seven
and a half minutes-ish per level so it
was fun my thing is Mario games are
probably my favorite games of all time
when I if it was a single franchise I
would definitely say that that is my
favorite franchise now we haven't gotten
a 3D sandbox Mario game in a long time
yes which of Mario 64 Mario Sunshine
yeah and then the Galaxy games were
fantastic but they were kind of weird in
between where they were a lot more
linear than yes they had that too yeah
the devs actually describe it as a uh
miniature miniature Garden which is uh
I'm going to pronounce it incorrectly
but hakona okay is a term for Miniature
Garden which is what they do and they
very intricately designed very
particular how they designed it so you
can just go and explore and discover
everything in this condensed space yeah
they kind of try to create so what's the
philosophy then for going back to the
other style they just want they they
wanted to do something different using
the Hat the whole thing with cppy a
different exploration aspects that's why
they want to do something different with
this one they've already done Galaxy so
they want to do something different when
they did created this they want to
create something that people could just
really have fun with and be complete
lost at the same time just be surprised
as they're going through the whole game
like jumping up taxis so looking at the
trailer it was absolutely Bonkers yes
starting off with that T-Rex and all of
that like that where did that type of
inspiration come from the devs actually
from what I from my understands like
they really decided one of the first
they came up with was the idea of
capturing that whole capture mechanic
and then they basically just asked
that anyone any idea they could come up
with and they had a bunch and they
basically chose their favorites to
create the game so hence the T-Rex being
taken over with C all that stuff like
that and even the different now they
have different outfits too right now you
can see buy this outfit bu the suit
too so something that I noticed when we
were playing the demo is that there's
checkpoints all all over the uh the the
levels right and every time you get the
checkpoints you can go to your map and
fast travel to those Point yes you can
fast travel different points on the map
yeah how big are the maps compared to
the Mario 64 maps for example that
that's what they're trying to compare it
to is the idea of collecting all those
moons like similar in Super Mario 64 was
collecting all those different stars but
this one you see in this he's in a
little suit oh let's go he does look
good I love it he has a tie on
everything so yes but no that's why they
start they they really want for that
Mario 64 Style just uh just to have more
fun with it how they design everything
the capturing mechanic we're talking
about a second ago they really had fun
with it awesome so in Mario 64 every
level had about six stars that you can
collect how many moons are in each level
oh jeez uh I've seen some so far that
had like 30 40 50 plus yeah there's a
lot of moons in them and the moon power
the The Odyssey that's Mario ship to get
around from Kingdom to Kingdom um but
yeah the difference too between Mario 64
is that every time you got a star you
had you start to level over again this
time when you get moons you just keep
going okay so it really does try to get
you into that idea that you can just
keep playing over and over so you can
play for like 5 10 minutes to find some
moons or you can sit down for a marathon
session and play Forever I mean I feel
like this is a very lofty comment to
make but seeing this like seeing the
trailer and then playing it today it
kind of is giving me breath of a wild
Vibes in terms of
Reinventing what Mario is and making it
so open and not getting in your way and
wanting you to keep exploring and trying
different things and like I had such a
great time going around the corners and
getting moons and being like Oh man
here's another one here's another one
and it kind of felt like it just kept
ramping up in the same way the shrines
did see you see one off in the distance
you see a moon even though you're going
for another one you're like wait how do
I get this one how do I go through and
do this that's actually a big difference
between breath of the wild and and and
Super Mario uh Odyssey is that it's more
about that thing you find right in front
of you versus Zelda was like how do I
get to that point way off in the
distance so that's what they really did
differently in this game well something
that I didn't do a good job of in the
demo I did early and I kept failing at
is one of my favorite things about Mario
64 was that beginning level like outside
the castle yes just going with the trees
and cl climbing them and flipping off
and just trying to figure out what I
could and couldn't do and immediately
within 5 minutes of playing this I was
like wait can I climb that and I was
like oh I can climb that oh I can't
climb that trying to figure out what the
rules are and especially New Dong City
like seeing the skyscrapers it's like oh
there's ways to get up there yes and
there are ways to get up again reminded
me of Zelda in a lot of ways and just
feeling there's a lot more verticality
uh to the levels than there was in say
Mario 64 mhm that's something they
really built in this one as said that
whole density that really that sense of
exploration that's inside area they're
having a lot of fun with that for
sure so the human people yes in New D
City with make you
feel how do they make you feel you happy
about that I I think it's pretty cool
it's I like seeing Mario do something
new and different You' never seen him
before so this is only and this is only
one of the Kingdom this is the Metro
Kingdom so all these different things
you see there's Pauline hang on the
auditorium mayor Pauline we saw I I love
the the Easter eggs here obviously
Pauline from the original Donkey Kong
game uh another thing we ran into is our
friend Captain Toad yes Captain Toad's
in this level guys yeah you got to go
you got to go find Captain Toad if you
play this when you find him does he
confirm that Captain Toad's treasure
Tracker is coming to the Nintendo switch
no he doesn't he doesn't tell you
anything he didn't tell me anything no
not anything yet yeah find out I'm so
excited to play this game it's like one
of the the best things for me at E3 is
playing a game and being like all right
I don't want to play this more right now
because I can't wait to just play the
entire thing that's just even though I
work at working at Nintendo there's
often times where I will avoid I will
only play what I have to play to talk
about the game but I don't want to know
anything else cuz I don't want to ruin
for myself so I can played at home I do
feel like it's an additive experience of
just kind of going through and finding
every Moon and seeing every place you
want to go and and getting there and
also I love that there's a lot more
mechanics going on uh than in previous
Mario games especially with the hat with
Cappy that Cappy changes everything of
how this game works be able to use the
Hat different ways the capturing all
those things going on so yeah that's
that and and see what's going to be like
when you capture the T-Rex the the
goomas the the moai which we which you
I'm not sure we got a chance to get that
far in the sand Kingdom with the
sunglasses oh we didn't get that if you
get far enough in you actually have
sunglasses that you when you drop them
down you can see hidden Pathways that
you can see otherwise see that's
interesting so what I am excited about
is the gameplay opportunities that the
different Cappy abilities give you when
the level we played I got to play as
Bullet Bill and kind of he can move
around uh on one plane you can't go up
or down so it's like that's one like
gameplay element they got but then when
you take control of something else for
example it allows you to like fly a bit
or like swim a bit and I'm interested to
see what the dinosaur does and what all
these different things do and it's kind
of like a bunch of mini games within the
obvious like tried and true tight
platforming that Mario's known exactly
and that's that's part of the fun is too
is discovering what can C be control or
not control or capture for that matter
just kind ofate what are some cool
things that he can uh well we've seen
some of that's that's the trailer show
like the T-Rex the glomba the the Koop
you actually start throwing the frying
pan back and forth um and there's the
map actually as well she just brought up
a second ago actually I'm not sure where
Sarah's warping us too we'll find out
think fav part of her favorite part oh
back to the beginning back to the
beginning um so is there a hub world
like is there Peach's castle or
something equivalent well we really
haven't talked too much about what the H
world is going to be I know a lot of
people been asking that question um
we're not sure yet we haven't really
talked that a lot of people are assuming
it's going to be new don city but we
haven't really got into that detail yet
have to just wait till October okay
October 27th tell us now speaking of
like mini games and stuff I hear you
yeah so right yeah right here Mario took
threw a cab you took over a person you
captured one of the people and now you
have to control this little remote
controlled car to try to get to one of
that that Moon that's hidden over there
if Sarah can make it she can do it I
believe in her do it I believe I believe
here we go this it no almost there it is
there we go he's pretty stoked about
yeah I like those I like the mini games
that are hidden there's the or not
hidden but like littered around the
world or you were doing the jump rope
one earlier and I can totally see that
being like we only had minutes of a d we
could record it's like I want to see I
would love to have just done that for a
while like how how how many Mario jumps
can you do in this jump I've seen people
do actually Sarah herself has actually
done it before using the motorcycle oh
wow she's got got a couple jumps
actually on the motorcycle just jumping
up and down and that's something the
devs really want to discover as well is
that they have certain Solutions and
they want to see what other Solutions
people come up with when they start
trying to solve these problems so what's
going on here cuz this this is giving
some Galaxy Vibes she actually went into
the manhole she moved one of the holes
uh with the capture and then actually
now she went down it's this secret area
you discovered to try to find more Moon
shards to get another Moon
okay and using using Cappy you're able
to then throw throw cppy to actually
move the move different pieces and it's
cool too you can throw Cappy to to
actually stun the the piranha plants
yeah Chads yeah so what's Cappy's deal
what's his backstory we haven't revealed
C yet
basically all these things I actually
don't know the full story behind C we
haven't discovered yet it's easier to
play ignorant when I don't know all
these things yet so but no C is great
because it's a giv someone who Mario to
Adventure with on this Grand Odyssey of
his so well so speaking that like jokes
aside Mario not necessarily known for
story and all that stuff but I
appreciate in this game there seems to
be a lot of non-playable characters just
kind of like adding like what they have
to say but unlike 64 Sunshine where like
the Toads or the doino island people I
forgot their names um would uh be
talking to you and you have to just keep
hitting a to like get through it these
are just kind of prompts that pop up and
don't get in your way and again it's
like it's I felt like there was a lot of
momentum in this game and also the new
roll ability I really love the speed
that that gives the roll ability even
the Hat stalling with Cappy there's all
these everything you can do and explore
with cppy which is awesome to have a
chance to do but the story is
interesting with the fact that now it's
uh Bowser trying to marry Princess Peach
this time they have the whole wedding
outfit about time settled down it's
about time Mario's got the outfit too
but even Beyond there's also the new
enemies the brutal which is the that car
that you see on the Airship those kind
of the bunny things yeah those are
called the brutal so what's their deal
they're basically helping Bowser plan
his wedding a they're event planners yes
I can't hate on that no no like Jennifer
Lopez got to do it for love I get it
yeah yeah do what they can so what
what's something cool that we could see
here uh I'm not sure sharah we Sarah can
take us anywhere you want is there
anywhere you guys want her to take you
guys
uh I don't know go climb something go go
really high okay goes High let's get
Let's get high let's get to that tippy
top the tippy top
game just looks so good Tim oh it does
and the coolest thing so we get to play
this anywhere we want like that'ss my
mind like we're so used to these Mario
games being of this quality but on a
Home console but now it's
whoa there we
go I'm really excited to see uh the
later levels in this game because I love
the it the all the nods like the the
level this new dong City all this donkey
konges things going on like the
construction and stuff that's super cool
and all the the outfits that he wears
are Throwbacks to random old Mario
things whether it's Game Boy games like
golf or uh boxing and all that see
here's what I'm talking about with the
climbing situation you can climb up
there you go steps Little Steps right
there kind of climb up there it's hard
but I did it earlier ah see if here can
have you jumped rope with a motorcycle
no no but I jump try to thr jump pretty
well if I'm being honest he's trying
we'll see but yeah no that's not part of
part going as high as you can exploring
see what you can discover oh there she
goes oh no she jumped
off lining up there we go a it's okay
it's okay you got as high as you can
it's fine in that regard but yeah no
that's part of the fun I'm just really
just exploring this whole area there's
the Odyssey you can see off in the
distance oh cool Mario ship did you
actually get a chance to go inside the
Odyssey no we did for a second uh I
wasn't paying attention yeah which then
regie was next to me play arms I got
distracted
yeah uh we we left out to go buy a
somero yes cuz I really wanted the
somero that's what you do in this game
yeah exactly yes so the Soma the Poncho
all the Aesthetics even like the
Explorer outfit he had on as well is it
all aesthetic so far what all're showing
is about Aesthetics okay okay cool which
you have which it depends where you at
because like to get the Mexican Pon the
Poncho and the somera you have to get
the purple coins which are called
Regional coins that's the name of them
officially so yeah and you have to and
then you can use it to buy certain items
when you're over there so what are the
differences between the coins then cuz
I'm seeing you have 205 coins normally a
100 would get you a life what's going on
so far you so right now Sarah used the
coins actually to buy uh to buy to buy
this costume right here that that the
suit that Mario's wearing so it just
depends uh the coins can use for
different things to discover and right
now what she's doing right now is the
actual mission that you're on right now
is to help that drummer he doesn't have
a band yeah so you're helping find the
band members I get it I saw all all that
we've come to the end oh it's over yeah
that's how well yeah I mean Mario's even
happy Perfect music there you go you got
a moon that's how we end it uh thank you
so much for coming by thanks uh we
wanted to tell you of course that of
course I'm sure you knew your game's
awesome you're kind of funny improved E3
award there oh y thank you Mario Odyssey
very well deserved no thanks everybody
else who also help choose it when's it
coming out October 27th all right great
not too far off yeah we can't wait you
play anywhere you can play it on the
switch anywhere you're going or play it
lazily like two I play games pretty
lazily now with the switch spraw out no
I do all the time it's awesome with the
switch well Tim thanks for joining me
thank you for having me it's been a
pleasure to hang out it's been a
pleasure to hang out with all of you did
you have
fun ladies and gentlemen remember even
though this is the end of kind of funny
on the gam spot Co-op stage they will be
back tomorrow so go to twitch.tv/
Gamespot gamespot.com All That Jazz you
can catch us on youtube.com kindof
funnygames there's also youtube.com/ of
funny we just put up a video of us going
through our Sex Dungeon Airbnb you heard
that right go check that out uh but
thank you all for hanging out today
thank you in person for hanging out
today ladies and gentlemen this is E3
2017 and until next time it's been our
pleasure to serve
[Applause]
you